YOUR HERE AND WELCOME TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE. I'M GONNA COMMITTEE
WE HAVE THIRTEEN BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA TWELVE WITH
AUTHORS WHO WILL BE PRESENTING
HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE
WE DO HAVE ONE PROPOSED BILL
FOR CONSENT- AND THAT IS OUR
VICE CHAIRS BILL. ALL AUTHORS
WILL BE SET BE PRESENTING AGAIN
IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE.
GRAYSON JENNA COMMITTEE BEFORE
WE GET INTO SOME OF OUR
HOUSEKEEPING THIS MORNING WE'VE
GOT TO BE ABLE TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. MR NOW CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR MCGUIRE
HERE WIRE PRESIDENT SENATOR
NIELSEN. NIELSEN PRESIDENT
SENATOR DORADO HERE TORONTO
PRESIDENT SENATOR HERTZBERG.
SENATOR WIENER. WIENER PRESENT
FOR PLACE IN GERMANY QUORUM IS
BEEN ESTABLISHED WE'RE GONNA
CURRENTLY KEEP BILLS ON CALL TO
ALLOW THE MAJORITY LEADER TO BE
ABLE TO ADD ON WOULD LIKE TO BE
TO TAKE CARE OF SOME QUICK
HOUSEKEEPING ON HOW THE
COMMITTEE'S GONNA ROLL TODAY
THEN WE'D LIKE TO BE TO TAKE UP
OUR ONE ITEM CONSENT CALENDAR-
AND THEN WE'RE GOING TO TURN IT
OVER TO THE GOOD SENATOR FOR
MARANDA AND WE DO APOLOGIZE TO
EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU FOR-
WAITING WE'RE TRYING TO DO SOME
LAST MINUTE ISSUES ON ONE
SPECIFIC BILL TODAY. IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVER NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATE TORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS
AND IT HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES HERE IN COMMITTEE
TODAY IN COMPLIANCE THOSE
ORDERS THE SENATE IS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO OUR
NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AND OF
COURSE WE WELCOME ANY AND ALL
OF YOU TO BE TO PARTICIPATE
TODAY. TO ALLOW THAT PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC HERE TO ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE WE ALSO HAVE
A OVERFLOW ROOM THAT'S IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY- TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW INDIVIDUALS
TO BE TOGETHER IN THE TWO ROOMS
WE'RE ALSO GOING TO BE USING A
LIVE TELECONFERENCE OF HIS
TODAY FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WANTING TO BE A TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT WE WELCOME YOU
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING
FROM YOU TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER. IT'S TOLL FREE.
844-291-6364 THAT ACCESS CODE.
IS SEVEN THREE SIX. TWO EIGHT
TWO THAT NUMBER IS ON THE
SCREEN WE LOOK FORWARD HEARING
FROM EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU.
ONLY MOVE THE PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU'RE GONNA BE PROMPTED BY A
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE AND THEN
ZERO FOR SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION.
WE DO ASK FOLKS IF YOU ARE
CALLING IN TODAY TO PLEASE.
PRESS THE MUTE BUTTON ON YOUR
DEVICE- TO BE ABLE TO AVOID ANY
FEEDBACK. THANK YOU GENTLEMEN
IN THE UNLIKELY EVENT THAT
INDIVIDUAL BECOMES UNRULY AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR THE
COMMITTEE. OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MEETING. WHILE
EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINING PROCESS A
CONDUCTOR HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE
AS THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. MAYBE IF YOU LAG
TIMES- FOR PARTICIPANTS WE JUST
ASK FOR EACH AND EVERYONE OF
YOU TO BE ABLE TO HAVE SOME
PATIENCE. AND WE'RE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO GET THROUGH THIS
TOGETHER AND AGAIN WE LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING FROM YOU IF
YOU'D LIKE TO BE A DIALING TO
PROVIDE COMMENT TODAY. THAT
NUMBER IS. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR.
BUT WITH THE ACCESS CODE OF
SEVEN THREE SIX. TWO EIGHT
THREE TWO. PLEASE ENTER WE HAVE
A MOTION TO BE A TO TAKE UP OUR
ONE BILL CONSENT CALENDAR AND
THAT'S SB SEVEN NINE. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY CENTER DRAWS SO.
MISTER MISTER CONSULTANT CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. BUSH
MOVED TO ADOPT THE CONSENT
CALENDAR SENATOR MCGUIRE HI
WIRE HI SENATOR NIELSEN.
NIELSEN HI SENATOR DORADO.
TORONTO HI SENATOR HERTZBERG.
WIENER AYE WIENER OUR-
TICKETING COUNTER CURRENTLY
ENJOYS A FOUR ZERO VOTE WE'RE
GOING TO KEEP THE CONSENT
CALENDAR OPEN AND HAVE OUR
MAJORITY LEADER WHEN HE ARRIVES
AT TO BE ABLE TO ADD ON. AGAIN
I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
CENTER GLAZER FOR HIS PATIENTS
TODAY I ALSO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE GOOD SENATOR
FIRMER INTO FOR HIS WORK ON ALL
ISSUES OF. PUBLIC EDUCATION
WHETHER IT'S HIGHER RATE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE YOU SEE CSU
SYSTEM A VERY CRITICAL BOND
BILL THAT IS COMING FOR TODAY
MISTER SENATOR THE FLOOR IS
YOURS AND WE WELCOME YOU
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS FOR ALLOW ME
TO PRESENT THIS BILL SB TWENTY
TWO WOULD AUTHORIZE A FIFTEEN
BILLION DOLLAR BOND FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY TO BALLOT. FOR
FACILITIES FOR K. THROUGH
TWELVE THROUGH HIGHER EDUCATION
SPECIFICALLY THE BOND INCLUDES
NINE BILLION FOR PRESCHOOL
THROUGH GRADE TWELVE. AND TWO
BILLION H. FOR THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY. THE LAST K.
THROUGH TWELVE AND HIGHER
EDUCATION BOND PASSED IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX. HOWEVER BY TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE ALL THOSE FUNDS
WERE ESSENTIALLY EXHAUSTED.
THIS PART IS CRITICAL FOR
BRINGING ALL OF OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS. K. THROUGH TWELVE
THROUGH HIGHER EDUCATION INTO
THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY AND
ENSURING OUR CHILDREN OF CLEAN
DRINKING WATER AND SAFE PLACES
TO LEARN. THE PANDEMIC HAS
HIGHLIGHTED THE NEED FOR SAFE
SCHOOLS AND CAMPUS FACILITIES
TO PROTECT THE HEALTH OF
CHILDREN AND STAFF. CURRENTLY
MANY SCHOOLS DO NOT HAVE
SUFFICIENT BUILDING SPACE TO
COMPLY WITH FEDERAL AND STATE
RE OPENING. GUIDELINES ON
SMALLER CLASS SIZES. TO GET THE
CONSTRUCTION UP. AND- REPAIRS
ARE NEEDED TO CREATE LARGER
CLASSROOMS IMPROVE VENTILATION
SYSTEMS AND REDUCE THE RISK OF
TRANSMISSION AND SHARED SPACES.
ACCORDING TO THE PUBLIC POLICY
INSTITUTE ABOUT TWO THIRDS OF
THE STATE SCHOOL FACILITIES ARE
MORE THAN TWENTY FIVE YEARS
OLD. AND RESEARCH HAS SHOWN
THAT IT WOULD COST OVER A
HUNDRED SEVENTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS TO MODERNIZE SCHOOLS
AND COLLEGES IN THE NEXT
DECADE. WE NEED TO DO OUR BEST
TO HELP OUR STUDENTS WE DID
HAVE A DISAPPOINTING LOSS IN
THE MARCH TWENTY TWENTY
ELECTION BUT I WAS PLEASED TO
SEE THAT IN NOVEMBER VOTERS
APPROVED. SIXTY LOCAL SCHOOL
BOND MEASURES- ASSUMING THEY
DECIDED ON SIXTY THE APPROVED
80% OF THEM. THIS BILL BEFORE
YOU IS AN EXTENSION OF
COMPROMISES THAT WERE REACHED
LAST YEAR ON THE MEASURE THAT
WAS ON LAST YEAR'S BALLOT.
THERE ARE STILL CONVERSATIONS
GOING ON IN DISCUSSIONS WITH
LEADERSHIP IN THE GOVERNOR AND
STAKEHOLDERS- THIS BILL
ADVANCING TODAY WITH YOUR
APPROVAL. ALLOW THOSE
CONVERSATIONS TO CONTINUE IT
WOULD ALLOW THE SENATE TO STAND
UP FOR THE IMPORT IMPROVEMENTS
THAT WE ALL WANT TO SEE IN OUR
SCHOOLS AND OUR UNIVERSITY. I
WANNA DOLLARS THE CHAIR- WHO IS
A CO AUTHOR OF THIS MEASURE
THANK YOU. I THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THE
MEASURE TODAY I HAVE JASON
MURPHY FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA HERE TO TESTIFY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
SENATOR AGAIN NO B. S. REALLY
AND GRATEFUL FOR YOUR WORK ON
THIS AND CONTINUE TO ADVANCE
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR OUR K.
TWELVE AND SECONDARY SYSTEMS AS
WELL WE'RE GOING TO TURN IT
OVER TO OUR LEAD SUPPORT
WITNESS OF ISSUE TWENTY TWO.
THAT'S JASON MURPHY
REPRESENTING THIS UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA MISTER MURPHY YOU
ARE THREE MINUTES YOU'RE NOW IN
COMMITTEE PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS-
JAKE THE MURKY HERE ON BEHALF
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB TWENTY TWO AND-
AGAIN WANT THANK THE SENATOR
FOR BRINGING THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE. ALL WORDPRESS
DISCUSSED TODAY. CLEARLY THE
UNIVERSITY FITNESS EVENT AGAIN
LONG TERM CAPITAL NEEDS. OVER
HALF OF OUR FACILITIES ARE OVER
THIRTY YEARS OLD- OUR TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY SIX. APPLE
PLANS TO PLANT IN A FIVE TWENTY
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS. IN
UNFUNDED CAPITAL AND DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE NEEDS. OVER THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS WITHIN THE
UNIVERSITY. OF THIS AMOUNT.
TWENTY ONE BILLION. IS THE VET.
AT STAY SUPPORT. EDUCATION AND
GENERAL FACILITY PROJECT. THE
FUNDING PROVIDED BY A FEW
TWENTY TWO WOULD GREATLY AFFECT
THE UNIVERSITY IN DEVELOPING
THESE UNFUNDED PROJECTS THAT
WILL FOCUS ON ACCOMMODATING
ENROLLMENT GROWTH. AND RENEWAL
OF EXISTING FACILITIES
INCLUDING SEISMIC CORRECTIONS.
IN CLOSING I WOULD JUST NOTE-
BUT A REFERENCE ON PAGE FIVE
TWO- THE LEASE. REVENUE OR I'M
SORRY THE REVENUE BOND ACROSS
THE DIVERSITY DOES HAVE ADDED
OPTION TO UTILIZE THIS WAS
PROVIDED- BACK IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN. AS A RESULT OF AB
NINETY FOUR. WE WOULD JUST NOTE
THAT THE WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE HAVING THE AB DAY
FOR PROFIT. AVAILABLE FOR US TO
UTILIZE THE PHANTOM PROJECTS
BUT WE WOULD NOTE. AB EIGHT BB
NINE CORPORATE THIS WILL NEVER
ALLOW US. TO STAY ON TRACK OR
KEEP UP WITH OUR OVERALL NEEDS
AND SO THEREFORE WE CONTINUE TO
BELIEVE THAT- WE HAVE THE
OPTION AND- INTERESTED IN
PARTICIPATING IN ONGOING STATE
BOND ISSUES SO THAT ALL CLOSED
AGAIN TIS STATE THANK YOU. TO
THE AUTHOR AND- REITERATE. OUR
STRONG SUPPORT BIRTH TO TWENTY
TWO. THANK SO MUCH WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL- MISTER. WE ARE NOW
GOING TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WHO WOULD
LIKE TO BE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
IN. ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE.
ERNESTINE AND WE'RE NOT GONNA
BE GOING TO OUR OVERFLOW ROOM
TO PAY TO SEE PLAY OF ANY
INDIVIDUALS WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB TWENTY
TWO. HEARING SEEN I KNOW WE'RE
NOT GONNA BE GOING TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE. LAYS IN
GERMAN WE'RE GONNA ASK YOU TO
PLEASE PREPARE TO BE A TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB TWENTY TWO
AND- TWENTY TWO. NOT A
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE
QUEUE UP ALL INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE PREPARED TO SPEAK. IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWENTY TWO NOW.
THANK YOU IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF SB TWENTY TWO YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE WILL GO
TO LINE OF THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. NOT NOT ONLY STILL
PLACE. OKAY THANK YOU EXTRALITE
OF THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU- ERR BAKU THE
CALIFORNIA STATES- CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE PLEASE OFF OUR SUPPORT-
SENATE BILL TWENTY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WILL LINE. THE
LINE OF THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU SURE MEMBERS
MARK MCDONALD MGI ADVOCATE ON
BEHALF OF KERN SAN FRANCISCO
PERALTA SAMPOERNA DINO AND YUBA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS.
WERE ACTUALLY SUPPORT IF THE
MANDATE FOR A MORE EQUITABLE
DISTRIBUTION OF THE HIGHER AT
BONDS WE HAVE A LETTER ON FILE
WITH THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU WILL A LINE
OF FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE OF OPEN.
I SUGGESTING I WROTE THE BOOK
ON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP AND
WE ARE PROUD TO SUPPORT THE
BILL THANK YOU THANKS JUSTIN
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF FORTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
SHARON MEMBERS THAT ON THE
HELPER WILL BRING TO FUTURE A-
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PHONE CALL
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER. I
DON'T GO FROM OUR LINE FORTY
ONE. YOUR LINES OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON JENNIFER BAKER ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FACILITY COALITION AT THE
CORNER COMMENDED THANKS SO MUCH
JENNIFER OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU OF A LINE OF FORTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING THEIR MEMBERSHIP IN THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE WE ALSO
HAVE THE SUPPORT OF PREVENTIVE
POSITION. WE ARE SEEKING
AMENDMENTS TO ENSURE THAT
COMMUNITY COLLEGES YOU SEE THAT
GLOBAL SHARE OF BOX. THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PHONE CALL TODAY LET'S GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR JUST A REMINDER IT
IS S. B. TWENTY TWO IN SUPPORT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THENZERO.
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORT IN Q. BETTER MODERATOR
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE NOT
GONNA BE GOING TO THOSE WHO MAY
BE OPPOSE. CURRENTLY WE DO NOT
HAVE A LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS-
ON RECORD SO WE'RE GONNA A SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE. MA'AM I'M
GOING TO ASK YOU WERE YOU
WELCOME YOUR TESTIMONY SO. WE
WELCOME YOUR TESTIMONY IN YEAH
AND SO WHAT WE'RE- SO WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO IS WE'RE GONNA
WELCOME THAT. ANYONE WHO IS IN
OPPOSITION OF SB TWENTY TWO TO
BE ABLE TO PLEASE COME UP TO
THIS MIKE RIGHT NOW IF ANYONE
IS IN OPPOSITION OF SB TWENTY
TWO HERE ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE. YES MA'AM PLEASE COME
RIGHT UP. YEAH YOU'RE GOOD HE
SAID IT WILL BE AND I'LL BE
HAPPY THE- IN OPPOSITION.
MEMBER GONNA GIVE YOU A YOU CAN
HAVE THREE MINUTES JUST LIKE-
WHAT OUR LEAD- PROPONENT HAD SO
YOU HAVE THREE MINUTES TO
MINUTES. YOU MEAN I GET TO SEE
MORE THAN MY NAME. BOB WHERE
YOU LIVE IN THE UNITED. STATES
AND JUST NOW THE CLOCK IS
MOVING TO MA'AM IN THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. LAST YOU KNOW SENATORS.
IT LEAD OPPOSITION SO IF YEAH
I'M STANDING HERE. REALLY
WONDERING HOW IN THE WORLD USED
CALIFORNIANS. SPEND. FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS. OPERATE HIGHER
EDUCATION CAMPUS. YOU
DEDICATION ONLINE MY DAUGHTER
IS TAKING CLASSES THROUGH
SIERRA COLLEGE IT'S ALL VIRTUAL.
AND YOU WANT TO USE FIFTEEN
MILLION OF CALIFORNIA'S DOLLARS
TO MAKE UPGRADES TO AN ONLINE
EDUCATION SYSTEM. THIS IS A
LITTLE STRANGE TO ME. I MEAN
THE CHILDREN STILL DON'T HAVE
SCHOOL. BUT THIS IS ABOUT
HIGHER EDUCATION RIGHT BECAUSE
I'M JUST TALKING OFF THE FLOOR
HEY MIKE MCGUIRE. A BOND. A
BOND YOU WANT CALIFORNIANS TO
PAY MORE MONEY FOR THINGS THAT
THEY'RE ALREADY NOT GETTING. SO
WHAT SO WHAT IF THE BUILDINGS
ARE SEVENTY FIVE YEARS OLD.
YOU'RE NOT LETTING PEOPLE INTO
THE BUILDINGS ANYWAY. YOUR
FARMER TECHNOCRACY IS SHOWING
MIKE MCGUIRE. YOU WANT ME ONE
MINUTE LEFT WHAT SHOULD I DO
ROLLER SKATE TAP DANCE. THAT'S
WHAT THAT'S WHAT MCCARTY GIVES
ME IF I'M ENTERTAINING ENOUGH
TO GIVE ME MORE TIME AWAY
THAT'S TE ASSEMBLY AND THEY
DIDN'T LET ME IN TODAY NO THEY
LET ME IN. AND THEY DIDN'T
ARREST ME. AND THEN THEY KICKED
ME OUT AND SO I COULDN'T COME
BACK SOMETIME IN THE SENATE SO
WHAT ARE THE RULES AROUND HERE
MIKE MCGUIRE BECAUSE THEY SEEM
TO CHANGE BUT I CAN PROMISE YOU
CALIFORNIANS WON'T PUT UP WITH
THIS. THEY WON'T. FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS YOU WANT MORE
MONEY THANK YOU SO MUCH IN YOUR
THREE MINUTES ARE UP
APPRECIATED THANK YOU FOR BEING
WITH US TODAY WE'RE NOT GONNA
BE GOING TO ANY IDEATIONAL
OPPOSITION WITNESSES IN OUR
OVERFLOW ROOM LET'S GO TO OUR
OVERFLOW ROOM PLEASE AND SEE IF
WE HAVE ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION WE NOT
SEE ANYONE THERE ARE NOT GONNA
BE GOING TOWARD TELECONFERENCE
LINE THAT A MODERATOR WE'RE
LOOKING FOR THOSE WHO MAY BE
OPPOSED TO SB TWENTY TWO. ON
THE TELECONFERENCE LINE IF YOU
CAN PLEASE. TO THEM UP. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR OPPOSITION OF SB
TWENTY TWO YOU MAY PRESS THE
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE OF FORTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE COURT ABOUT
THE B. TWENTY TWO THERE WERE
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES EARLIER
OUR APOLOGIES. ON BEHALF OF THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
SCHOOL FROM THE TWENTY THREE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SCHOOL
DISTRICT SUPERINTENDENT AND
SUPPORT OF SB TWENTY TWO YEAR
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
PLEASE THANK A SUPERINTENDENT
TO- IT WE ARE LOOKING FOR THOSE
WHO ARE OPPOSED SB TWENTY TWO
FREE OF ANY OVERFLOW FROM OUR-
SUPPORT WILL. WELCOME THOSE AS
WELL- MADAME MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU KNOW
COME FROM LINE FIFTY YOUR LINE
AS- MY FIFTY FOUR DROP SO WE'LL
GO TO LINE OF THIRTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS RICHARD
MARX AND FOR THE WESTERN
ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION. THE PLUMBING
HEATING COOLING CONTRACTORS OF
CALIFORNIA- WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THE MEASURE BECAUSE OF THE P.
L. A. LANGUAGE IN SECTION
TWELVE. WE THINK THIS
CONTRIBUTED TO THE FAILURE OF
PROP THIRTEEN WE'RE VERY
DISAPPOINTED THAT IT'S INCLUDED
IN THIS MEASURE AS WELL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SIR. WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PHONE CALL
TODAY THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THAT LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE AND MODERATOR.
THANK YOU WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. ALL RIGHT HERE IN THAT WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. WE'RE
GONNA TURN IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
SEE IF THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE WILL
ALSO WELCOME A MOTION AS WELL
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE OUR MOTION. ALL RIGHT
I THINK YOU GUYS CENTER DRAWS
EMOTION. YES MY MOOD THANK YOU
SO MUCH THAT IS A MOTION THE
MOTION IS A DO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS THAT CENTER
GLAZER WOULD YOU LIKE TO BE A
CLOSE PLEASE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY. THANK YOU SO
MUCH THE MOTION BY SENATOR
RISES A DO PASS APPROPRIATIONS
MISTER NOW CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL BUSH IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR MCGUIRE HI WIRE ARE YOU
SENATOR NIELSEN. NIELSEN RA
SENATOR DORADO. ZERO ZERO
SENATOR HERTZBERG. SENATOR
WIENER. WIENER I FORTY ZERO
FOUR ZERO VOTE THAT MAIL IS ON
CALL I THINK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
SENATOR WE'RE GRATEFUL- WE ARE
HONORED TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
CENTER MELENDEZ WITH US THAT
WE'RE GOING TO DO A BIT OF
DISINFECTED AND WE'RE GOING TO
WELCOME THE GOOD SENATOR TO BE
OUT OF PRISON SB THREE NINETEEN
SB THREE NINETEEN IN AS ALWAYS
WE WELCOME THE GOOD SENATOR TO
COMMITTEE. BERMAN CENTER THE
FLOOR'S YOURS OUT WHEN YOUR
PREPARE. I WANT TO REVOKE. HE
NEEDS TO BE GOVERNOR. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THE GOVERNOR. ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GONNA GET A CENTER
MELENDEZ MICRON. THERE WE GO
PLEASE THERE WE GO OKAY THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE FOR ALLOW ME
TO PRESENT THIS BILL TO YOU
TODAY. I AM HERE TO PRESENT SB
THREE NINETEEN WHICH IS
SPONSORED BY THE DESERT VALLEY
BUILDERS ASSOCIATION THIS
MEASURE WILL MAKE A SIMPLE
CHANGE TO THE MITIGATION FEE
ACT BY CLOSING A LOOPHOLE
RELATED TO ANNUAL REPORTS
CURRENTLY IS ALLIES WRITTEN IN
AGENCIES OBLIGATED TO PROVIDE
ANNUAL REPORTS IDENTIFYING
REVENUES COLLECTED AN EXPANDED
IN THE SPECIFIC USE OF THOSE
FUNDS. SHOULD THE AGENCY FAILED
TO PROVIDE SUCH REPORTS FOR AT
LEAST THREE CONSECUTIVE YEARS
THE PUBLIC OR PRIVATE ENTITY
MAY REQUEST AN AUDIT OF THOSE
FUNDS- ACCOUNTS FOR THE
AGENCIES EXPENSE UNFORTUNATELY
THE SCOPE OF AN AUDIT IS NOT
DEFINED INTERPRETATION BY A
LOCAL AGENCY COULD LIMIT THE
AUDIT TO ONE YEAR OR THREE.
HOWEVER IT IS LIKELY THAT THE
SUBJECT AGENCY HAS FAILED TO
COMPLY FOR FIVE OR MORE YEARS
BEFORE FORMAL AUDIT OF THESE
FUNDS IS REQUESTED SB THREE
NINETEEN SIX TO FIX THIS BY
REQUIRING AN ENTITY AUDIT EACH
YEAR THE AGENCY FAILED TO
PROVIDE ANNUAL REPORTS. THIS
SIMPLE CHANGE WILL INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY AND ENSURE THE
GENERAL PUBLIC INDOOR BUILDERS
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW
IN QUESTION NEW OR ADJUSTED
FEES JOINING ME TO REMOTELY
TEST BY IS GRETCHEN GETS HERE
IS THE CEO OF DESERT VALLEY
BUILDERS ASSOCIATION THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND I ASK FOR
YOUR I. ABOUT THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER MONDAYS WERE GREAT FOR
THE CENTER FOR WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE ON THIS BILL WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO OUR SUPPORT
WITNESSES ARE TO LEAD SUPPORT
WITNESSES. LET'S START WITH
THIS GOOD YEAR IS SET FROM THE
DESERT VALLEYS BUILDERS
ASSOCIATION IT'S GOOD TO HEAR
AND SEE THE FLOOR IS YOURS YOU.
ARE NOW IN COMMITTEE YOUR THREE
MINUTES. GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
STAFF HAS INTRODUCED MY NAME IS
GRETCHEN GUTIERREZ CEO OF THE
DESERT VALLEYS BUILDERS
ASSOCIATION. THE BBVA PROVIDES
LEGISLATIVE AND GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS ADVOCACY THROUGHOUT
EASTERN RIVERSIDE AND IMPERIAL
COUNTIES. ARE SENSATION SERVES
NEARLY TWO HUNDRED MEMBERS OF
THE CONSTRUCTION AND
HOMEBUILDING INDUSTRIES. I'M
LEGISLATIVE REVIEW AND
ASSISTANCE IN THOSE AREAS
IMPACTING THE ABILITY TO
PROVIDE HOUSING THROUGHOUT THE
REGION. ONE OF THOSE AREAS IS
THOSE FEES COLLECTED UNDER THE
MITIGATION FEE ACT. THE ACT WAS
INSTITUTED TO PROVIDE THE
NECESSARY INFRASTRUCTURE AND
SERVICES FOR NEW RESIDENTIAL
COMMERCIAL AND INDUSTRIAL
CONSTRUCTION. WITHOUT BECOMING
A BURDEN OR REDUCING THE
EXISTING LEVEL OF SERVICE TO
THE CURRENT POPULATION WITHIN A
COMMUNITY. CURRENTLY THERE ARE
ONLY THREE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THE GENERAL PUBLIC OR BUILDERS
PREVIEW IN QUESTION NEW OR
INCREASED IMPACT FEES. DURING
THE INITIAL NEXUS STUDY
ESTABLISHING SUPPORT FOR THE
FEE STRUCTURE. DURING THE
ADOPTION OF A CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENT PLAN WHICH MAY BE
ADOPTED DURING THE ANNUAL
BUDGET BUT COULD ALSO BE
AMENDED OR ADOPTED IT ANYTIME
BY THE GOVERNING AGENCY. OR
DURING THE REVIEW OF THE ANNUAL
SIXTEEN HUNDRED REPORT PROCESS
FOLLOWING GOVERNMENT CODE
SECTIONS SIXTY SIX. OH SIX AND
SIXTY SIX OH OH ONE. THEIR
ANNUAL AND FIVE YEAR REPORT.
THE GENERAL PUBLIC AND INDUSTRY
ARE GENERALLY UNAWARE OF THE
ADOPTIONS. OF CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENT PLANS. THIS- THEN
PROVIDES. THE TROOPER TO AND
QUESTION HOW THE AGENCY IS
COLLECTING AND DISPERSING THOSE
MITIGATION FUNDS TO THE ANNUAL
REPORT. THEY'RE CURRENTLY NO
RAMIFICATIONS FOR LOCAL
AGENCIES FAILING TO PROVIDE
THOSE IN REPORTS. WITHIN THE
SPONSORS REGION MORE THAN 20%
OF THE AGENCIES ARE REGULARLY
FAILING TO PROVIDE THESE AND
REPORTS. THE REMAINING 80% OF
AGENCIES TWO THIRDS OF THEM
CURRENTLY USE THESE FUNDS
INAPPROPRIATELY. UNDER SENATE
BILL TWELVE OH TWO SENATOR
STONE SIGNED BY GOVERNOR BROWN
IN SEPTEMBER TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
ACTION MAKES THE- EIGHT
AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC TO FROM
THE COLLECTING LOCAL AGENCY
RESPONSIBLE FOR ACCURATE
REPORTING SHOULD THE AGENCY
FAILED TO PROVIDE AN ANNUAL
REPORT FOR THREE CONSECUTIVE
YEARS THE GENERAL PUBLIC OR A
BUILDER MAY REQUEST AN AUDIT OF
THOSE MITIGATION FEE ACCOUNTS
THE BURDEN OF THE COST OF THE
AUDIT WILL BE BORNE BY THE
LOCAL AGENCY SB TWELVE OH TWO
DID NOT DEFINE THE PARAMETERS
OF THE AUDIT FOR WHICH THE
FUNDS WOULD BE REVIEWED. SB
THREE NINETEEN WHAT ESTABLISHED
THAT FOR EACH CONSECUTIVE YEAR
THAT THE AGENCY IN QUESTION
FAILED TO PROVIDE THE ANNUAL
REPORT AS REQUIRED PURSUANT TO
THE MITIGATION FEE ACT THAT
YOUR WOULD BE AUDITED THEREBY
ESTABLISHING A CONTRACT A
CONSECUTIVE PATTERN OF
REPORTING WE THANK CENTER
MELENDEZ FOR INTRODUCING THIS
BILL LEGISLATION AND WE URGE
YOU TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO AND
I VOTER SUPPORT FOR SB THREE
NINETEEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
REALLY APPRECIATE IT IS GOOD
HERE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
JOINING COMMITTEE WERE NOT
GOING TO BE ABLE TO CHECK IN
FOR THOSE WHO MAY BE OPPOSED TO
THIS. BILL WE'RE GOING TO SEE
IF WE HAVE ANYONE OPPOSE HERE
IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE. KERN
SEEN AND WE'RE NOT GONNA GOING
TO OUR OVERFLOW RUMORED CHECK
OVERFLOW ROOM TO SEE IF ANYONE
IS OPPOSED. HEARINGS HE KNOWN
IN THE OVERFLOW ROOM. WE I'M
SORRY I SAID OPPOSED. IN
SUPPORT I APOLOGIZE IN SUPPORT.
I AM SO SORRY. THAT WE DO HAVE
AN INDIVIDUAL WHO IS IN
SUPPORT. MA'AM YOU'RE GOING TO
BE ABLE TO STATE YOUR FIRST AND
LAST NAME. ALONG WITH YOUR
AFFILIATION IF YOU LIKE. PLEASE
THE FLOOR IS YOURS MA'AM. BUT
IT'S JUST. NO WE HAD A LEADS
FOR WITNESS- I SEE HOW THIS.
OKAY SO MY NAME AND MY
AFFILIATION. MY NAME IS ANDREA
HAD STRUM. MY AFFILIATION IS A
MOTHER OF FOUR LIVING IN
COMMUNISM ON LOCKDOWN JUNIOR IN
YOUR POSITION. MELENDEZ
ANYTHING SHE DOES MELENDEZ FOR
GOVERNOR AND NIELSEN IF YOU
WANT TO TALK ON THE IN THE ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE
GRATEFUL APPRECIATE THAT WE'RE
NOT GOING TO BE GOING TO AGAIN
OUR OVERFLOW ROOM BECAUSE I
SAID OPPOSITION I MEANT TO SAY
AT SUPPORT SO LET'S GO TO THOSE
IN OUR OVERFLOW ROOM- IT WE
HAVE NO ONE IN. SUPPORT WE'RE
NOW GOING TO BE GOING TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE WE'RE GONNA
CHECK IN WITH OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE- IN ASK
MADAME MODERATOR IF WE CAN
PLEASE ASK ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
NINETEEN TO PLEASE CHIME IN
NAPA YOU WANTED YOURSELF. MADAM
MODERATOR. THANK YOU IF YOU
AREN'T SUPPORT. YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR SB THREE
NINETEEN. ONE AND THEN ZERO. IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
NINETEEN. AND ONE MOMENT THERE
ARE FEW QUEUING UP. AND WE WILL
GO TO THAT LINE AND THAT LINE
OF LINE TWENTY. THIRTY ONE.
MIGHT STILL BE ON. PINE TWENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER MEMBERS MICHAEL GETTING
HIT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB THREE
NINETEEN AND THANK SENATOR
MELENDEZ FOR SOMEONE TO BRING
THE BILL UP. THANK YOU SO MUCH
IS GOING TO OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR
WE HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORT
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. ALL
RIGHT LAYS IN GERMAN WE'RE NOT
GONNA GO TO THOSE WHO MAY BE
OPPOSE WE'RE GONNA START HERE
ROOM FORTY TWO IN THREE THAT
CHECK TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION OF SB THREE
NINETEEN. HEARING IN SEEN NO
AND WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO
OUR OVERFLOW ROOM IN TWENTY
FOUR OH FOUR HEARING SEEN NINE.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO GO TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE. THAT WE'RE
GONNA ASK MADAME MODERATOR TO
BE TO QUEUE UP ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS IN OPPOSITION. TO THE SP.
THREE NINETEEN MATTER MODERATOR
PLEASE DO SO NOW. THANK YOU IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION OF SB
THREE NINETEEN. YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO NOW. ONE AND
THEN ZERO ZERO IN OPPOSITION OF
SB. THREE NINETEEN. MISTER
CHAIR I SEE NO NO ONE IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME FOR OPPOSITION ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GONNA BRING HIM
BACK TO COMMITTEE THANK YOU
MADAM MODERATE APPRECIATION
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK TO HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS UP FOR A
CEREMONIES PLEASE CENTER WIENER.
BUT WE HAVE A MOTION WITH A
MOTION NOBODY SENATOR WIENER
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. SEVENTY NINE CENTER
MELINDA'S IF YOU'D LIKE TO
CLOSE PLEASE I THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK
YOU AGAIN CENTER MELINDA THREE
WORK ON THIS. IMPORTANT ISSUE
AND FOR WORKING WITH US AS
WELL. MR NOW CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL AND PROVIDE THE
MOTION. MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR SENATOR
MCGUIRE HI WIRE. SENATOR
NIELSEN. SENATOR DO ALSO. DRAWS
OH FIVE SENATOR HERTZBERG.
SENATOR WIENER WIENER HI THREE
TWO ZERO ALL RIGHT IT'S A THREE
ZERO VOTE THAT CINNAMON IS
WE'RE GONNA KEEP THE ROLE OPEN
IF IT WORKS FOR YOU TO BE ABLE
TO ADD ON OUR VICE CHAIR AS
WELL AS MAJORITY LEADER THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
MEMBERS ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO
MUCH VERY GRATEFUL CENTER
MELENDEZ ALRIGHT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF COMMITTEE FOR
MOVING RIGHT ALONG WE'RE NOW
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER FOR
ITEM NUMBER FOUR IS AN ISSUE
THAT I DISCARDED THE MOMENT SAY
THAT CENTER GONZALEZ HAS BEEN
WORKING ON. FOR QUITE SOME
TIME- AND THAT'S THE ISSUE OF
BROADBAND AND I JUST WANNA TAKE
A MOMENT TO RECOGNIZE THE GOOD
SENATOR FROM LONG BEACH FOR ALL
OF HER WORK ON BROADBAND
DEPLOYMENT AND IT'S BECOME EVEN
MORE ACUTE ISSUE DURING THE
PANDEMIC SHE DOES HAVE A BILL
IN FRONT OF US TODAY SB THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT NOW THAT SHE'S
BEEN WORKING ON A MEANS IS
WELL- MADAM SENATOR ICING
YOU'RE GONNA BE TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS IN COMMITTEE TODAY
YES MISTER CHAIR I WELL ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH- ON
ITEM IS THREE SEVENTY EIGHT THE
FLOOR IS YOURS AND AGAIN THAT
AND SENATOR. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TEENAGERS WORK ON THIS CRITICAL
SUBJECT THANK YOU I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS- I'M HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT SB THREE SEVENTY EIGHT
IT'S IMPORTANT MEASURE IS A KEY
COMPONENT TO CLOSING THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE BY PROVIDING
CLARITY INTERNET SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ON BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE
DEPLOYMENT METHODS SB THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT WILL HELP PROMOTE
THE DEPLOYMENT OF BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE AND INTERNET
CONNECTIVITY FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS BY REQUIRING LOCAL
JUST RESTRICTIONS TO ALLOW
FIBER CABLES TO BE INSTALLED
USING COST EFFECTIVE TECHNIQUES
INCLUDING OPEN TRENCHING BORING
AND MICRO TRENCHING. THE BILL
WILL CREATE A BEST PRACTICES
STANDARDS BY DEPLOYING
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
LOCAL PLANNING AGENCIES MUST
FOLLOW WHEN THE ENTITY SIX TO
THE PLAY BROWN BAD IN THE
BROADBAND IN THEIR COMMUNITY
CURRENTLY EVERY JURISDICTION IN
CALIFORNIA HAS DIFFERENT FIVE
PER INSTALLMENT REQUIREMENTS
WHICH OFTEN CAUSES A MAJOR TO
TIME DELAY AND BROADBAND
PROJECT APPROVAL AND DEPLOYMENT
MAY NOT BE MET THIS IS
UNACCEPTABLE WITH US ESPECIALLY.
AS BROADBAND IS ESSENTIAL IN
OUR CALIFORNIA CAN UNITIES. THE
AND- TODAY WE HAVE DANCE.
DIRECTOR GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
WITH CROWN. AND LAREAU MOON
JOOSS GENERAL COUNSEL WITH THE
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP
GROUP. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
FOR THE TIME TO PRESENT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON SB THREE SEVENTY EIGHT
THANK YOU SO MUCH READING
SENATOR IN BEFORE WE GO TO LEAD
WITNESSES I WANT TO CALL THE
COMMITTEE'S ATTENTION CALL THE
COMMITTEE'S ATTENTION TO THE-
SPECIFIC. AMENDMENTS IT'S BEEN
PASSED OUT. TO EACH AND
EVERYONE OF THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS IF YOU COULD PLEASE
PROVIDE- THE AUTHOR IS WELL I
COPY THE MINUTE SHE SAYS SHE
HAS SAT IN FRONT OF HER IS WELL
WE'VE GREATLY APPRECIATE THAT.
LET'S GO TO OUR LEAD WITNESSES.
ARE LEAD WITNESSES WHAT
HAPPENED THREE MINUTES EACH
WE'RE GONNA START WITH DAN
TRIED SIR DIRECTOR GOVERNMENT-AFFAIRS FOR GRAND CASTLE DAN.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS YOU HAVE
THREE MINUTES. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF MY NAME IS
DAN SWEITZER DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR CROWN
CASTLE. WE'RE PROUD TO SPONSOR
US FEATURES OF NEW BECAUSE IT
WILL ALLOW BROADBAND PROJECTS
IN THE STATE TO BE BUILT
QUICKER WHILE THE SAME TIME
REDUCING CONSTRUCTION IMPACTS
IN COMMUNITIES. THE BILL
ANSWERS WITH THE INDUSTRY'S
BEST PRACTICES OF MICRO
TRENCHING ALLOWED BY LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO INSTALL HIGH
SPEED INTERNET FIBER CABLES
UNDERGROUND. MY PROJECTION
TECHNOLOGY CUTS EIGHTY TWO INCH
WIDE A MONTHLY SIXTEEN INCH
DEEP TRENCH TO WEIGH THE FIBER
UNDERGROUND. WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY BACK FILLING AND
SEALING THE ENTIRE PROCESS
TAKES HOURS THANK KARSTEN DRIVE
ON THE ROADS IN THE SAME DAY.
MICHAEL JOHNSON IS TYPICALLY
60% CHEAPER AND 80% QUICKER
THAN TRADITIONAL OPEN TRENCH ST
EXCAVATIONS WHICH CREE LANE
CLOSURES AND NEGATIVELY IMPACT
NEIGHBORHOODS. PSYCHOLOGY IS
BEING USED ENTITIES AROUND THE
COUNTRY AND HAS BEEN
SUCCESSFULLY DEPLOYED IN LOS
ANGELES FOR OVER THIRTY MILES
OF FIBER HAVE BEEN INSTALLED IN
RECENT MONTHS USING THIS
TECHNIQUE. NO NECESSARY BECAUSE
MANY LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ARE
HESITANT TO UTILIZE THIS NEWER
TECHNOLOGY THAT CITY STAFF ARE
USED TO BE OLDER MORE
DISRUPTIVE METHOD OF OPEN
TRENCHING. MY PROTECTION
COMPLIES WITH ALL UTILITY
SAFETY RULES AND GOES FURTHER
BY USING GROUND PENETRATING
RADAR PRIOR TO INSTALLATION.
FASTER INSTALLATION OF FIBER
MEANS COMMUNITIES AROUND THE
STATE CAN GET CONNECTED TO HIGH
SPEED INTERNET. IN DAYS INSTEAD
OF MONTHS. THIS WILL ALSO
COMPLEMENT THE STATE'S EFFORTS
TO PROVIDE MORE FUNDING FOR
BROADBAND BY ENSURING THAT
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE DOLLARS OR
MAXIMIZE THE BENEFIT RESIDENTS
AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. WE
COMMEND THE AUTHOR AND THE
CHAIR FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
IMPORTANT BILL AND ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS. THANK YOU. I DAN
THANK YOU SO MUCH AT LEAST IN
GENERAL NOW GONNA BE GOING TO
OUR NEXT LEAD WITNESSES THIS IS
GONNA BE OUR FINAL IT'S P. THE
ROW. MINNOWS WHO'S A GENERAL
COUNSEL AND SENIOR VICE
PRESIDENT TECH AND INNOVATION
AT THE SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP PETE THE FLOOR
IS YOURS YOU HAVE THREE MINUTES
AND I'LL GIVE YOU THIRTY SECOND
PROMPT. THANK YOU SO MUCH THE
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP
IS CMMITTED TO BROADBAND
EXPANSION CALIFORNIA BECAUSE IT
WILL BENEFIT ALL SECTORS OF THE
ECONOMY INCLUDING EDUCATION.
TELEHEALTH EMERGENCY RESPONSE.
AGRICULTURE AND INNOVATION. WE
SUPPORT SB THREE SEVENTY EIGHT
BECAUSE IT ENSURES THAT THE
INDUSTRY BEST PRACTICE OF MICRO
TRENCHING. IT IS USED TO
QUICKLY INSTALL FIBER FOR HIGH
SPEED INTERNET PROJECTS. THIS
BILL WILL HAVE AN IMMEDIATE
MEANINGFUL IMPACT. BY ALLOWING
FIBER CAN BE INSTALLED IN HOURS
INSTEAD OF WEEKS. AND EQUALLY
AS IMPORTANT IT'S LESS
DISRUPTIVE ON OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS. BY TWO INCH
WIDE. BY TWO FOOT DEEP
PRECISION FIBER INSTALLATION
THANK YOU CAN BE COMPLETED IN
THE SAME DAY. IS MUCH BETTER
THAN TRADITIONAL OPEN
TRENCHING. WHICH TEARS UP
STREETS AND CLOSES LANES OF
TRAFFIC FOR WEEKS. LEADERSHIP
GROUP SUPPORTS FUNDING AND
STREAMLINING TO HELP ACCELERATE
BROADBAND DEPLOYMENT. THIS BILL
WILL MAKE SURE THAT STATE AND
FEDERAL BROADBAND FUNDING WILL
BENEFIT LOCAL COMMUNITIES. AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE WHICH HAS
NEVER BEEN MORE IMPORTANT. THAN
DURING THE CURRENT CRISIS WE
FACE. AND GOING FORWARD. WE
URGE YOUR FIVE VOTE FROM THE
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP.
GROUP THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US HERE TODAY
ALL RIGHT RAISING GERMAN WE'RE
GOING TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT OF THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE. ENCINO AND
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE GOING TO
THAT LONELY OVERFLOW ROOM LAYS
IN GERMAN THERE IS NO ONE.
READY TO ROLL ON SB THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT. SO WE'RE GONNA
GO TO OUR PHONE LINES ARE GONNA
ASK THE MODERATOR TO PLEASE
QUEUE UP PLEASE QUEUE UP. ALL
THOSE IN SUPPORT OF THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT MADAME MODERATOR
THE FLOOR'S YOURS. THANK YOU IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT MY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. WE WILL GO TO LINE
OF FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SHARE AGO HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE THANK YOU IT'S GOOD TO
HEAR VOICE ERICA THANK YOU SO
MUCH SIS GOT OUR NEXT CALLER.
THANK YOU WILL GO TO LINE OF
FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PINE
FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU WILL
GO TO LINE OF TWENTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WHY. TWENTY GERMAN
MICHAEL GETTING HERE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH
MICHAEL NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU WITH A LINE OF SIXTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS ROCKSTAND
GOLD ON BEHALF OF THE WIRELESS
INFRASTRUCTURE ASSOCIATION
IMPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY NEXT CALL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
NO FURTHER SUPPORT IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME FOR THE PRE SHOULD
MATTER MODERATOR WE'RE NOT
GOING TO GO TO THOSE WHO MAY BE
IN OPPOSITION TO SB THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT. WE DO HAVE A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION THAT'S AT THEIR
ADVOCATE MIKE ROBESON AND WHO
IS GOING TO BE ON THE LINE MIKE
YOU HAVE THREE MINUTES ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION. SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION OR ONE LEAD WITNESS
TO SB. THREE SEVENTY EIGHT MIKE
YOU'RE IN COMMITTEE THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. HI GOOD MORNING SO
YEAH MICROBES IN ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION WHICH IS THE-
CESSATION OF PUBLIC. PUBLIC
POWER IN PUBLIC WATER AGENCIES
THAT ON MAINTAINING THE
CRITICAL IN. ABOVE GROUND AND
UNDERGROUND INPUT UTILITY
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE STATE-
SHE CAME AWAY IS A POSSIBILITY
AS IN PRINT TODAY- BECAUSE IT
CAN IMPACT THE SAFETY INTEGRITY
OF THE CRITICAL IN FIRST. FOR
THAT TEAM WE MEMBERS NEED PAIN-
HOWEVER YOU KNOW WE HAD. A
CONVERSATION WITH THE AUTHOR
INNER STAFF AND- CREATE THE-
CREATE THOSE CONVERSATIONS AND
BELIEVE THE AMENDMENTS TAKING-
THIS MORNING ARE TAKING TODAY.
DEAL WITH A LOT OF THE ISSUES
THAT SENIOR WHITE HOUSE AND
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO- TO
WORKING WITH HER IN THE NEXT
COMMITTEE TO- TO YOU KNOW MORE
TO. ACTUALLY REMOVE OPS- AND
INCH THAT BY TRENCHING AS IT
GOES FOR IS A- IS- DONE THE IN
THE- A MAN AND- ACCORDING TO
CITY STANDARDS IN THE CALL
BEFORE YOU LAW SO WE WILL WE-
BEGIN. OPPOSED AS IT WOULD WAS
IN TODAY BUT WE- YOU'RE LOOKING
FOR TO RESOLVE ALL THAT AS WE
FORWARD THANK YOU. THANKS MUCH
MISERABLE. MORE TO CALM I'M IN
KNOW THAT THE SENATOR WILL
ALWAYS BE ONE PHONE CALL HUESO
DO APPRECIATE THAT SIR THANK
YOU FOR CALLING IN TODAY WE'RE
NOT. GOING TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE ELSE ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE. AT THAT TO BE TO SPEAK
UP AS- OF THREE. EIGHT HEARING
IN SEEING NO ONE WE'RE NOT
GONNA GO TO OVERFLOW ROOM. NO
ONE IS IN THAT OVERFLOW ROOM
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE GOING TO
THE PHONE LINES. BETTER
MODERATOR IF YOU WANT TO QUEUE
UP ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT CAN YOU
PLEASE DO SO NOW. THANK YOU FOR
IN OPPOSITION OF S. B. THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. ONE AMEND THEIR
OF YOUR OPPOSITION OB SB THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT. AND WE WILL GO
ONLINE OF THE TWENTY THREE YEAR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING CARE
MEMBERS TRACY RYAN NOW
REPRESENTING TODAY THE BROKEN
RIBS AS THE CALIFORNIA IRVINE
COUNTY THE CALIFORNIA COMPANY
STATED SUFFICIENT COUNTY THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES. IN
THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION
WE DO NOT HAVE A FORMAL
POSITION ON THE BILL WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING AT THE SENATORS ON
THURSDAY THE COMMITTEE STAFF TO
ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS- AND THOSE
OF THEM- LOCAL GOVERNMENT. WE
APPRECIATE ALL OF THE MEDICARE
AMENDMENT THE AUTHOR HAS
COMMITTED TO TAKING TODAY AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
THE CONVERSATION WITH THEIR
OFFICE IN THE SPONSORS ON THE
APPROPRIATE TIME FRAME FOR. A
PERMIT APPLICATION REVIEW WITH
THE GOAL OF GETTING ALL OUR
ORGANIZATION A SUPPORT POSITION
IN THE FUTURE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH WE APPRECIATE. THAT
PHONE CALL LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. THANK YOU WHAT A LINE
OF SIXTEEN YEAR LAW OF THE-
GOOD MORNING JEREMY. PRISCILLA
KIDDER BEHALF OF THE CITY
BEVERLY AND RESPECTFUL. THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PHONE CALL NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU A LINE OF SIXTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS GREG COOK
REPRESENTING NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA POWER AGENCY I WANT
TO ECHO THE COMMENTS MADE BY MR
ROBSON ON BEHALF OF C. ME AWAY
AND THANK THE STAFF FOR THEIR
FINE WORK ON THE ANALYSIS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD TO
HEAR VOICE OUR NEXT CALLER.
THANK YOU WHAT A LINE OF FIFTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MACKLER WITH SYMPATHIZERS ON
BEHALF OF THAT SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC POWER
AUTHORITY AND WE WOULD
ASSOCIATE COMMON QUICK MICROBES
IN WHICH THE ANYWAY AND DID
MUCH RESPECTFULLY REMAIN
OPPOSED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY NEXT
CALLER. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THERE ARE NO FURTHER OPPOSITION
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. RECEIVE
YOUR GRANDMOTHER LATER WE'RE
GONNA TURN IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
TO BE A TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
WE ALSO WELCOME THE MOTION IS
WELL. WE HAVE A MOTION A MOTION
BY SENATOR ALSO SAID SHE'S IN
WITH THAT MOTION ON ITEM NUMBER
FOR TO HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE. HEARING SEEN NINE
NOT MADAM SENATORS CENTRE
GONZALEZ WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE PLEASE S. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I WANT TO
THANK- ALL OF OUR SUPPORTERS
THAT CALLED IN TODAY AS WELL AS
THE OPPOSITION WORK- IS
EXTENSIVELY WORKING WITH- EVERY
SINGLE OF. ONE OF OUR
STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE THAT WE
GET THIS BILL LANGUAGE RIGHT WE
KNOW THAT IT'S NOT EASY- BUT
BROADBAND DOLLARS ARE COMING
INTO CALIFORNIA THERE IS A
PRIORITY FOR BROADBAND ACCESS.
AND WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT WE-
CONTINUE MOVING FORWARD IN A
WAY THAT WORKS FOR EVERYBODY I
WANT TO THANK YOUR COMMITTEE
FOR THE ANALYSIS AS WELL AND- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS CENTER
GONZALEZ WE HAVE A MOTION ON
THE FLOOR MOTION FOR BY CENTER-
DRIVE SO WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE
TURNED OVER TO MR NOW TO BE. A
CALDERON PROVIDE THE MOTION.
MOTION IS GROUP. AS AMENDED BUT
FOR A MAN. AND REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ENERGY UTILITIES
AND COMMUNICATION. SENATOR
MCGUIRE HI. WIRE AYE SENATOR
NIELSEN. NIELSEN HI SENATOR DO
ALSO DURAZO HI SENATOR
HERTZBERG. SENATOR WIENER
WIENER HI IF FOUR ZERO IT'S
CURRENTLY FOR IS YOUR VOTE FOR
YOUR VOTE LAYS IN GERMAN WE
APPRECIATE THAT EVER TO KEEP
THE BILL OPEN AND ALLOW THE
MAJORITY LEADER TO BE ABLE TO
ADD ON WE'RE GOING TO ASK OUR
AMAZING SERGEANTS TO BE ABLE DO
AN ALL CALL FOR AYE SENATOR
SKINNER CENTER SKINNER IS NEXT
BUT PLAYS IN GERMANY- IF IT'S
ALRIGHT WITH THE COMMITTEE
SINCE CENTER SKINNER AND THAT'S
GIVE HER ABOUT A MINUTE TO SEE
IF SHE'S GOING TO BE ABLE TO
SHOW. IF HE IS- IN NO SHE'S
WORKING A LOT ON BUDGET SHE
DOES NOT- WITH THAT LOOKING
INTO THE VICE CHAIR MISTER VICE
CHAIR IF YOU'RE COMFORTABLE I
WOULD THEN LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
GO TO SENATOR WIENER HI SINCE
WE DON'T HAVE AN AUTHOR BUT
WILL GIVE HER ABOUT A MINUTE TO
BE ABLE TO- SHOW HERE AND THEN
WE'LL GO TO CENTER WINNER SO
WHAT WHAT WE TAKE A QUICK BREAK
QUICK BREAK LAYS IN GERMAN AND
SEE IF WE ARE GOING TO GET AN
AUTHOR. OR TO COMING INTO
COMMITTEE.
ALL RIGHT GLAZER
WINNER WINNER CHICKEN DINNER.
WE HAVE CENTER EGGMAN WELCOME.
SO LADIES AND GENTLEMEN WE'RE
NOT GOING TO BE GOING TO ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
ON OUR FILES WE ARE GOING TO BE
TRACKING DOWN SENATOR CABALLERO
CENTER COPYRIGHT HAS ITEM
NUMBER FIVE WE'LL ALSO BE
TRACKING DOWN A CENTERS SKINNER
FOR ITEM NUMBER SIX BUT IN THE
MEANTIME WE WELCOME THE GOOD
SENATOR. FROM STOCKTON AT
CENTER EGGMAN TO BE A PRESENT
SB FOUR TWENTY SEVEN A CRITICAL
ISSUE ESPECIALLY AS WE HEAD
INTO THE DRAFT CENTER EGGMAN
FORESHORES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR AND- AND MEMBERS
I'M HERE TODAY TO TALK ABOUT
WATER ONE OF OUR MOST VALUABLE
RESOURCES- AND BACK VOTE SO
VALUABLE THAT IT IT IS OFTEN
THE- THE NUMBER OF SUBJECT IS A
WORD. BUT THE ITEM OF THEFT-
THERE'S MORE WATER THEFT THAT
OCCURS THAN WE MAY REALIZE
WHICH IS WHY I'M HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT S. B. FOUR TWENTY SEVEN
I'D LIKE TO START OUT BY
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE AND- THANK THE
COMMITTEE AND THE CHAIR FOR ALL
THEIR WORK. THIS BILL WOULD
ALLOW LOCAL WATER AGENCIES TO
ENHANCE THE PENALTIES FOR WATER
THEFT AS IT POSES A SERIOUS
PUBLIC HEALTH AS WELL AS A
SAFETY RISK EVERY TIME A NON
POTABLE SOURCE IS A LEGALLY
CONNECTED TO DRINKING WATER
SYSTEM THERE'S A CHANCE OF IT
CONTAMINATING THE WHOLE WATER
SOURCE. THIS MIGHT SEEM ODD TO
YOU THAT SOMEBODY WOULD DO
THIS- BUT YET THINK ABOUT
SOMEBODY GOING WITH THE BIG
HOSE AND CONNECTING TO A FIRE
HYDRANT AND THEN BE ABLE TO USE
IT IN SOME KIND OF COMMERCIAL
ENTERPRISE BECAUSE OFTEN TIMES
A- THE COST THE PENALTY FOR.
STEALING AT THAT WATER IS LESS
THAN IT WOULD BE TO ACTUALLY.
COOK UP LEGALLY TO THAT WATER
SYSTEM- THIS BILL IS AN- AND-
TO OUR WATER SYSTEMS. AND WE
KNOW THE IMPORTANCE. OF CLEAN
AND SAFE DRINKING WATER. THE
CURRENT PENALTIES ARE SIMPLY
NOT DETERRING WATER THEFT THEY
ARE SET AS LOW AS ONE HUNDRED
TWO HUNDRED AND FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS FOR THE FIRST SECOND
AND THIRD OFFENSE. RESPECTIVELY
IN A TWELVE MONTH PERIOD. WATER
AGENCIES HAVE WITNESSED ILLEGAL
CONNECTIONS TO HYDRANTS WITHOUT
APPROPRIATE EQUIPMENT AND
WITHOUT A PERMIT. IT PENALTIES
FALL FAR BELOW WHAT IT WOULD
COST TO DO IT YOURSELF- DESPITE
THE NEED TO DETER THE STRANGE
BEHAVIOR THIS BILL IS NOT
INTENDED TO ALLOW FOR PUNITIVE
PENALTIES- AND IN FACT MOST OF
THESE PENALTIES ARE NOT TOWARDS
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE JUST TRYING
TO GET CLEAN DRINKING WATER TO
THEIR HOME. THIS IS FOR MORE
COMMERCIAL ENTERPRISES THAT
OCCUR. WE THINK THIS BILL
STRIKES THE RIGHT BALANCE
BETWEEN- MAKING URE WEEK WE
KEEP OUR OUR WATER SYSTEM
MAINTAINED AND THEN. HAVING THE
FINES BE. DETERRENT ENOUGH THAT
PEOPLE WILL WILL STOP ILLEGALLY
CONNECTING UP. I AM TOO AB TWO
WATER SYSTEMS. AND WE THINK
THIS BILL STRIKES THE RIGHT
BALANCE IN WITH ME HERE TODAY
TO TESTIFY IS RYAN- ME. FROM
THE REGIONAL WATER AUTHORITY
AND- SOMEONE FROM ONE OF MY-
FUTURE LIFE AS A CITY
COUNCILMEMBER. MARC MEDICINE
WITH THE L. GROUP WATER
DISTRICT. THANK YOU SO MUCH
READING SENATOR AIMED AT LEAST
IN GENERAL COMMITTEE THIS BILL
DOES ENJOY BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
WHICH WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL FOR.
SO WE'RE GONNA START WITH RYAN
FOR THE REGIONAL WATER
AUTHORITY THEY WERE GONNA MARC
WITHOUT GROW WATER DISTRICT.
BRIAN WE WILL COMMUNICATE MANY
OR THREE MINUTES AND JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT YOU ARE AWARE
THAT YOU HAVE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT ON THE BILL. THE. FLOOR
IS YOURS THREE OF UP TO THREE
MINUTES. THANK YOU TO- CREATES.
WE BE RESPECTFUL OF THE FACT
THAT WE DO HAVE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I THINK BETTER
EGGMAN COVERED. A GREAT DEAL-
THE POINTS THAT NEEDED TO BE
MADE AND I DON'T HAVE A WHOLE
LOT ATTY- I THINK SHE COVERED A
LOT OF GROUND BUT AGAIN- I
DON'T THINK I SAID MY NAME YET
SO FOR THE RECORD RYAN A
JACKING WITH THE REGIONAL WATER
AUTHORITY. WHO IS R. W. A. R.
D. THE JOINT POWERS THAT THE
SCENE COMPRISED OF TWENTY
DRINKING WATER AGENCIES THAT
PROVIDE. WATER TO TWO MILLION
PEOPLE AROUND PEOPLE IN THE
GREATER SACRAMENTO AREA AND OUR
MISSION IS TO. SERVE REPRESENT
AND ALIGNING INTERESTS- ARE
AGENCIES AND STAKEHOLDERS TO
ADVANCE THE DELIVERY- WATER
SUPPLY RELIABILITY AVAILABILITY
QUALITY AND AFFORDABILITY. AND
THAT IS. WHY WE HAVE AN
INTEREST IN THAT PARTICULAR
BILL BECAUSE WATER REALLY IS A
CHALLENGE TO THAT MISSION. AND
FRANKLY CENTER EGGMAN HIT THE
NAIL ON THE HEAD- THE ISSUE IS
THAT THE FINES ARE JUST NOT A
SUFFICIENT DETERRENT. TO THE
POINT WHERE I IT IS FRANKLY WE
HAVE- SOME ACTORS OUT THERE.
WHO JUST- CAN'T BE BOTHERED TO
GO THREE LEAD TO. BECAUSE IT
JUST BY. IS THE COST OF
BUSINESS TO TAKE ON A FINE. AND
POTENTIAL QUITE- THAT WATER SO
AT RISK AND SO- I DO WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR ALL THE
TIME AND AN EFFORT THAT THEY
PUT IN ON THE BILL AND I THINK
THAT- AGAIN AS CENTER EGGMAN.
STATED THAT THE APPROPRIATE
BALANCE HAS BEEN STRUCK WITH
LANGUAGE THAT FOR YOU AND SO I
WILL THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR TIME AND I WILL- YOU KNOW
BACK IN THE ANY. OF THE
ADDITIONAL TREATMENT THANK YOU
THANKS SO MUCH MISTER TAKING
FROM THE REGIONAL WATER
AUTHORITY WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
GOING TO MARK MADISON
REFERENCING THE OKRA WATER
DISTRICT WE DO HAVE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT MR MEDICINE THE FLOOR.
IS YOURS YOU HAVE UP TO THREE
MINUTES. GOOD AFTERNOON CARE
MCGUIRE AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR HELPING
ME TODAY MY NAME IS MARK
MADISON I'M THE GENERAL MANAGER
OF THE LOCAL WATER DISTRICT.
WHICH SUPPLIES DRINKING WATER
TO OVER FORTY SIX THOUSAND
CUSTOMERS YOU KNOW GROWTH WHICH
IS JUST SOUTH SACRAMENTO'S MOST
YOU KNOW. THE THIS PROJECT
NUCLEAR SENATE BILL FOURTEEN
pOUR COLLABORATION CONSENSUS.
COHESION AND SOME GOOD OLD
FASHIONED COMMONSENSE. WE WORK
HARD TO ADDRESS CONCERNS AS WE
PUT THIS TOGETHER HOPE YOU
AGREE. HERE WE ARE CONTRA
ILLEGALLY CONNECT OUR WATER
SYSTEM IS STILL WATER THE
PROJECTS. APARTMENT FACT THAT
THIS IS EITHER IF BROWN'S POSE
A SERIOUS THREAT TO PEOPLE TELL.
INTERMISSION THE WATER SYSTEM
CAN OCCUR WHEN DIRTY EQUIPMENT
HOOKED UP IN THIS USUALLY
HAPPENS REQUIRE HUNDRED. WE'VE
GOT CONTRACTORS DEALING WATER
USING EQUIPMENT CLEARLY LABOR
LABELED NOT FOR PORTABLE USE
THAT FACT. I CAUGHT ONE MYSELF
JUST TWO MONTHS AGO THREE
BLOCKS AWAY FROM OUR
MINISTRATION OFFICE IN BROAD
DAYLIGHT. BY COLD WATER
AGENCIES IN CALIFORNIA NUMBER
ONE DISTRICTS TAKE PROBABLY
TAKE PRIDE IN THE PLEASE STATE
CLEAN DRINKING WATER TO OUR
CUSTOMERS. OUR DUTY OUR
CUSTOMERS DEPEND ON THAT MOST
OF YOU HAVE A WATER AGENCY THAT
PROVIDES WATER TO YOUR HOME.
AND I'M SURE YOU CAN APPRECIATE
WHAT I'M SAYING. I WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT WE SAY FOR YOU
FRIENDLY JUST LIKE WE DO.
ILLEGAL COME MAY. TO STEAL
WATER. OUR CURRENT LAW THE NOT
ALLOW FOR PENALTIES TO.
PROVIDED WE HAVE A PROCESS FOR
CON LUXURY DESPERATELY TANK OF
WATER BUT NOT ALL OF THEM THIS.
I DON'T WANT TO BE BY SOME
DON'T WANT TO PAY FOR THE PAPER
THE WATER THEY TAKE. SO THEY
STILL THEY JUST UP WE GO
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT HEARD BY
THE GENERAL FUND IT'S ONLY A
HUNDRED BUCKS. ONE CALL WE THIS
MAY TIMES CONTRACT MORE THAN.
TO PAY THE MINIMUM ON THE ON
THE WAY A HUNDRED. YOU CAN
UNDERSTAND IS NOTHING SHORT
CONTRACTORS THEY JUST WANT TO
GET THE WORK DONE AND- FRANKLY
THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND OR
SOMETIMES CARE ABOUT THE THREAT
THEY ARE POSING BUT PEOPLE.
DRINK OUR WATER YOUR THIRTY.
THREE THOUSAND BOARD. FEET HE'S
FIRED. TO DESTROY THESE
ACTIONS. WE BELIEVE SAID ABOUT
FOUR TWENTY SEVEN WILL DO THAT.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK SENATOR A
GREATER STAFF FOR OFFERING IS
STILL. THERE ONCE AGAIN THANK
THE GOVERNMENT THE GOVERNMENT
FINANCE COMMITTEE FOR ALLOWING
ME TO SPEAK. ON BEHALF OF OUR
DISTRICT ALL OF THE WATER
AGENCIES IN CALIFORNIA. BUT
MOST IMPORTANTLY THE PEOPLE.
TRYING TO SAFEGUARD I REQUEST
YOU SUPPORT SENATE BILL FOUR
TWENTY SEVEN THANK YOU. FOR
YOUR TIME IT'S YOUR MEDICINE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK INTO WE
ALSO APPRECIATE. EVERYTHING
THAT CENTER EGGMAN HAS BEEN
DOING ON THIS CRITICAL ISSUE.
FACING GERMAN WE'RE NOW GOING
TO BE A NEW ATTORNEY TO SEE IF
WE HAVE ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL HERE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE. HEARING IN SEEN
NINE WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO
OUR OVERFLOW ROOM. WE HAVE NO
ONE IN OUR OVERFLOW ROOM AT
THIS TIME WE ARE NOW GOING TO
GO TO THE PHONE LINES TO BE TO
CHECK IN WITH THOSE WHO MAY BE
IN SUPPORT IN SUPPORT OF SB.
FOUR TWENTY SEVEN MATTER
MODERATOR CAN YOU COULD PLEASE
Q. THOSE UP. SB FOUR TWENTY
SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN THERE ARE NOW. ONE AND
THEN ZERO IF YOU AREN'T SUPPORT
OF SB FOUR TWENTY SEVEN. WE
WILL THE LINE OF SEVENTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. CHRIS ANDERSON ON
THE OPPOSITION OF CALIFORNIA
WATER AGENCIES IN SUPPORT
THANKS SO MUCH CHRIS NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. AND AGAIN IT'S
THE ONE AND THEN ZERO IF YOU'RE
IN SUPPORT OF SB. FOUR TWENTY
SEVEN. MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO
FOR THIS IMPORTANT Q. THANK YOU
SO MUCH MATTER MODERATOR WE'RE
NOW GOING TO LOOK TO THOSE WHO
MAY BE OPPOSED TO SP FOUR
TWENTY SEVEN. WE DO NOT HAVE A
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS ON
RECORD WE ARE GOING TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM YEAH IF ANYONE
WOULD LIKE TO BE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. HERE IN ENCINO AND
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO OUR
OVERFLOW ROOM THERE'S NO ONE IN
OUR OVERFLOW ROOM WANTING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION FOR TWENTY
SEVEN WE'RE NOT GOING TO TURN
TO OUR PHONE LINES NOT A
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE
UP ANY INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
SPEAK. IN OPPOSITION OF SENATE
BILL FOR TWENTY SEVEN. THANK
YOU FOR IN OPPOSITION. SB FOUR
TWENTY SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO NOW. ONE AND THEN
ZERO HERE IN OPPOSITION OF S.
B. FOUR TWENTY SEVEN. MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NO OPPOSITION IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU SO
MUCH BETTER MODERATOR WE'RE
GONNA BRING THIS BILL BACK TO
COMMITTEE TO BE AND SEE IF WE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS OR IF ANYONE WOULD
LIKE TO BE ON OFFER A MOTION.
BARDIN COMMITTEE ABBOTT OFFERED
A MOTION ANYBODY OFFER TO
MOTIONS HERE DRAWS OF THAT IS A
MOTION RIGHT THERE. ALRIGHT WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR DRIES
OUT THERE WE GO- IN AND OUT WE
DID HERE I CENTER EIGHT MAN SAY
THAT SHE'S GONNA BE TAKING. THE
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS HERE IN
COMMITTEE- IT CENTER EGGMAN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
ACTUALLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU SO MUCH RATE MAIN NAV
MISTER NOW CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL AND ALSO PROVIDE THE
MOTION. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
PUBLIC SAFETY. SENATOR MCGUIRE
HI REQUIRE HIGHER SENATOR
NIELSEN. NIELSEN. SENATOR DRAWS
SO. YEAH TORONTO A- SENATE
HERTZBERG. SENATOR WIENER
WIENER HI FOUR ZERO FOUR ZERO
IT'S ALL GOOD OKAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH SOONER A BE READY KEEP THE
BILL OPEN- AS A CENTER DRAWS IS
GONNA BE PROVIDING THE RICARDO
LARA AWARD THAT TO THE MAJORITY
LEADER AT ONCE AGAIN HERE WHICH
I THINK IS- WHAT FOUR STRAIGHT-
SENATOR WHAT WOULD YOU SAY.
ALTHOUGH I DO HAVE TO CLARIFY
THAT I THINK. WHEN THE CHAIR.
ARRIVES AFTER OTHER MEMBERS
ARRIVES AS HAPPENED FOR A FEW
HEARINGS I THINK THAT'S A
WEIGHTED. SCORE SO THERE MIGHT
BE IT MIGHT BE THAT THE CHAIR
IS GOING TO WIN THE RICARDO
LARA I DON'T KNOW WHAT I'M I'M
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT DEAL
THIS YEAR WAS STILL WORKING ON-
HIT IN WHAT AUTHOR I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE COUPONS EXACTLY.
YOU'RE THE BEST AND WE DO THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU SENATOR
SO. LAZY GERMANY SHE'S HERE AND
READY TO GO THAT'S- SB THREE
NINETY FIVE IN SENATOR
CABALLERO THIS IS ABILITY SHE'S
BEEN WORKING ON ON ALL ISSUES.
OF E. CIGARETTES AND EXCISE
TAX. MANSER THE FLOOR'S YOURS
ON SB THREE NINETY FIVE. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT
SB THREE NINETY FIVE. I WOULD
LIKE TO START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND I
WANT TO THANK YOU AND YOUR
STAFF FOR YOUR ASSISTANCE ON.
THREE NINETY FIVE. E.
CIGARETTES CONTAIN A HARMFUL
COMBINATION OF NICOTINE
FLAVORING AND OTHER CHEMICALS
ADDITIVES ALTHOUGH THEY ARE
CURRENTLY TAXED AS OTHER
TOBACCO PRODUCTS R. O. T. P.'S.
THE TAX RATE IS MUCH LOWER THAN
THAT OF TRADITIONAL CIGARETTES
THEREBY CONTRIBUTING TO THE
GROWING DISPARITY BETWEEN THESE
PRODUCTS. AND UNDERMINING
EFFORTS TO CURB VAPING. THIS
MEASURE SEEKS TO CREATE PARITY
BETWEEN THESE PROJECTS.
PRODUCTS BEIPING HAS BECOME
INCREASINGLY POPULAR DESPITE
THE HIGH A RISK OF ADVERSE
HEALTH INCOME. OUTCOMES THIS
HAS BEEN ESPECIALLY PROBLEMATIC
AMONG OUR YOUTH ACCORDING TO
THE CDC'S NATIONAL YOUTH
TOBACCO SURVEY NEARLY 20% OF
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS REPORTED
CURRENT E. CIGARETTE USE. AND
OF THOSE 40% REPORT HEAVY USE
OF THE E. CIGARETTES. THE
AVAILABILITY OF YOUTH APPEALING
FLAVORS AND MARKETING HAS IN
LARGE PART CONTRIBUTED TO THIS
TREND. MANY TOBACCO RETAILERS
ARE MORE PREVALENT IN THE
POOREST AND MORE ETHNICALLY
DIVERSE NEIGHBORHOODS WHICH
OFTEN INCLUDES POPULATIONS MOST
AT RISK. OF AN ADEQUATE HEALTH
CARE ACCESS AND COVERAGE. SB
THREE NINETY FIVE THE HEALTHY
OPTIONS AND PREVENTION
EDUCATION ACT PROPOSES CLOSER
TAX PARITY BETWEEN THE SALE OF
VAPING. PRODUCTS AND
TRADITIONAL TOBACCO PRODUCTS BY
PROPOSING A NEW TAX ON VAPE
PRODUCTS. PROCEEDS OF THE RED
THE NEW GENERATED GO TO A EXIST
VOTER APPROVED SOURCES
INCLUDING EARLY CHILDHOOD
SERVICES PUBLIC HEALTH. AND
HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE PROGRAMS
AND IT ALSO INCLUDES FUNDING
FOR PHYSICIAN STUDENT LOAN
REPAYMENT PROGRAMS FOR THOSE
WORKING IN OUR MOST
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. ON
THE LINE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE MEASURE ISMARK GOT
GRANT GOULD WITH THE FIRST FIVE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER
COPYRIGHT BERNIE GOING TO THOSE
WHO ARE IN SUPPORT IN SUPPORT
OF SB THREE NINETY FIVE. AND
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO MISS GRANT
GOLDEN FROM FIRST FIVE
CALIFORNIA YOU HAVE THREE
MINUTES THREE MINUTES TO BE A
PRESENT WILL GIVE YOU THIRTY
SECOND PROMPT THE FLOOR IS
YOURS YOU'RE NARROWING
COMMITTEE. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN THE WIRING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MARGARET. I
AM THE POLICY DIRECTOR FOR THE
FIRST FIVE ADMINISTRATION OF
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING THE
FIFTY FIVE COUNTY COMMISSION
ACROSS THE STATE. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO JOIN TODAY
TO BE IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
NINETY FIVE. AND THEY GET A
BETTER COPY OUR FIRST STRONG
LEADERSHIP ON THE CELL. WITH
IMPORTANT THOUGH CREEK PARITY
BETWEEN THE SALE OF THE
PRODUCTS AND TRADITIONAL
TOBACCO PRODUCTS WITH THE
ULTIMATE GOAL OF PROMOTING
SMOKING SPECIATION. BY THE
HIGHER RISK OF NEGATIVE HEALTH
OUTCOMES THE PROBLEM IS THE
BABY AMONG YOUTH AND OTHER
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS OF THE
LEARNING. IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN ONE FOR HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS AND ONE IN TEN LOCAL
IT AND RECORDING USING E.
CIGARETTES THE PREVIOUS MONTH.
REFLECTING THE INCREDIBLE
UPTAKE IN AB HABITS.
ADDITIONALLY 80% OF PARENTS WHO
BATES DO SO AND HOMES AND CARS
EXPOSING THOUSANDS OF YOUNG
CHILDREN TO TOXINS SUCH AS
HEAVY METAL. FILTER FINE
PARTICULATE AND NICOTINE THERE
SECONDHAND EXPOSURE. HOWEVER
OUR STATE TECHNICIAN POLICY HAS
NOT KEPT UP WITH THE PUBLIC
HEALTH CONCERNS AROUND BEEPING.
IN FACT CHECKED RAISING RATES
ON OTHER TOBACCO PRODUCTS WICH
INCLUDE BAIT HAVE DECLINED BY
8% SINCE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN. THIS MEANS THAT BABY
PRODUCTS COST LESS. TODAY THAN
THEY DID FOUR YEARS AGO MAKING
THEM MORE ACCESSIBLE TO THE
GENERAL PUBLIC. SIMPLY PUT
CALIFORNIANS REDUCTION IN
TAXATION RATE DOES NOT MEET.
THE PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS
AROUND BAKING- THERE THAT THE
BILL WOULD FUND AND- OF.
PREVENTION PER THEY GET ABOUT
OF TO BACK UP WITH. BY HELPING
THE DETERMINES THE HEALTH.
FUNDING FROM BILL WOULD BE DEAD.
TO EARLY CHILDHOOD. FUNDED
THROUGH FIRST BY. PUBLIC HEALTH
INTERGRADE MEDICARE HEALTH CARE
PROGRAM. ABOUT THE PRODUCT
RETAILERS ARE MORE PREVALENT IN
LOWER INCOME AND MINORITY
COMMUNITIES WHICH ARE OFTEN THE
MOST AT RISK OF INADEQUATE
HEALTHCARE ACCESS IN BAKING AT
THERE BUT THAT. POLICIES LIKE
SB THREE NINETY FIVE WILL HELP
STRENGTHEN COMMUNITIES. BOLSTER
THE SOCIAL SAFETY NET AND
SUPPORT INCREASING NUMBER OF
YOUNG CHILDREN FAMILIES AND
INDIVIDUALS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA WHO RELY ON THESE
CRITICAL PUBLIC SERVICE THAT.
FOR THESE REASONS THE FIRST BY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
SUPPORT BUT THEN PORTENT BILL
AND. RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
I. ABOUT. WE APPRECIATE YOU
CALL IN TODAY THANK YOU SO MUCH.
REALLY GRATEFUL FOR EVERYTHING
THAT FIVE DAYS UP AND DOWN AT
THIS GREAT STATE WE'RE NOT
GOING TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
OUT. IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
NINETY FIVE HEARING COMMITTEE
TODAY. HEARING SEEN ON WE'RE
GONNA GO TO THAT OVERFLOW ROOM
THAT IS THE LONELIEST ROOM IN
THE CAPITOL. NOTHING GOING ON-
IN THE OVERFLOW ROOM WE'RE NOT
GOING TO GO TO THE PHONE LINES
AT WE'RE GONNA ASK THE
MODERATOR TO PLEASE QUEUE UP
ANYONE IN SUPPORT AT S. B.
THREE NINETY FIVE MINIMUM
WRITER. THANK YOU IF YOU WERE
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE NINETY
FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO NOW. WE WILL BILL MY
NUMBER FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THIS IS KAREN LAYING ON
TOP OF THE SOLANO COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS AT THE PORT
TODAY THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
AUTHOR IN THE CHAIR. THANK YOU
SO MUCH THIS CURRENT X. COLOR.
SB LINE SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CATHY LANDS
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR HEALTH PHYSICAL
EDUCATION RECREATION AND DANCE
IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT AND WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR HER
LEADERSHIP THANK YOU VERY
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR CALL TODAY
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER.
THANK YOU THEY'LL COME FROM
LINE SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DAVID KRIEGER
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
DISTRIBUTORS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE NINETY FIVE
NORTH THANKS TO THE AUTHOR AND
COMMITTEE FOR ALL THEIR WORK
THANK YOU THANKS DAVID LET'S GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU
AND MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO
FURTHER SUPPORTING QUEUE AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE MODERATOR OR NOT GONNA
BE LOOKING TO THOSE WHO MAY BE
OPPOSED OPPOSED TO SP THREE
NINETY FIVE. WE DON'T HAVE A
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS ON
RECORD WE'RE GONNA SEE IF
ANYONE HERE IN FORTY TWO OR
THREE WOULD LIKE TO BE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. HEARING SEEN
NONE WERE TO GO TO THE OVERFLOW
ROOM. IN C. NINE NINE IT WE'RE
NOT GONNA BE GOING TO OUR
TELEPHONE LINES ARE GONNA ASK
THE MODERATOR TO PLEASE QUEUE
UP ANYONE IN OPPOSITION OF SB.
THREE NINETY FIVE. THANK YOU
FOR IN OPPOSITION OF SB THREE
NINETY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO NOW. ONE AND THEN
ZERO HERE IN OPPOSITION OF SB.
THREE NINETY FIVE. THE MEDICARE
WE HAVE NOT PROVISIONING KILL
ALL RIGHT WE DON'T HAVE ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION WE'RE GONNA BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE TODAY TO
SEE IF WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS AND WE
ALSO WELCOME A MOTION. ON
SENATE BILL THREE NINETY FIVE.
THEY THAT SAID ROSES RED ROLE
SHE'S GOING ON A MOTION ON SB
THREE NINETY FIVE THANK YOU
SENATOR ALSO. WE LOVE HAVE
INCIDENT DRAWS SO IN COMMITTEE
THIS YEAR. I THANK YOU SO MUCH
AT THAT SEE IF THERE'S ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. FROM THE COMMITTEE.
HEARING SEEN UNDERGOING
TURNOVER CENTER TOP EURO IN
STATE THANK YOU OF MEDICINE-
FOR YOUR WORK AND IF YOU'D LIKE
TO CLOSE WE WELCOME THAT. THANK
YOU VERY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISS- MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS THAT IT'S PRETTY CLEAR
THAT THE TAXATION HASN'T KEPT
UP WITH PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
SENATE CAREER WERE NOT INJURED
OVER TO MISTER GOOD NOW FOR
READING THE MOTION AS WELL AS
CALLING THE FUNDS. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND RE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH. SENATOR
MCGUIRE. HI REQUIRE- A SENATOR
NIELSEN. SENATOR A- TORONTO HIS.
WHO SENATOR WIENER WIENER HI
THREE ZERO THREE ZERO VOTER AND
KEEP THAT ROLE OPEN ATTENDED
ALLOW THE MAJORITY LEADER IN
OUR VICE CHAIR TO BE OF ADD ON
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE SO
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU. FACING
GERMAN WE'RE NOT GOING TO
WELCOME US SENATOR SKINNER AT
TO THE PODIUM THIS IS ON SENATE
BILL THREE NINETY EIGHT THREE
NINETY EIGHT IS FOCUS ON SOME
REALLY IMPORTANT CONSEQUENCES
RESULTING FROM VOTERS APPROVING
PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR AND IT
IS HARD TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO THE GOOD SENATOR
FROM BERKELEY AND REPRESENTING
THE EAST BAY FOR THE AMENDMENTS
TODAY THAT'S GOING TO REMOVE
THE TAX COMPONENTS FROM THE
BILL NOW IT'S GOING TO REMOVE
TODAY BUT I WOULD CONSIDER THAT
TEMPORARY BECAUSE- WE'RE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO WORK
COLLABORATIVE LEE AS WE HAVE
THE ENTIRE STEP OF THE WAY.
WITH THE GOOD SENATOR ON THIS
BILL AS IT MOVES FORWARD AT
CENTER SKINNER AND I'VE
DISCUSSED REFORMS TO THE
CANNABIS TAX SYSTEM TO MAKE IT
MORE EFFICIENT AND EQUITABLE
ESPECIALLY FOR CULTIVATORS- AND
IN FACT YESTERDAY AND I JUST
WANNA SAY THANK YOU TO SENATE'S
GONNA READER REALLY GOOD
CONVERSATION WHERE THE- GOOD
SENATORS STAFF TEAM IN THE
STAFF TEAM FOR GOVERNANCE IN
FINANCE I HAVE ALREADY
SCHEDULED A MEETING TO DISCUSS
THE TAX ISSUE NEXT WEEK ON
REFORMS- IN AND THEREFORE THE
ONLY AMENDMENTS IN FRONT OF
COMMITTEE TODAY. ARE THE TAX
COMPONENTS OF THE BILL- DID
THIS COMMITTEE RECEIVED THOSE
THAT ARE IN LAST NIGHT THE
REMAINDER OF THE BILLS IN FRONT
OF US INCIDENTS CAN I JUST WANT
TO SAY YOU WERE ONE OF THE MOST
COLLABORATIVE HERE IN THE
BUILDING I WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT WE LOOK
FORWARD TO PLAYING THE NEWS.
HERE IN THE NEXT. COMING WEEKS.
THANK YOU MISS CHAIR AND THANK
YOU FOR- X. WHAT WE ARE. ON AND
AS YOU INDICATED I AM ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE MINUTES WHICH
WOULD REMOVE THE INCREASED
EXCISE TAX. WITH OF COURSE THE
COMMITMENT THAT WE WOULD WORK
TOGETHER TO FIGURE OUT. HOW TO
ENSURE THAT LOCALS GET SOME
SHARE OF THE REVENUE NOW ALL
EXPLAIN WHY THAT'S SO IMPORTANT
BECAUSE IT'S- INFECTED THE COR
THE BILL. SO AS WE ALL KNOW
PROP SIXTY FOUR LEGALIZED ADULT
USE OF CANNABIS. AND YOU KNOW
MANY OF US IN OBVIOUSLY VOTERS
WELCOME THAT. AND WHAT PART OF
OUR PURPOSE. CERTAINLY YOU KNOW
THERE WERE MANY PEOPLE WHO HOPE
THAT WE WOULD GET LOTS OF
REVENUE FROM IT. AND WE OFTEN
SEE OBVIOUSLY WANT TO
DECRIMINALIZE. BUT WHAT
UNFORTUNATELY IS A KURD IS THAT
WE DO IN WHILE WE HAVE MANY.
BUSINESSES THAT ARE FOLLOWING
THE RULES. THAT GOT LICENSED.
THAT ARE COMPLYING WITH
EVERYTHING. WE STILL HAVE ABOUT
A THIRD. OR RATHER THEIR ONLY A
THIRD. OF CALIFORNIA'S LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS OR JURISDICTIONS
THAT HAVE LEGAL BUSINESSES
OPERATING. NOW AS WE KNOW HOW
LONG WE HAD AN ILLEGAL
BUSINESS. THE LEAGUE ILLEGAL
BUSINESS IS THRIVING. ANSWER
RIGHT NOW THAT ILLEGAL CANNABIS
BUSINESS IS ESTIMATED IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TO HAVE A VALUE OF
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS. THE L.
A- PUTS THE VALUE OF OUR LEGAL
MARKET. ONLY AT THREE POINT
THREE. SO WHAT DOES THAT TELL.
THE GOOD BUSINESSES THAT HAVE
COMPLIED WITH THE REQUIREMENTS.
IT REALLY YOU START TO THINK
WHY SHOULD I HAVE. AND SO WE
REALLY WANT TO. HELLO WE WANT
TO SUPPORT AND ENCOURAGE THE
LEGAL BUSINESS AND ONE OF THE
WAYS TO DO IT IS ONE OF THE
REASONS THAT LOCALITIES HAVE
NOT EITHER ALLOWED. LEGAL
BUSINESSES OR SO IS BECAUSE THE
PROPOSITION SET UP A VERY
COMPLICATED LOCAL LICENSING
REGIME WHICH SOME LOCALITIES
ARE JUST EITHER DO NOT HAVE THE
RESOURCES FOR. OR YOU KNOW WHAT
WE FOR WHATEVER REASON THEY DID
NOT WANT TO SET UP THAT. REGIME
HOWEVER THEY'RE NOT OPPOSED TO
HAVING A LEGAL BUSINESS OPERATE
SO WHAT THIS BILL WOULD DO IS
CREATE THE ABILITY FOR THE
LOCALITY TO OPT IN TO THE STATE
SYSTEM SO THE STATE COULD GIVE
THE LICENSE. NOW IF YOU THE
LOCALITY WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO
WANT TO OPT IN IF YOU CAN'T GET
ANY MONEY FROM THAT AND SO
THAT'S WHY WE NEED TO FIX THE
PART THAT MR REQUIRE THE CHAIR
POINTED OUT AND WE'RE WORKING
TOGETHER TO DO IT. BUT AS I
BASICALLY INFORMED YOU OF WHAT
THE ESSENTIALLY BILL DOES WHICH
IS CREATE THIS ABILITY FOR THE
LOCALITY TO OPT IN AND LET THE
STATE. GIVE THE LICENSING BY TO
THE LOCAL ENTITY TO OPERATE IN
THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS. IT
ALSO CREATES AN EQUITY
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE IN OUR
BUREAU OF CANNABIS CONTROL. AND
LOWERS THE LABOR PEACE
AGREEMENT THRESHOLD FROM
TWENTY- EMPLOYEES TO CAN'T SO
WITH THAT ALLOW ME WITNESSES TO
SPEAK AND I HAVE AMY JENKINS
FROM THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION AND ROBERT
HARRIS FROM SEIU CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SOONER
SKINNER AGAIN VERY GRATEFUL FOR
THE PARTNERSHIP LET'S GO TO OUR
FIRST LEAD WITNESSES YOUR LEAD
WITNESS YOU HAVE UP TO THREE
MINUTES THIS IS GONNA BE ANNIE
JENKINS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION MICHIGAN'S. WORK ON
THE COMMITTEE THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. YES THEY YOU CHAIR AND
CAN MEMBER AMY JENKINS WITH
PROFESSIONAL ADVOCACY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION. WHICH
REPRESENTS OVER FOUR HUNDRED
MEMBERS ACROSS ALL ASPECTS OF
THE CANNABIS BY CHANGE WE WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
INTRODUCING THIS IMPORTANT%
LEGISLATION AND FOR YOUR WORK
MISTER CHAIR CAN MAKE THAT
SPELL- I BETTER BELL. AND IT
SEEKS TO EXPANDCOMPUTER ACCESS
TO LICENSED AND REGULATED
CANNABIS GROW VOLUNTARY PROGRAM
WHERE BY THE STATE WHAT IS THE
PRIMARY RESPONSIBILITY OF OUR
COMMERCIAL CANNABIS LICENSING
ON BEHALF OF PARTICIPATING
JURISDICTIONS. CALIFORNIA'S
LEGAL CANNABIS INDUSTRY HAS
FACED CONSIDERABLE CHALLENGES.
THE REGULATORY FRAMEWORK FOR
CANNABIS TOOK A FACT INCLUDING
A LACK OF ACCESS TO CAPITAL
HEAVY REGULATORY BURDENS AND
COMPETITION FROM A MUCH LARGER
UNLICENSED MARKET. DESPITE
THESE CHALLENGES LEGAL CANNABIS
BUSINESSES HOLD MASTER GROWTH
POTENTIAL CALIFORNIA'S LICENSED
INDUSTRY GENERATED MORE THAN
FOUR POINT ONE BILLION AND
TAXABLE SALES IN TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY. A. 50% INCREASE FROM
THE PRIOR YEAR. DR ALSO TO A
AND DOLLAR LIKE TO THE-
DEPARTMENT OF TAX SHE ADMITS.
THE LICENSE HAVE ALSO
EXPERIENCED SIGNIFICANT JOB
GROWTH ADDING ROUGHLY TWENTY
FOUR THOUSAND WELL PAYING JOBS
RESULTING IN MORE THAN FIFTY
THOUSAND FULL TIME POSITION IN
CALIFORNIA. DESPITE THE
INDUSTRY SIGNIFICANT
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE STATE'S
ECONOMY ONLY ONE OUT OF FOUR
DOLLARS AND ON CANNABIS AND
CALIFORNIA ARE SPENT IN THE
LEGAL MARKET THIS IS PRIMARILY
DUE TO TWO FACTORS. FIRST IT
TURNED B THE STATE HI CHRI
RGULATORY BURDENS UNLIKE THE
BUSINESSES SELL CHEAPER
UNTESTED PRODUCTS TO PATIENTS
AND CONSUMERS AND SECOND AS
PREVIOUSLY POINTED OUT ONLY 32%
OF CALIFORNIA FIVE HUNDRED AND
FORTY CITIES IN CHINESE.
AUTHORIZED LEGAL RETAIL
CANNABIS BUSINESSES LEADING
MANY PATIENTS AND CONSUMERS
WITHOUT ACCESS TO SAFE AND
LEGAL PRODUCTS. JUST IMAGINE
THE POTENTIAL IF MORE
COMMUNITIES AUTHORIZED LICENSED
CANNABIS RETAIL SB THREE NINE
EIGHT OFFERS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ARE STREAMLINED APPROACH TO
PROVIDE SAFE ANDRESPONSIBLE
ACCESS TO REGULATED CANNABIS.
EXPANDING LEGAL ACCESS THIS
BILL WILL HELP CURB DEMAND FOR
UNLICENSED PRODUCT AND HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
JOBS AND ECONOMIC GROWTH WHILE
INCREASING THE STATE AND LOCAL
TAX REVENUES. HE SAID WE ALSO
WISH TO APPLAUD THE SENATOR FOR
INCLUDING PROVISIONS TO
ESTABLISH A STAKEHOLDER
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE TO ENSURE A
FAIR AND EQUITABLE DISTRIBUTION
EQUITY GRANTS. AND TO DEVELOP
MODEL GUIDELINES FOR LOCAL
EQUITY PROGRAMMING THIS IS A
CRITICAL LONGSTANDING PRIORITY
FOR CPA'S DIVERSITY INCLUSION
AND SOCIAL EQUITY COMMITTEE.
THE REASONS WE STRONGLY RESPECT
ELECTRONIC SUPPORT THE BELL AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT FOR SB THREE NINE EIGHT
TODAY THANK YOU THANKS SO MUCH
MISS JENKINS GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY WE'RE NOT GOING
TO GO TO ROBERT HARRIS
REPRESENTING SEIU CALIFORNIA
MISTER HARRIS YOU HAVE UP TO
THREE MINUTES. I'LL GIVE YOU A
THIRTY SECOND. PROMPT URINE
COMMITTEE THE FLOOR IS YOURS. I
DO NOT CALL AND SEE IF WE HAVE
ROB HARRY S. YOU CAN. WE'RE
GONNA CHECK IN WITH CECILIE DO
WE KNOW IF WE HAVE ROBERT
HARRIS ON THE LINE. WE DO CARE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. EVERY
GOVERNOR HARRIS HARRIS ON THE
APP. COVERED HERE SO YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIA. IN SUPPORT OF-
DISPEL I MIGHT STILL ECHOING
COME ARE YOU ARE NOT A QUEEN%
ESTHER HARRIS NOT ON OUR END AT
LEAST AT YOUR END COMMITTEE
YOUR LIVES IN PLEASE PROCEED
GOOD MORNING. AFTERNOON NOW
GOOD MORNING. SO YES IT. HELLO
THIS ROBERT HARRISON B. F. L.
C. I. U. CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL- ARE SEVEN HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND MEMBERS
AND THEIR FAMILIES THAT WOULD
BE AN INVITING INTEREST IN BOTH
THE DISTRICT'S COMPUNCTION AND
EARLY AND HONESTLY THE ARMENIAN
IN RESCINDING THE TAX REPORTS
THAT COME WHEN WE EXPAND THE
MARKET- SO. L. A. O. IS
ESTIMATED THAT THE DESPITE
EXPANDING THE MARKET PLACES
WHERE IT ISN'T OPEN RIGHT NOW
THE STATE WILL WOULD RECEIVE
BETWEEN SIX HUNDRED MILLION THE
MILLION AND BILLION DOLLARS IN
NEW REVENUE. SYMPORTER BECAUSE
THAT REVENUE IN YOUR ARTICLE
PROGRAMS SUCH AS CHILD CARE
WHICH REDUCES CHILDHOOD TRAUMA
IMMUNITY IN THE REINVESTMENT
FOR COMMUNITIES IMPACTED BY THE
WAR ON DRUGS FOR MANY OF OUR
MEMBERS LIAM AND EARLY
INTERVENTION AND PREVENTION
PROGRAMS IN THOSE SAME
COMMUNITIES. MARKET EXPANSIONS
ONE MOST EFFECTIVE TOOLS TO
REDUCE ILLEGAL MARKET I'M
COLORADO WITH THE MARKET
DENSITY ONE REAL RETAIL STORE
TO SEVENTY EIGHT HUNDRED
RESIDENTS THE NEED BE EVEN
LEGAL MARKETS ONLY 13% OF TOTAL
SALES IN CALIFORNIA WITH THE
DENSITY OF ONE RETAIL STORE TO
THIRTY NINE THOUSAND CITIZENS.
WE HAVE A 62% A LITTLE ILLEGAL
SALE IN OREGON WHICH I
CALIFORNIA OVER PRODUCES MORE.
THAN THAT CITIZENS COULD EVER
USE. YEAH THEY ARE THERE RIGHT
RATIO OF SIX THOUSAND THREE SIX
ONE RETAIL STORE TO SEE.
THOUSAND- PRESIDENT YIELD ONLY
FOR FOURTEEN- ILLEGAL SALES.
THE SECOND ISSUE THAT HAS
SUPPORTS THIS BILL AS WE LOOK
AT EVERYTHING THROUGH THE
THROUGH THE LENS OF. SOCIAL
EQUITY AND RACIAL JUSTICE YOU
KNOW THE ALTERNATIVE WORKING ON
BUILDING AND IMPROVING THE
SOCIAL EQUITY PROGRAMS THAT ARE
NOW LOCAL AND NOT QUITE UP TO
PAR THIRD S. CI USING THOSE TO
THE STRONG VIBRANT ECONOMIC
RECOVERY DEPENDS ON THE VOICES
OF WORKERS BEING CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA ONCE SWAM TRYING TO
ENSURE THE CANNABIS WORKERS
HAVE A VOICE IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH INDUSTRY OWNERS. HOWEVER
STATE LIKE NEW JERSEY NEW YORK
VIRGINIA NEW MEXICO LEGALIZED
CANNABIS EACH YEAR AND STRONG
IN AND ACTED MUCH STRONGER
PROTECTIONS FOR WORKERS THIRTY
SECONDS WE WANT CALIFORNIA THE
LEAD AND WE SUPPORT OUR
BROTHERS AND SISTERS IN U. D.
W. OF CW AND THE TEAMSTERS. AS
YOU OFFER MOVES FORWARD WITH
THIS BILL AND WE WISH TO THANK
THE AUTHOR AND THE COMMITTEE OR
COMMITMENT TO WORK TO IMPROVE
CAMPUS IN CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH ONE TAKEN THE
TIME COMING INTO COMMITTEE TO
BE ABLE HAVE CONVERSATION AND
TO BE HEARING COMMITTEE AS WELL
THANK YOU LAYS IN GENERAL NOW
TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE NINETY
EIGHT KAREN SCENE NINE HERE IN
THE COMMITTEEROOM WE'RE GOING%
TO GO TO OUR OVERFLOW ROOM WE
DO NOT SEE ANYONE WANTING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
NINETY EIGHT INNER OVERFLOW
ROOM WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO
OUR PHONE LINES. MATTER
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE
QUEUE UP ALL INDIVIDUALS IN
SUPPORT. OF SB THREE NINETY
EIGHT NOW. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF S. B. THREE NINETY
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AND WE'LL GO LINE OF A
YEAR LONG IS OPEN. YES HELLO
DELUCA IN BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
OAKLAND MOCKED THE EXTRACTION
CRISCO IN STRONG SUPPORT AND
APPRECIATE ALL THE LEADERSHIP
FROM THE AUTHOR THANKS BIGELOW
PRE SHADED THAT'S GOT OUR NEXT
CALLER. THANK YOU OF A LINE OF
FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE TERM MEMBER BEVERLY ON
BEHALF OF YOUR LOCAL THIRTY
NINE THIRTY REPRESENT OVER A
HUNDRED FORTY THOUSAND HOME
CAN'T TALK ABOUT IT WHY. WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS
LEADERSHIP AND COMMITMENT TO
CREATING FAVORABLE MARKET
ACCESS FOR CONSUMERS AND
GROWING STATE REVENUE TO
UNDERSTAND CRITICAL PROGRAM
CLEAN CHILD CARE LITTLE MINOR
COMMENTS WITH. MY COLLEAGUES.
THEY'RE HERE AT THE AYE YOU TO
HELP THEM LIBERAL CANDID EQUITY
PROGRAM WELL. THE DATE SUPPORT
THE LINE ITEM THANK YOU SO MUCH
WE'RE GONNA NUMBER YOUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE WE'RE GOING TO
REMIND FOLKS WE HAVE OUR TO
LEAD WITNESSES I'M NOT TRYING
TO BE CRUNCHY BUT JUST WE HAVE
TO GIVE EQUAL TIME TO ALL AND
ESPECIALLY IN THESE REMOTE TIME
SO I DO APOLOGIZE ABOUT THAT.
SO WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR FOLKS
ON THE PHONE IS FIRST LAST
NAME. YOUR ORGANIZATION AND
YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL AND
AGAIN NOT AT ALL TRYING TO. BE
CRUNCHY WHATSOEVER. LET'S GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU DON'T FROM ONE EIGHTY SIX
ONE OF OPEN. THIS IS YOUR
REMEMBERS MORE ON BEHALF OF
SEEING CO ABOUT WITH THE IMAGE
TAKEN TODAY WE TO SOME THE ON
THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH TAX CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU WILL GO ONLINE A EIGHTY SO
YEAR LINE IS OPEN. AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN THIS IS A TO
RECALL ME UP THE YOU KNOW FOOD
WORKERS. SUPPORT OF AMENDED
WERE WORKING WITH DOCTORS
OFFICE ON A NUMBER OF
AMENDMENTS AND APPRECIATE HER
EFFORTS AND- BECAUSE OF THE
TIME LIMITATIONS AGAIN SUPPORT
AMENDED FROM YOSEMITE THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBER
GRATEFUL TO HEAR YOUR VOICE
IT'S GOING TO OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I APOLOGIZE I'M I'M
WAITING FOR A DIFFERENT BILL
ACTUALLY BY I THINK. WE'LL GO
NEXT FINE OF EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS GEORGE MILLER ON BEHALF
THE WEED MAPS IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB THREE NINE EIGHT. JOHN
GEORGE MILLER BRING IN THE
VOICE TODAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER MILLER AT THAT'S GOING
TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU LINE THIRTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MISTER KAREN
SENATORS BIGGER FEEL ON BEHALF
OF THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
COALITION IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE NINE EIGHT THANK YOU
SENATOR SKINNER. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR PHONE CALL NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU LINE
SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRD ALICIA
PRIEGO ON BEHALF OF THE
COMPACTION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER. DESPITE EIGHTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
MATTHEW WALDRON HERE-
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THREE
NINE EIGHT ON BEHALF OF THE
CANNABIS CONSUMER POLICY
COUNCIL AND OUR COALITION
PARTNERS AMERICANS FOR SAFE
ACCESS AND THE UNITED CORE
LINES THANK YOU VERY MUCH IT'S
MATTHEW. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU WITH A LINE OF
SEVENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
QUESTION HOW WILL BLOCK WITH
THE TEAMSTERS WE SUPPORT THE
BROAD CONTOURS OF SB THREE
NINETY EIGHT WE'VE SHARED
AMENDMENT WITH THE AUTHOR- WITH
PROTECTIONS FOR DISTRIBUTORS
THAT WE HOPE TO SEE INCLUDED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
YOUR PHONE CALL LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORT SUPPORT IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME HI MY MODERATOR WILL
TALK TO YOU IN JUST A SECOND
LET'S GO AND SEE IF WE HAVE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM HEARING SEEN
ON WE'RE GONNA GO TO THAT. THE
ONLY ROOM HERE IN THE CAPITAL
OR OVERFLOW ROOM. I NEEDED TO-
HERE TODAY ON THIS BILL SO
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO OUR
PHONE LINES TO AND WE'RE GOING
TO CHECK IN WITH THE MODERATOR
MADAM MODERATOR LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
FOR SB THREE NINETY EIGHT IF
YOU CAN PLEASE QUEUE THEM UP
NOW. THANK YOU FOR IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE NINETY
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN ZERO IN
OPPOSITION OF SB. THREE NINETY
EIGHT. MISTER CHAIR I SEAT NO
ONE THANK YOU AT THE TIME FOR
OPPOSITION I LOVE WORKING WITH
HUMANA MODERATOR THANK YOU SO
MUCH TO TURN IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE TODAY TO SEE IF WE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
WELCOME MY MOTION NOW RIGHT AT
CENTER DRIVES A POLICE INFORMER
INSURANCE WELL I MOVED A MOTION
BUT- I HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS
JUST. TELL YOU SOUND A LITTLE
BIT BETTER IF I MAY MISTER
PLEASE I'M JUST. CURIOUS HERE-
THE STATE IS CURRENTLY
LICENSING- STRAIGHT. I MEAN.
YOU CAN GET A LICENSE STRAIGHT
FROM THE STATE. IS THAT IS THAT
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW THERE IS
THE OPTIONS YES THERE IS THE
ABILITY FOR- AS LONG AS THE
LOCALITY DOES NOT OBJECT SO
THERE IS ALREADY THAT ABILITY
BUT OF COURSE IN THOSE CASES
THE- LOCALITY GETS NO REVENUE.
AND SO WE HAVE IN WE HAVE A
CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE THERE ARE
THERE ARE LOCALITIES WHO HAVE
NOT SET UP. THEIR LICENSING
STRUCTURE BECAUSE OF ITS
COMPLICATION BUT WHO WANT TO
HAVE LEGAL BUSINESSES AND OF
COURSE WANT TO SHARE IN THE
REVENUE SO THIS IS THIS BILL
WOULD CREATE THAT ABILITY I
JUST ONE MORE QUESTION IF I
CAN- HOW WOULD. HOW DO YOU KNOW
HOW IF THOSE LOCAL AREAS ARE
REALLY GOING TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THIS I MEAN IT IS THE JUST A
GUESS BECAUSE SOME OF THEM HAVE
SAID SO OR DO WE REALLY HAVE
SOME RELIABLE EXPECTATION-
INTERESTING QUESTION BECAUSE OF
COURSE MY STAFF AND I HAVE
DISCUSSED THAT A LOT BECAUSE
WHY WOULD WE WANT TO. GO TO THE-
TROUBLE PUTTING SOMETHING
COMPLICATED INTO PLACE IF IT
DID NOT GET. UTILIZED NOW IF
THE LOWER. CAN RECOVER NO. IT
IS LIKELY IT WON'T YOU- SO
THAT'S WHY .COM SO IMPORTANT
AND WE'RE ON IT- HOWEVER I CAN.
RIGHT NOW. WE WITH THIS PANDA
INDUCED RECESSION. AND KNOWING
THAT AT LEAST BRICK AND MORTAR
THERE SOME LEVEL OF BRICK OR
MORTAR TYPE OF OPERATIONS THAT
ARE NOT GOING TO COME BACK AND
WHILE WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO
COLLECT SALES TAX FROM INTERNET
SALES. IT'S NOW IF FOR EXAMPLE
OF THE AMAZON WAREHOUSES YOU
KNOW SHOW MORE FAR AWAY THAN
THAT LOCAL JURISDICTION DOESN'T
GET EVEN IF YOU YOUR YOU BUY
THE PRODUCT OR WHATEVER SO
POINT I'M MAKING IS THAT OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS REVENUES HAVE
REALLY BEEN HURT. AND SO THEY
MADE ESPECIALLY WHEN THEYSEE
THE VALUE OF. THAT WILL THAT
THREE DOLLARS OUT OF EVERY FOUR
DOLLARS SPENT ON CANNABIS IN
THE STATE IS BEING SPENT
ILLEGALLY AND THAT IF THEY
CREATED THE PATHWAY FOR THE
LEGAL THEY COULD BE COLLECTING
REVENUE WHICHWOULD HELP THEM
SO THAT I THINK PERHAPS A
COUPLE YEARS AGO WE MAY NOT
HAVE FOUND QUITE AS MUCH BUT I
THINK NOW LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
REALLY GOING TO BE LOOKING FOR
REVENUE. SINCE THIS PANDEMIC.
THE QUESTION I THINK IS HER
SANDRA SO IT WOULD LIKE TO GO
TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS WE DO HAVE A MOTION ON
THE FLOOR. BY SENATOR RUSSELL
SHARING. NO QUESTIONS. WE'RE
GONNA TURN OVER TO THE SKINNER
FOR THE CLOSE. THANKS SO MUCH
CARE- I WAS JUST REFLECTING.
SPECIALLY ON HEARING NO
OPPOSITION. AT LEAST FOR
CALLERS- THAT. YOU KNOW WHAT.
WHILE I HAVE NOT. SPENT MOST OF
MY ADULT LIFE PRIMARILY WORKING
ON. THE ACCEPTANCE AND
LEGALIZATION OF CANNABIS. I
CERTAINLY HAVE. BEEN INVOLVED
IN IT FOR OVER FORTY YEARS. AND
I WAS REFLECTING ON THE FACT
THAT I COORDINATED. THE VERY
FIRST. COURT UPHELD LEGAL.
DECRIMINALIZATION OF CANNABIS
INITIATIVE. BACK IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY NINE IN BERKELEY. AND
NOW TODAY WE HAVE. IT LEGAL
ACROSS THE STATE. AND YET
IRONICALLY WE ARE FACING THIS
CIRCUMSTANCE. OF ES- THE GOOD
WITNESS AMY JENKINS POINTED OUT.
ONLY ONE DOLLARS OUT F EVERY
FOUR DOLLARS SPENT BEING SPENT
WITHIN THE LEGAL MARKET SO I AM
THAT MUCH MORE COMMITTED TO
DOING EVERYTHING I CAN TO
INCREASING THAT LEGAL MARKET
AND SUPPORTING THAT LAURIE
LEGAL MARKET AND WITH THAT I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON SB
THREE NINETY EIGHT. THANK YOU
SO MUCH SENATE SKINNER WE LOOK
FORWARD TO OUR CONTINUED
PARTNERSHIP TOGETHER AND AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
ON THIS CRITICAL ISSUE WE'RE
GOING TO TURN IT OVER TO MR NOW
THE BEARD A LAY OUT THE MOTION
AS WELL AS CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
THE FIRST AMENDED AND BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
RULES SENATOR MCGUIRE AYE
MCGUIRE FIVE SENATOR NIELSEN.
NIELSEN SENATOR DORADO. DORADO
BY SENATOR HERTZBERG. SENATOR
WIENER WIENER HI THREE ONE FIVE
ZERO THAT'S THREE ONE VOTE
WE'RE GONNA KEEP THE ROLE OPEN
AND ALLOW THE MAJORITY LEADER
TO BE ABLE TO ADD ON HERE WHEN
HE'S ABLE TO GET TO THE HEARING
ANSWERS MEANS THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER SKINNER. THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
WE'RE GOING TO TURN THIS OVER
TO SENATOR ALAN WE'RE GRATEFUL
LOOK SENATE ALLEN HAS A
COMPLICATED BILL IT'S A REALLY
IMPORTANT BILL AND HE'S BEEN
WORKING HARD TO BE ABLE TO LAND
IT AND WE JUST WANT TO SAY.
THANK YOU TO CENTER ALLEN FOR
ALL HIS WORK ON THIS. AT THIS
IS SENATE BILL FIVE SIXTY
THREE. MR ON THE FLOOR IS YOURS
AND WE WELCOME YOU TO COMMITTEE
SIR. WHAT DID YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND I WIND UP WITH THE THANK
YOU ARE HARD WORKING SENATE
STAFF WHO. HAVE TO WIPE DOWN
EVERY SURFACE AND ENSURE THAT
WE'RE WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO. DO OUR PART IN STOPPING
THE SPREAD OF THIS TERRIBLE
VIRUS SO THANK YOU. AS ALWAYS
LET ME JUST START BY THINKING
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO THINK THE
EXCELLENT- AND STAFF. FOR ITS
HARD WORK I AM VERY HAPPY TO
ACCEPT YOUR COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS- THERE IN COMMON SIX
MEMBERS FOR YOU TO. REFER TO.
NON URINALYSIS THEY BASICALLY
RE ESTABLISHED AT THE REQUEST
OF THE REALTORS PROVISIONS-
RELATED TO NIFTY TO DISTRICT
PLAN ADOPTION AMENDMENT AND
REVIEW. YOU'VE GOT MY
COMMITMENT THAT I WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK COLLABORATIVELY WITH
THIS COMMITTEE AND ALSO WITH
STAKEHOLDERS IF THE BILL. DOES
MOVE FORWARD TODAY. THIS BILL
SB FIVE SIXTY THREE UPDATES AND
IMPROVES UPON THE SECOND
NEIGHBORHOOD INFILL FINANCE AND
TRANSIT IMPROVEMENTS ACT. NIFTY
TWO. NIGHTS A VOLUNTARY TAX
INCREMENT FINANCING TOOL TO
CATALYZE AFFORDABLE INFILL
HOUSING. NEAR TRANSIT NOW AS
THIS COMMITTEE KNOWS IN THE
WAKE OF REDEVELOPMENT'S
DISSOLUTION. THE LEGISLATORS
CREATED NUMEROUS INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCING INSTITUTIONS THAT
HAVE YET TO CATALYZE
SUBSTANTIAL GROWTH. A NIFTY TWO
WAS ESTABLISHED IN CONSULTATION
WITH HOUSING AND TRANSIT
ADVOCATES TO PROVIDE CITIES AND
COUNTIES. WITH A FINANCING
TOOL. THAT THE- THAT ESPECIALLY
INCENTIVIZE IS THE DEVELOPMENT
AND CONSTRUCTION OF HOUSING IN
TRANSIT ORIENTED COMMUNITIES.
TO THE LEGISLATION THAT I
AUTHORED CREATING THE STATUTE
ALSO REQUIRED THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH
OPR. TO STUDY AND REPORT ON THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF TANK TAX
INCREMENT OF TOOLS FOR
INCREASING HOUSING PRODUCTION.
SO HERE'S THE THING OPR TRIP.
WHICH WAS RELEASED EARLIER THIS
YEAR NOTES THAT LIMITED REVENUE
POTENTIAL OF INCREMENT
FINANCING TOOLS. QUOTE
SIGNIFICANTLY LIMITS THEIR
ABILITY TO ASSIST IN MEETING
STATE HOUSING GOALS AND IT
RECOMMENDS EXPLORATION OF WAYS
TO OP POTENTIALLY LEVERAGE
EXISTING STATE PROGRAMS AND
FUNDING SOURCES. TO ENABLE USE
OF FINANCING TO PROMOTE
LOCATION EFFICIENT DEVELOPMENT
AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
PLACES WHERE CURRENT INCREMENTS
FINANCING TOOLS ALONE. MAY BE
INSUFFICIENT. SO THIS BILL
INCORPORATES- PR'S
RECOMMENDATION. I ENVISIONING A
ROLE FOR POTENTIAL STATE
FUNDING TO BOLSTER A SHARED
GOAL WITH CITIES AND COUNTIES
OF BUILDING INFILL HOUSING AND
COMPLEMENTARY INFRASTRUCTURE
TRANSIT. IT ALSO STRENGTHENS
NIFTY TO USE TENANT
PROTECTIONS. HOMELESSNESS
PREVENTION IN INTO DISPLACEMENT
PROVISIONS ENSURING DISTRICTS
AUGMENT BUT NOT UNINTENTIONALLY
UNDERMINE CALIFORNIA'S
AFFORDABLE HOUSING STOCK. SO BY
ESTABLISHING A ROBUST FRAMEWORK
FOR COLLABORATION AND CO
INVESTMENT BETWEEN THE STATE
AND ITS CITIES AND COUNTIES.
WHO WISH TO WORK TOGETHER TO
BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PREVENT HOMELESSNESS IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES THIS BILL PROVIDES
A MECHANISM THE COMMERCIAL MORE
FINANCIAL RESOURCES THAT ANYONE
LEVEL OF GOVERNMENT. CAN
PROVIDE ALONE SO ON THE PHONE
WITH ME TODAY AND SAID THAT
DESPITE SUPPORT ANYTHING ON
BEHALF OF MOVE LA AND SANTA
MONICA TO RENTERS RIGHTS. THE
CO SPONSOR THIS LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER- AND
WE'RE NOW GOING TO GO TO OUR
LEAD. SUPPORT WITNESS AGAIN MR
ST THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
MOVE LA. MICHIZANE YOU HAVE UP
TO THREE MINUTES UP TO THREE
MINUTES I'LL GIVE YOU THIRTY
SECOND PROMPTED THE FLOOR IS
YOURS YOUR NOUN COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU ARE CHAIRMAN
REQUIREMENTS THANK YOU
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FROM THIS
OPPORTUNITIES I'M DANNY ST I'M
EXECUTIVE ACTOR OF MOVE LA- AND
ALSO A MEMBER OF THE STEERING
COMMITTEE OF SANTA MONICA FOR
RENTERS RIGHTS WE WANT TO.
THANKS IN AROUND THE FIRST
LEADERSHIP. AND HIS COURAGE IN
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. THANK
YOU SENATOR ALLEN SO- ASEAN
SAID SB FIVE SIXTY THREE TRIES
TO CREATE A FRAMEWORK FOR
COLLABORATION. AND CO
INVESTMENT. IN THE CENTER
CALIFORNIA'S COUNTIES AND
CITIES. WISH TO WORK TOGETHER
TO BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
TO PREVENT HOMELESSNESS. WE
BELIEVE IN IT WILL TAKE.
SUPPORT INVESTMENT FROM ALL
THREE PRIMARY LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT. TO MEET THE NEED
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AND
HOMELESS PREVENTION IN
CALIFORNIA AND THIS BILL
CREATES A FRAMEWORK BUILDING
OFF. THE NIFTY TO PROGRAM- SIGN
IN THE LAWN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
ALSO. CENTER ALLEN'S BILL- IT
WILL PROVIDE THIS FRAMEWORK- TO
EAT. ANY EGGS WHENEVER ANY
COUNTY- CITY AGREED A FORMER
DISTRICT AND COMMIT THAT 40% OF
THE TOTAL RESOURCES OF THE
DISTRICT. WILL BE COMMITTED TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. IF SUCH AN
AGREEMENT IS MADE THEN PROVIDES
AT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
SHALL PROVIDE- UP TO HALF THE
PHONES. THAT THE CITY AND
COUNTY COMBINED BEFORE WILL
HAVE THE COMMITMENT. IS BUT
ONLY IF THE LEGISLATURE HAS
APPROPRIATED FUNDS FOR THIS
PURPOSE AND WITHIN THE LIMITS.
OF WHAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS
APPROPRIATED WE ENVISION. AND
SUGGESTED THE BILL THAT THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL- AND
HOMELESS COORDINATING THE
FINANCING COUNCIL. DEVELOPING
GUIDELINES TO- FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF SUCH AN
EFFORT- THIS FOLLOWS NIFTY
TUNES COMMITMENT TO. INVESTORS
IN YOUR TRANSIT WHICH WE KNOW
HAS BEEN IN THE CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM IMPORTANT- OBJECTIVE OF
THE STATE. TO HELP REDUCE THEIR
BY. THE EMPTY. OF VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED AND GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS. SO- IT ALSO IN THE
BILL ALL INCLUDES 10% OF THE
TOTAL. WE INVEST- GREENING. AT
FIRST LAST MILE. PEDESTRIAN
BICYCLING INTEREST. THE OTHER
COULD PERCENT CAN BE IN IN
VARIETY OF INTERESTS PURPOSE.
INCLUDING INVESTMENTS IN THEIR
TRY SO IN. BEES OBJECTIVES ARE
SO TO WHAT THE STATE OF HAS
ADOPTED. NSK REDUCTION PROGRAM
I'M INTERESTED IN WHAT
COMMUNITIES AGENCY PROGRAM-
THAT EMPLOYS CAP AND TRADE
FUNDS WE SEE THIS AS A KIND OF
BOOKEND. TO THE HSE PROGRAM WE
PROVIDE HERE ALSO INCLUSION
LOVE LANGUAGE COMMITTING TO
SKILLED AND TRAINED LABOR. WE
BELIEVE THAT SKILLED TRADE
LABOR IS YOU PROBABLY STANDARD
FOR DISTRICTS LIKE THIS DO NOT
COVER THE ENTIRE STATE THE
CURRENT VOLUNTARILY AROUND THE
STATE AND DISTRICTS THAT WOULD
BE LIKELY TO BEING WELL
RESOURCE SINCE THEY'RE BRING IN
RESOURCES FROM THREE LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT. AND WE ANTICIPATE
THAT LABOR WILL BE IMPORTANT
PARTNER IN RAISING LOCAL FARMS
AND COUNTY FUNDS AND OTHERS TO
MAKE TEAMS COMING TO DISTRICTS
FLOURISH THIRTY SECONDS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME WE- RESPECT AND-
APPRECIATE VERY MUCH YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THESE ISSUES AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR GOVERNMENTS
AT THE TIME CRITICAL AND.
COMPLICATED TIME IN CALIFORNIA
HISTORY. THANK YOU SO MUCH. MRS
IN RIVER GRATEFUL FOR TEST
WE'RE GONNA SEE THERE'S ANYONE
HERE ROOM FORTY TWO THREE WOULD
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT THE BILL
HEARING SEEN UNDER TO THE OVER
FOR ROOM. NO ONE WISHING SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL IN THE
OVERFLOW ROOM. WE'RE NOT GOING
TO GO TO OUR MODERATOR AND OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE TO BE TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE SIXTY THREE. ABOUT A
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE
UP THOSE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE SIXTY THREE. YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE AND ZERO
OF YOUR IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
SIXTY THREE. AND MY MOMENT WE
DO HAVE ONE IN QUEUE AT THE
MOMENT THANK YOU. S. WERE
WAITING FOR THE MODERATOR WE'RE
GONNA REMIND FOLKS YOU CAN DIAL.
844-291-6364 IN THE CODE IS
SEVEN THREE SIX TWO EIGHT THREE
TWO IF YOU'D LIKE TO
PARTICIPATE. IN THE LIVE LINE
OR TELECONFERENCE LINE HERE
TODAY MATTER MODERATOR DO WE
HAVE ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE SIXTY THREE. YES WE HAVE A
LINE OF TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS RON MILLER ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL FIVE SIX
THREE. WE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH
SENATOR ALLEN AGAIN AND MOVE LA
THE SPONSORS OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH IT HEAR VOICES
MILLER THANK YOU SO MUCH THAT'S
GOING TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
NO FURTHER SUPPORT AND KILL.
ALL RIGHT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR AND I
NOW TURN IT BACK HERE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
TO SB FIVE SIXTY THREE WE DO
NOT HAVE A LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS ON RECORD WITH THE
COMMITTEE. CURRENCY KNOWN IN
THE RUMORED OR OVERFLOW ROOM
THAT'S ROOM TWENTY FORTY. AT
THERE IS NO ONE ROOM TWENTY
FORTY WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO
OUR TELECONFERENCE LINE. NOT A
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. IN OPPOSITION OF SB
FIVE SIXTY THREE. THANK YOU
LIVE HERE IN OPPOSITION OF SB
FIVE SIXTY THREE. YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN
ZERO IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION OF
SB. FIVE SIXTY THREE. MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NO OPPOSITION
INTO AT THE TIME THANK YOU
MATTER MODERATOR THIS BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE TO SEE IF WE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
OR A MOTION TO APPROVE. DO I
SEE ALL RIDE TOGETHER AND
ADDRESSES ON IT'S WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR ALSO ON SB
FIVE SIXTY THREE- IN ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS HEARING
C. NINE CENTER ON WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. PROFESSOR ABOUT
THANK YOU SO MUCH ALL RIGHT AND
GENTLEMEN. WE ARE NOW WITH THE
MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY CENTER
DRIVE SO WE'RE GONNA GO TO
MISTER GREEN NOW ON THE SERVER
NOW WHO WILL BE PROVIDING THE
MOTION. IS WELL AS- RECALLING
THE ROLE OF THE SERRANO. ROSHEN
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMEND AND RE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HOUSING. SENATOR
MCGUIRE I REQUIRE. A SENATOR
NIELSEN. NIELSEN SORRY SENATOR
DO ALSO. THERE ALSO ARE YOU
SENATOR HERTZBERG. THE MEASURE
WIENER. WIENER HI FORTY ZERO
CAN'T GIVE ME ONE MOMENT. THANK
YOU MEMBERS.
RIGHT RIGHT
JUSTINIANO. IF YEAH. YEAH THEY
WERE CONCERNED YEAH. ARE THESE
IN GENERAL THERE IS A FOUR
EIGHT ZERO VOTE A FOUR EIGHT
ZERO VOTE LAYS IN GERMAN WE'RE
GONNA KEEP THAT BILL ON HOLD IN
A NOTE THAT WE'RE GOING TO FIND
OURSELVES IN AUTHOR BECAUSE
WE'RE GONNA NEED IT SOONER OR
PARTS FOR TO ADD ON TO IT.
THANK YOU SEEN AROUND VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL KEEP
IT ON CALL. SO WE'RE LOOKING
FOR ANOTHER READY GIVEN ABOUT
SIXTY SECONDS. AND WE DON'T
HAVE AN AUTHOR WE'RE GONNA
INVITE SENATOR WIENER TO BE TO
PRESENT SB FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT.
LET'S GIVE IT SIXTY SECOND
SITES IN GENERAL- ANTI WE CAN
FIND ANOTHER.
ALL RIGHT BASIN
GENTLEMAN- WHAT WE'D LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO DO BECAUSE WE DO NOT
HAVE AN AUTHORED COMMITTEE. WE
ARE GOING TO TURN OF THE WAR
OVER. TO SENATOR WIENER CENTER
WIENER HAS TWO BILLS TO BE ABLE
TO PRESENT. HERE'S THE ITEM
ITEM THIRTEEN. SB SIX SEVENTEEN
SO WHAT WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
DO IS WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
TAKE. ITEM. TWELVE SB FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT- WHAT LOOK AT
THAT AS WE ACTUALLY HAVE CENTER
GROVE SO WHAT WE TURN OVER TO
TENER GROVE- TO BE ABLE TO
PRESENT- AND ON ITEM NUMBER
NINE WE'RE GOING TO DISINFECT
THE PODIUM- IN IN WE'RE GONNA
TURN IT OVER TO SENATOR GROVE.
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH I
APPRECIATE THAT CENTER WINNER
THANK YOU. THE LAYS IN GERMAN
HERE'S WHAT WE LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO DO I'D LIKE TO GO OVER THE
BILLS THAT WE HAVE LEFT TO TAKE
UP TODAY ITEM NUMBER NINE SB
SIX FIFTY EIGHT CENTER GROVE
HOUSING COMMITTEE WE'RE GOING
TO ASK THAT- SENATOR MAN.
PLEASE COME DOWN TO THE
COMMITTEE ROOM AND OUR
FANTASTIC SERGEANTS ARE GONNA
BE CALLING SENATOR MEAN TO BE A
TO COME PRESENT AND WE'RE ALSO
GOING TO CALL SENATOR CORTESE
TO BE A COME PRESENTED AS WELL
SO WE'RE LOOKING FOR SENATOR
MAIN INTERPRETATIONS HE- COULD
BE OVERCOME PRISON AFTER
SENATOR GROVE. FIRST AND
FOREMOST I WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO THE GOOD SENATORS IN A
ROW. FOR HER WORK ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE- MADAM SENATOR
YOU DO A BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
THE COMMITTEE TODAY THE FLOOR
IS YOURS AND WE WELCOME YOU TO
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE. THANK
YOU SIR VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS TODAY
IMPRISONING SP SIX FIFTY EIGHT
WHICH IS BEING SPONSORED BY
SENATE SAMBAR DINO COUNTY
ASSESSOR RECORDER CLERK MR BOB
DENTON FORMER SENATOR. THIS
MEASURE AUTHORIZES COUNTY
ASSESSOR'S TO OFFER A PARTIAL
PROPERTY TAX DEDUCTIONS FOR
DISABLED VETERANS A
PROPORTIONATE TO THEIR
PERCENTAGE OF DISABILITY RATING
PROVIDED BY THE U. S.
DEPARTMENT OF VETERAN AFFAIRS.
FOR THE MILITARY SERVICE IN
WHICH THE VETERAN HAS BEEN
DISCHARGED OTHER STATES OFFER
PROPERTY TAX CREDITS ON VARYING
DEGREES AND- MANY ALLOW
VETERANS TO QUALIFY WITH
DISABILITY RATINGS LESS THAN
1100% INCLUDING FLORIDA
ILLINOIS IN TEXAS. CURRENTLY
DISABLED VETERANS MAY REQUEST
REDUCTION ON THEIR PROPERTIES-
HOME SS VALUE FOR THE PURPOSES
OF DETERMINING PROPERTY TAXES
IF THEY ARE 1100% DISABLED
BLIND IN BOTH EYES OR HAVE LOST.
ONE OR MORE LIMBS. IF DISEASE
THE BETTER TO SURVIVE SPOUSE
ALSO QUALIFY. HOWEVER WITH THIS
WITHOUT THIS BILL A VETERAN
WITH A LIFE CHANGING 50%
DISABLED RATING WOULD BE WOULD
CONTINUE TO BE AN ELIGIBLE FOR
PROPERTY TAX DEDUCTIONS.
ACCORDING TO TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN DATA PROVIDED BY THE
U. S. DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS
AFFAIRS THERE APPROXIMATELY
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND VETERANS
WHO HAVE SOME LEVEL OF
DISABILITY RATING. M. AND IF
THEY OWN PROPERTY WOULDN'T NOT
TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR PROPERTY TAX
DEDUCTION IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN LOS ANGELES ALONE
THERE ARE APPROXIMATELY FIFTY
THOUSAND VETERANS HE WOULD BE
INELIGIBLE UNDER THIS CURRENT
LAW. AT A TIME IN TWO THOUSAND
AND EIGHTEEN THE VA ESTIMATED
THAT IN CALIFORNIA THERE'D BE
MORE THAN TEN THOUSAND HOMELESS
VETERANS. WHICH WAS FIVE TIMES
MORE THAN THE NEXT HIGHEST
STATE SB FIVE SIX FIFTY EIGHT
COULD- COULD BE THAT SAVING
GRACE FOR A VETERAN HELPING
THEM TO KEEP THEIR HOME TO GET
THEM THROUGH THE HARDSHIP UNTIL
THEY CAN GET BACK ON THEIR
FEET. WE ALL KNOW AND ARE AWARE
THE SACRIFICES THAT OUR
VETERANS MAKE WHEN THEY SWEAR
TO DEFEND OUR COUNTRY- WHAT WE
MUST ALSO REMEMBER IS THAT
VETERANS STRUGGLE TO ADJUST
BACK TO CIVILIAN LIFE AS WELL.
THIS TRANSACTION THIS
TRANSITION CAN EVEN BE MORE
DIFFICULT- FOR THOSE INJURED
WHILE SERVING IN WORST AND THAT
STRUGGLE WITH ILLNESSES-
ILLNESSES SUCH AS PTSD. THOUGH
THERE IS NO AMOUNT OF FINANCIAL
BENEFIT THEY CAN EQUAL THE
AMOUNT OF LOSS FOR THE DISABLED
VETERANS AND WHAT THEY FACE. SB
SIX FIFTY EIGHT CAN PROVIDE
MUCH NEEDED RELIEF FOR
STRUGGLING VETERANS AND THEIR
FAMILIES. FORMER STATE SENATOR
BOB DENTON HE WAS THE ASSESSOR
WHO IS THE ASSESSOR RECORDER.
FOR SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY IS MY
PER SPONSOR AND THE PRIMARY
WITNESS TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
AND HE'LL BE TESTIFYING
DEVELOPMENTS ARE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH CENTER GROVE WE ARE
GRATEFUL YOU'RE HERE TODAY
WE'RE NOT GOING TO TURN IT OVER
TO FORMER. SENATOR AND CURRENT
ASSESSOR CLERK RECORDER IN SAN
BENITO COUNTY THAT'S MISTER BOB
DUTTON AND OF COURSE WE ALWAYS
HAVE A SECTION FOR MR DUTTON IS
HE WAS ALSO THE CHAIR OF THE-
SENATE REVENUE AND TAXATION
COMMITTEE IS WELL- MISTER
SENATOR. THE FLOOR IS YOURS YOU
HAVE UP TO THREE MINUTES AND
WE'LL GIVE YOU THIRTY SECOND
PROMPT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE GOOD
SENATOR SENATOR GROVE. WELL I
THINK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AS
WELL AS MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR CONSIDERING THE
S. B. SIX FIFTY EIGHT- IS THE
GOOD SENATOR GROW IS SUPPORTED
OUT. I AM THE CUSTOMER DINO
COUNTY ASSESSOR THAT'S LIFE
AFTER BEING IN THE STATE
SENATE- THE AND IT BRINGS ME
GREAT PLEASURE TO PRESENT THIS
OPPORTUNITY WAS SENATE BILL SIX
FIFTY EIGHT- THIS ISSUE KIND OF
CAME UP- I USED. TO DO A LOT OF
RESOURCE FAIRS FOR VETERANS.
WHEN I FIRST GOT ELECTED AS THE
COUNTY ASSESSOR AND- ANSWER
THIS QUESTION KEPT COMING UP I
HAD PEOPLE THAT. WOULD HAVE
LIKE 90% DISABILITY AND THERE
WAS JUST NOTHING I COULD DO FOR
ME I HAD TO TELL NO. AND THAT
WAS REALLY DISHEARTENING. TO
LOOK AT SOMEBODY WHO'S WHO
SERVED HIS COUNTRY FAITHFULLY
WHO NOW. IN TODAY'S MILITARY
HIS YOU KNOW THE NATIONAL GUARD
PLEASE MORE CRITICAL ROLE THAN
IT DID BACK WHEN I WAS IN. THE
SERVICE BACK IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY. AND BECAUSE THEY'RE
NOT ONLY. HELP US HERE AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL BUT THEY ALSO. THEN
WE'LL GET COULD SOMETIMES
CALLED IN THE ACTIVE DUTY TO
SERVE. OTHER MISSIONS- AND
OTHER PARTS OF THE WORLD AS
WELL- THE CURRENTLY THE
DISABLED VETERANS EXEMPTION IS
ONLY AVAILABLE TO SOMEBODY
WHO'S TOTALLY DISABLED- THAT
MEANS A 100% AND THAT'S
DETERMINED BY THE VETERANS
ADMINISTRATION. WE HAVE OVER
TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND VETERANS
RESIDING HERE IN. SAN BENITO
COUNTY. WITH THE SERVICE
CONNECTED DISABILITY RATING.
AND OF THOSE ONLY ABOUT FOUR
THOUSAND VETERANS- HAVE A. 100%
DISABILITY RATING- THIS MEANS
IS BET SIX. ONLY APPLIES TO
ABOUT 16% OF THE DISABLED
VETERANS HERE IN SAMBAR DINO
COUNTY. AND EVEN IF A VETERAN
HAS A DISABLE READING OF 90%
CURRENT WHILE THE CURRENT LAW
DOES NOT ALLOW. THEM TO QUALIFY
FOR AN EXEMPTION. TOO OFTEN
WERE FORCED TO TURN AWAY
DISABLED VETERANS SEEKING. SOME
TYPE OF HELP OR ASSISTANCE. I
LIKE TO THINK- SENATOR GROW FOR
HER LEADERSHIP IN ON THIS ISSUE
AND I THINK IT'S CRITICAL WE
PROVIDE SUPPORT RESOURCES TO
OUR NATION'S. DISABLED
VETERANS. THEY MAKE A GREAT
SACRIFICE WAY SERVING OUR
COUNTRY AND DESERVING OF THIS
BENEFIT. ALSO I NOTICED IN THE
COMMITTEE REPORT THERE WAS
GOING TO BE- A POSSIBLE
CONSIDERATION OF AN AMENDMENT
TO ESTABLISH A- BOTTOM AND I
THINK THAT'S PROBABLY
REASONABLE I WOULD RECOMMEND.
FIFTY PERCENT- IF THAT WOULD BE
THE COMMITTEES DESIRE AND- AND
I CERTAINLY THINK IT WOULD BE
REASONABLE. WHAT YOU WANT THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR FAVORABLE
CONSIDERATION OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER AND AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SERVICE BOTH. IN THE
MILITARY AS WELL AS HERE- IN
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE.
LAYS IN GERMAN WE'RE NOW GOING
TO TURN TO ANYONE ELSE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL HEARING TEAM KNOWN
HERE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM ON
S. B. S. SIX FIFTY EIGHT WE'RE
NOT GOING TO GO TO. HAVE A
TWENTY FOUR OH FOUR- IN EXCUSE
ME TWENTY FORTY TWENTY FORTY
THERE IS NO ONE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SIX FIFTY
EIGHT. WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO
TOWARD TELECONFERENCING WE'RE
GONNA ASK THE MODERATOR TO
PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT AFTER. SB. SIX FIFTY
EIGHT NOW MADAME MODERATOR.
THANK YOU IF YOU ARE SUPPORT OF
S. SIX FIFTY EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS ZERO NOW. ONE
AND THEN ZERO IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX FIFTY EIGHT.
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE OF THE
THIRTY SIX YEAR LINE IS OPEN.
THIRTY LINE IS OPEN ON THE BILL.
NOT ON THIS BILL I WAS TRYING
TO SPEAK ON THE LAST CONCERN.
THANKS FOR THE LINE OF
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME IS SET THREE WHICH READ
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
REPRESENTING AMBER AT.
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION ACCOUNT
THAT FROM SERVICE OFFICERS
CALIFORNIA STATE COMMANDER
VETERANS COUNCIL. MILITARY
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA.
AND THE VIETNAM VETERANS OF
AMERICA ALL IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS LEGISLATION THANK YOU
NOT THANK YOU SO MUCH IS READY
FOR YOUR PHONE CALL LET'S GO TO
OUR NEXT. CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THERE WE HAVE
NO FURTHER SUPPORT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU MENTAL
MODERATOR I WILL BE RIGHT. NO
ONE HERE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY SEEN KNOWN IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WE'RE NOT GOING TO
GO TO OUR TELECONFERENCE LINE.
MADAM MODERATOR CAN PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO MAY
BE IN OPPOSITION. SB SIX FIFTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU HAVE HERE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SIX FIFTY
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN ZERO
HERE IN OPPOSITION OF SB. SIX
FIFTY EIGHT. MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE NO OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU SO MUCH
READING MODERATOR- THIS IS A
GREAT BILL AND APPRECIATE ALL
THE WORK AND THAT THAT MISS
GROVE IS PUT INTO THIS AND- HER
SERVICE IN THE MILITARY IS
WELL- IN HONORED THAT SHE IS
WORKING ON HER CONSTITUENTS
BEHALF EACH AND EVERY DAY AND
ESPECIALLY WITH THE VETERANS.
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SEE IF WE
HAVE A MOTION OR QUESTION
MOTION- MEDICINE OR DRUGS OKAY
WE OF COURSE WE HAVE A QUESTION
PLEASE AT CENTER DRIVES OF THE
FORESHORES YES- I WOULD BE
PREPARED TO- MOVE. THE BILL BUT
MY QUESTION IS AND IT WAS
RAISED I THINK BY CENTER DUTTON
IS THERE A BOTTOM THRESHOLD-
THAT IS BEING DISCUSSED. THERE
WAS NOT A THRESHOLD OR FLOOR
THRESHOLD AND THAT I'D BE
WILLING TO TAKE AN AMENDMENT.
ON THE FLOOR THRESHOLD IF- THE
WAY I ENVISION THE IN THE WAY
IT'S- THE WAY THE I ENVISION
THE BILL IS THAT RIGHT NOW.
CALIFORNIA VETERANS ARE
REQUIRED TO BE 1100% DISABLED.
A BLIND IN BOTH EYES OR YOU
LOSE ONE OR MORE LAMBS
WONDERED. ALOUD TO SEE ME TWO
OR MORE LINES. WHAT ABOUT A
DISABLED VETERAN WHO HAS HIS
ARM CUT OFF AND BECAUSE OF THAT
TRAGIC EVENT HE HAS PTSD AND
CAN'T FUNCTION IN SOCIETY. THIS
IS AN INDIVIDUAL THAT WOULD NOT
BE ELIGIBLE UNDER BENEFITS FOR
CALIFORNIA. SO I'M WILLING TO
WORK WITH YOU IN ORDER TO HELP
GET THE BILL PASSED MISS I'M A
DRAWS- BUT- I JUST THINK THAT
WE NEED TO PUT- VETERANS FIRST
AND- THIS. PARTICULAR BILL AND-
ONLY ADDRESSES THE ISSUES THAT
I THINK THAT VETERANS FACE
EVERY DAY- I HAVE OF. WOUNDED
VETERANS IN MY COMMUNITY A
DOUBLE AMPUTEE HAS NO PROBLEM
GETTING THESE TYPE OF BENEFITS.
BUT I ALSO HAVE A WITH A
VETERAN WHO IS- DEATH. I'M
ALMOST 80% DEATH BUT IT'S ONLY
A CERTAIN LIKE A 20% DISABILITY
RATING- BUT HE HAS TO READ YOU
KNOW SIGN LANGUAGE THINGS LIKE
THAT. AND THEN I HAVE ANOTHER
VETERAN THAT HAS LOST ONE ARM
AND THEY'RE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR
THESE BENEFITS AND I KNOW THAT
YOU HAVE A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
THE TRANSCEND YOUR DISTRICTS
I'D BE WILLING TO WORK WITH YOU
ONE OF. ON THE FLOOR. AND IF
THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL- MOVING
FORWARD I THINK THIS BILL IS
GOING TO BE REFERRED TO ANOTHER
COMEDIAN AND I'D WORK WITH YOU
ON THAT. WELL OUR IDEA- REALLY
APPRECIATED WHICH IS WHY I'M-
MOVING THE BILL. I JUST DON'T
KNOW. WHAT IT MEANS WHEN YOU
HAVE 5% DISABILITY OR 10%
DISABILITY AYE AYE I DON'T KNOW
PHYSICALLY WHAT THAT MEANS ARE.
OF MENTALLY WHAT THAT MEANS SO.
ARE. I RAISE IT BECAUSE IT I
THINK IT COULD- IT WOULD BE
CLEAR IF IT WAS A HIGHER A
HIGHER THRESHOLD THAN YOU KNOW
5% 3% HELP HOW FAR DOES THAT GO
SO I'M I'M GOING TO SUPPORT IT
BUT I JUST THINK THAT IT'S
OUGHT TO BE A CONSIDERATION
EVAN ABSOLUTELY NOTHING FOR
YOUR OFFER THANK YOU I'M M.
CENTER WE DO HAVE A MOTION ON
THE FLOOR EMOTIONAL FLOOR BY
SENATOR RAZA WOULD LIKE YOU TO
SEE IF WE NEED TO SHOW
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. AT
HEARING IN C. NINE. CENTER
GROUP WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
PLEASE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS CIRCUMCENTER
GROVE NICE WORK THANK YOU SO
MUCH ALWAYS GOOD TO SEE YOU
HOPE YOU HAVE A WONDERFUL
WEEKEND. WE HAVE A MOTION MY
CENTER DRIVE SO MISTER NOW IF
YOU CAN PLEASE READ THE
MOTIONS. AND CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
MILITARY AND VETERAN AFFAIRS.
SENATOR MCGUIRE AYE. MCGUIRE
HIS SENATOR NIELSEN. SENATOR
DRAWS SO TORONTO HI SENATOR
HERTZBERG. SENATOR WIENER
WIENER HI MISTER KNIGHT NIELSEN
R. FORTY ZERO THANK YOU SO MUCH
THAT IS A FOUR ZERO VOTE IS
CENTER WE'RE GONNA KEEP THE
ROLE OPEN AND ALLOW THE GOOD
MAJORITY LEADER TO BE ABLE TO
ADD ON AS SOON AS HE GETS A
COMMITTEE PCM- JUST COULD COME
OUR WAY IF YOU DON'T MIND. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH. NICE
JOB CENTRE ALL RIGHT. GERMAN
HE'S COMING TO A STREET FROM
ORANGE COUNTY HIS NAME IS
SENATOR MAN HE'S PRESENTING
ITEM NUMBER TEN SB SEVEN
NINETEEN. FOCUSING ON SURPLUS
LAND AND A FORMER MILITARY
BASES WE WELCOME. THE GOOD
SENATOR- COMMITTEE. WE'RE GOING
TO DISINFECT THE PODIUM AND
THEN WE'RE GONNA TURN THE FLOOR
OVER TO SENATOR MEN. TO BE TO
PRESENT SB. SEVEN NINETEEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR THE
FLOOR IS YOURS AND SEVEN
NINETEEN MISTER CHAIR EXCELLENT
JOB AND STAYING IN OF MOVING
INTO COMMITTEE ALONG. MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT SB SEVEN
NINETEEN TODAY. I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
STAFF. FOR THEIR DILIGENT AND
THOUGHTFUL WORK ON THIS BILL
AND I DO WANT TO SAY THE OUTSET
WE ARE ACCEPTING TAKE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN THE
COMMITTEE'S ANALYSIS. SB SEVEN
NINETEEN WOULD PROVIDE THE
TUSTIN LEGACY PROJECT WITH
LIMITED FLEXIBILITY UNDER THE
REVISED SURPLUS LAND ACT. WHILE
SETTING AGGRESSIVE A FORMAL
HOUSING TARGETS NOW FOR
BACKGROUND TESTING LEGACY IS A
MIXED USE DEVELOPMENT ON THE
SITE OF A FORMER MARINE CORPS
AIR STATION IN THE HEART OF
TUSTIN. THE CITY HAS BEEN
PLANNING AND EXECUTING THE
DEVELOPMENT OF TUSTIN LEGACY
FOR WELL OVER TWENTY YEARS.
THIS LAND WAS CONVERTED TO
CIVILIAN USE IN ACCORDANCE WITH
THE FEDERAL BASE REALIGNMENT
AND CLOSURE ACT IN NINETEEN
NINETY NINE. ANY TUSTIN LEGACY
REDUCE PLAN AN ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT REPORT WERE PREPARED. BY
CONTAINS THE PROPERTY WAS
APPROVED ON THAT BASIS BY
AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE. AND THE
CITY OF TUSTIN BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND TWO. SINCE THAT TIME
OF THE LAND TRANSFER FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO THE CITY
OF TUSTIN. EXTENSIVE
DEVELOPMENT HAS OCCURRED AS
PRESCRIBED IN THE REUSE PLAN.
FORMAL FOREIGN MILITARY BASES
HAVE BEEN UPDATED TO A VARIETY.
OF RESIDENTIAL EDUCATIONAL OPEN
SPACE AND COMMERCIAL USES-
SIGNIFICANT INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENTS HAVE BEEN MADE AND
THAT'S NO ECEPTION IN TUSTIN
TODAY. WHERE THEY DEVELOPED
ABOUT ELEVEN HUNDRED ACRES OF
THE SITE SO FAR. I INCLUDING
THIRTY EIGHT HUNDRED FIFTY
SEVEN UNITS OF HOUSING- NEARLY
18% OF WHICH ARE RESTRICTED TO
MODERATE OR LOWER INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS. AND FOUR HUNDRED
HOMELESS SHELTER BEDS. NOW IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THE
REVISED SURPLUS LANDS ACT DOES
NOT RECOGNIZE AGREEMENTS
BETWEEN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AND CITY- DOES NOT RECOGNIZED
FEDERALLY APPROVED REUSE PLANS
FOR FORMER MILITARY BASES. OR
AGGREGATE ENTITLEMENTS FOR
LARGE AREAS LIKE TUSTIN LEGACY
OF SURPLUS LAND ACT ON THE
OTHER HAND DOES AFFECT THE
CITY'S GOALS AND ABILITY TO
FUND INFRASTRUCTURE. CREATE
DIVERSE HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES
CREATE JOBS IN YOUR HOUSING AND
PROVIDE PUBLIC BENEFIT SHARED
BY THE ENTIRE COMMUNITY AT
TUSTIN LEGACY. THE CITY HAS
DONE ITS BEST BUT NEEDS
FLEXIBILITY UNDER THE REVISED
SLA TO ACHIEVE THE PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED GOALS. AND ALSO TO ME
IT'S FEDERAL OBLIGATIONS FOR
REDEVELOPING THE FORMER BASE
AND I WOULD I WOULD JUST ADD
THAT- IT'S IMPORTANT TO THINK
ABOUT THE FACT THAT THE CITY
MAY HAVE A STRONG LEGAL
ARGUMENT. FOR DEVELOPING A BASE
NOTWITHSTANDING THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE REVISED SLA
GIVEN ITS PRIOR AGREEMENT WITH
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT- BUT HE
HAS BEEN WORKING IN GOOD FAITH
TO DO ITS BEST TO TRY TO MEET
THE GOALS SET OUT IN THE S.
REVISED SLA. NOT MY BILL
SPECIFICALLY WOULD REQUIRE NEW
RESIDENTIAL UNITS BUILT ON THE
TUSTIN LEGACY SITE. TO MEET
EITHER THE FOLLOWING
AFFORDABILITY REQUIREMENTS IN
THE AGGREGATE. EITHER 20% OF
THE RESIDENTIAL UNITS WILL BE
ISSUED RESTRICTED TO PERSONS
AND FAMILIES OF LOW OR MODERATE
INCOME. FOR AT LEAST 15% OF THE
RESIDENTIAL UNITS. WOULD BE
RESTRICTED TO LOWER INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS AND 10% OF THOSE
UNITS AVAILABLE 10% YOU KNOW
UNITS AVAILABLE TO VERY LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS. I AM TOLD
THAT THE CITY OF TUSTIN THAT
THEY'RE WORKING THEIR BEST TO
TRY TO ACTUALLY GET 15% LOW
INCOME. IN THE AGGREGATE- BUT
WE WANT IT WILL PLAY MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO DO THIS ON A PARCEL BY
PARCEL BASIS AS REQUIRED BY THE
SURPLUS LANDS ACT. THAT TUSTIN
LEGACY IS ON THE LAST REMAINING
OPPORTUNITIES ORANGE COUNTY TO
PROVIDE FOR DIVERSE MIX OF
HOUSING JOBS EDUCATIONAL OPEN
SPACE UNITS SB SEVEN NINETEEN
PROVIDES NEEDED FLEXIBILITY FOR
THEM TO MOVE FORWARD- AND THIS
BILL WILL FACILITATE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THOUSANDS OF
HOUSING UNITS. AND HUNDREDS OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS IN
TUSTIN WHICH OTHERWISE WILL NOT
BE BILLED BY EXPEDITING.
HOUSING COULD A PRODUCTION
BRINGING JOB INCREASING AT. TO
SPACE. AND BUILDING NECESSARY
IN. FOR RUNNING. OUR ONLINE
TESTIFY IN OF IT SB SEVEN
NINETEEN WE HAVE THE CITY OF
TOXINS MERIT LETICIA CLARK AND
TRICIA MALONE WITH THE ANTI
DEVELOPMENT COMPANY AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
SENATOR AT MASON GENTLEMAN AS
WE MOVE INTO OUR WITNESSES WHO
DO IT LEAD TO SUPPORT WITNESSES
WE DO HAVE BIPARTISANSUPPORT-
ON RECORD ON THIS BILL. SO WE'D
LIKE TO BE ABLE FIRST TO GO TO
THE MAYOR OF THE GREAT CITY OF
TESTS AND WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT
MAYOR CLARK IS WITH US. AND
THEN WE'LL GO TO TRICIA MALONE.
CLARKI YOU ARE- WELCOMED INTO
COMMITTEE THE FLOOR IS YOURS
YOUR NOW LIVE MAYOR OF TESTING
MAYOR CLARK. THREE MINUTES.
THANK YOU- A GOOD DAY COULD
MIMIC WHAT IN COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME OF THE FUTURE CLARK I
AM THE MAYOR OF THE CITY
ATTENTION. THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE TO. ON BEHALF THE TOP
CAL. FROM SB SEVEN NINE RECORD.
THE UNIQUE SITUATION OF TUSTIN
LEGACY DIMENSIONAL SIXTEEN
HUNDRED VEHICLE. MILITARY BASE
BEING REDEVELOPED INTO MAKES
YOU COMMUNITY IN THE HEART OF
ORANGE COUNTY. BY WAY OF
BACKGROUND THE TOP ELECTED
PEOPLE DIDN'T THE ATTACHMENT TO
THE TWO. THE FEDERAL BANK ACT
USE. AND IF YOU CAN READ ABOUT
ARE GONE BY AGREEMENTS BETWEEN
THE FEDERAL. AND THE THIRTY THE
SURPLUS LAND BACK- AS AMENDED
IN TWENTY NINETEEN DID NOT A
CALPERS AGREEMENTS BETWEEN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND THAT THE
PEOPLE REDEVELOPMENT PROJECT
THE LEGACY. END OF THE SUPPORT
PLAN BAG. TO PRIORITY. WHAT MY
MENTAL UNDER UTILIZED OR INFILL
SITE OWNED BY AGENTS FOR
HOUSING. THE CITY OWNS PROPERTY
OUTSIDE OF THE LEGACY IN IS
PREPARED FOLLOW THE TERMS. AND
CONDITIONS OF THE AT THE LATE
HOWEVER I THINK YOU'LL AGREE
THAT CUT THE LEGACY OF ANYTHING
BUT SURPLUS. OR UNDERUTILIZED
PROPERTY UP IN TWO THOUSAND TO
ALMOST FOUR THOUSAND
RESIDENTIAL UNITS HAVE BEEN
BILLED AS MENTIONED BEFORE WITH
AN AGGREGATE AFFORDABLE
PORTABILITY OF ALMOST 18%
WITHOUT A MANDATE. ADDITIONALLY
COMPANY LEGACY HAS SPILLED
HOLDEN ANIMAL SHELTER. POSTAL
SERVICE THE CAMPUS SPONSORING
YOU OVER NINETY ACRES OF PARKS
AND OPEN SPACE AND OVER FOUR
HUNDRED PUBLIC SPENT. BY THE
ELDERLY WHAT PARTS BETWEEN
PERCENT TOTAL AFFORDABILITY ON
A PARCEL BY PARCEL APPROACH. AN
AGGREGATE AGGREGATE APPROACH
ALLOWS THE CITY TO FOR EXAMPLE
DO A MARKET WAIT FOR SALE
PROJECT. ON ONE PARCEL TO
GENERATE ENOUGH REVENUE TO FUND
THE NEXT MAJOR INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECT- ANYBODY THAT IS ABLE
TO DO PROJECTS WITH MORE
AFFORDABILITY ONCE A MAJOR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND PUBLIC
AMENITIES. ARE DEVELOPED ON
OTHER PARCELS INTO CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE COSTS FOR AN
AFFORDABLE DEVELOPER.
OPPOSITION INCLUDES GROUPS THAT
MY STAFF OF ALREADY MET WITH
FOR THE LAST EIGHTEEN MONTHS TO
ATTEMPT. TO FIND REASONABLE
SOLUTIONS. YOU COULD BELIEVE.
THE NATIONALLY THAT FORMER
MILITARY. PEOPLE TO REDEVELOP
THE GREAT. BUT BEFORE THE FOR
THOSE DON'T LOOK LIKE IT BUT NO
IT IN THE CHALLENGES OF THE
THIRTY LOOK HOW WE DEVELOPMENT
ACROSS. THE CREW HAVE STRUCK.
REALLY UNDER WHAT IT ARE WITH
THE- TO GET AFFORDABLE HOW
COSTS BUILT AT THE BAY. WITH
THE FUNDING. COURTS HAVE
MARKETS. RIGHT REPORT OUR
COMMITMENT TO. AFFORDABLE
HEALTH ACT OF THE LEGACY
REQUIRING. A TOTAL PER. MANDATE
A FIFTEEN TO TWENTY PER. WHICH
IS GREATER THAN THE MINIMUM
ACTUALLY. WITH YOUR SUPPORT WE
CAN ACHIEVE STATE BANK OF INDIA
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PRODUCTION
GOAL WHAT THE MEDIA OUR
OBLIGATION IN OUR- WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT I ASK FOR
YOUR STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
IMPORTANT BILL. FOR THE TO BE A
CONSTANT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR AN
AMERICA TAKING TIME IN YOUR
BUSY SCHEDULE TO BE ABLE TO BE
WITH US- IN APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY WE'RE NOW GOING
TO TURN IT OVER TO TRICIA
MALONE FROM ANTON. DEVELOPMENT
COMPANY- MISSED A LOAN YOU HAVE
THREE MINUTES AND I'LL GIVE YOU
A THIRTY SECOND PROMPT WE
WELCOME YOU. INDEED COMMITTEE
YOUR NOW LIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME TRICIA. THE MANAGER.
ALL THIS I DO LOT. GOOD MORNING
THE COURT ACROSS THE STREET.
NINETY ONE HUNDRED IS A MULTI
PLAN HOUSE TO THAT HAS EXTEND
EXPERIENCE WITH THE HARD. ONE
OF OUR IS LOCATED AT LEGACY
WITH TWO TWENTY FIVE YOU KNOW
THREE G. FROM TO A 120% THEY
MIGHT. OVER THE PAST TWENTY
FIVE YEARS AND COLLAB
COLLABORATED WITH TEN DIFFERENT
PUBLIC FOR TWENTY SIX HOW TO.
WE LOOKING IN THE CREATE OF
OVER THREE HUNDRED HIGH UNITS
IN A TOTAL AND OF TWO IN PUBLIC
PARTNERS. ANTON WE BUILD HOW
AND SUPPORT GOLD ALSO. OTHER OF
PRODUCING A HOW ACROSS THE
STATE WE UNDERSTAND THE AND
BUILDING THESE AND DIFFERENTLY.
PRODUCTION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IS NOT SAME ORANGE
RESIDENTS THE BEAR WELL NEWS
MORE THAN. KERN COUNTY HOWEVER
BLAST FUNDING. ACCORDING TO
HOUSING CAN. THANK LIKE AREN'T
COUNTY DO NOT THE SERGEANTS
YOUR APPROVED BY TECH FUNDS AND
SALES TAX REVENUE AND ISSUED.
ADAMANTINE WE RELY ON PARTNER
WITH PUBLIC A LIKE THE OF
AUSTIN SHE TO DELIVER HOW
ALLIANCE WITH THE REST OF THE
COMMUNITY WHEN I AND THEN. ARE
PRO. INTO COACH CHOSE TO BILL
IT HAS THESE GIVEN MIX OF JOB
RECORD. NO AND HOW TIED. BEEN
LOOKING. AND WILL CAN IN THE
FUTURE THE MIX. INTO AT LEGACY
AND LOOK JOHN CLOSE. HOW TO
INCREASE OUR CORE VERY CAN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FINING BUYER.
THE COMMUNITY THE PRAYER.
PERSONAL SO OF CONTEMPLATED
UNDER **** IS NOT ONLY IN. IT
IS NOT YOU WHICH THE ECONOMIC
LOW FOR OUR LOWER INCOME OR TO
FINANCE NEEDED TO GET OUT OF
THE HOUSE PROJECT. CURRENTLY
THE CITY OF IS ONE OF THE FEW
CITY WANTED CREATING NEW HOUSE
ARE. IN ADDITION CLOCK IN
PUBLIC BENEFIT. DUE TO
COMPARATIVE X. OF THE FORMER
MILLET BASE. HE WAY WOULD
IMPOSE AN OVER IMBALANCE OF
AFFORDABLE. RELATIVE OTHER
TYPES OF HOUSING JOBS AND
AMENITIES THAT I DON'T KNOW WAS
INTENT OF THE ACT. THE
FLEXIBILITY GRANTED WATER AS
PEACE. RECOGNIZE THE NEED TO
LONG JOB AND HOUSING AND- THE-
HOLDING CITY PART OF MANDATE
HIGHER THAN THE REVISED SLA WE
APPLAUD THE CITY BIRDS PASCO TO
HOUSING AND SUPPORT THIS CALL
COMMITMENT AT TUSTIN LEGACY
CARD I AM FOR YOUR FOR THE
IMPORTANT. THERE'S NO ONE AT
PREPARE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY WE'RE NOT
GOING TO GO TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE IF YOU'D
LIKE TO PARTICIPATE IN A
TELECONFERENCE FINE ON ANY THE
BILLS THAT ARE IN FRONT OF US
TODAY. PLEASE DIAL.
844-291-6364 NINE ACCESS CODE
IS. SEVEN THREE SIX TWENTY
EIGHT THIRTY TWO ALL RIGHT
MADAM MODERATOR THAT'S QUEUE UP
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF SENATE
BILL SEVEN NINETEEN BETTER
MODERATOR THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU IF YOU WERE IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN NINETEEN
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
ONE EIGHT NINE ZERO IF YOU WERE
IN SUPPORT OF SB. SEVEN
NINETEEN. MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
NO SUPPORT QUEUE AT THIS TIME
RIGHT NO SUPPORTING QUEUE THANK
YOU SO MUCH OF MATTER MODERATOR
WILL GET BACK TO YOU HERE IN
JUST A FEW MOMENTS. WE ARE NOW
GOING TO GO TO THOSE WHO ARE
OPPOSED TO SEVEN NINETEEN WE
HAVE TO LEAD WITNESSES- IN.
SUPPORT IN IN OPPOSITION WE
HAVE ESSAYS ARE- I'M GONNA
BUTCHER THE NAME THAT KARUBI IS
AS WELL AS- PEDRO GABO. SO I
CITIES ARE IS WITH THE KENNEDY
PEDRO'S NONPROFIT HOUSING
ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA SO- THAT'S GO TO- IS
HE'S OUR FIRST WITH THE KENNEDY
COMMISSION YOU HAVE. THREE
MINUTES SIR THE FLOOR IS YOURS
AND I APOLOGIZE IF I
MISPRONOUNCE YOUR NAME WE
WELCOME YOU TO COMMITTEE OF UP
TO THREE MINUTES THEY'LL GIVE
YOU THIRTY SECOND PROMPT YOU'RE
NOT ALIVE. A GOOD SERVER BLOOD.
VOCAL YOU DO NOT JOB. I
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF KENNEDY.
IN OREGON THAT WORKS ON
INCREASING THE HOUSING NOT FOR
HERE IN ORANGE. AND WE AND-
MANY OTHER AREAS. SUCH AS THE
ONE DO REP ARE VERY WITH
CREATING AFFORDABLE IN THE
FLOOR WHILE CRISIS. AND ALMOST
MISS AND ORANGE CHAU RANKS
AMONG THE TOP TEN NATION AFFORD.
AREAS IN THE NATION AND CAN TO.
HAVE CHALLENGES THE DRESS
HEALTH THAT LOW AND VERY LOW.
AND EXTREMELY INCOME COUNTY.
AND OFFICE SHOULD BILL TOWARD
PRIMARY REASONS ONE B. THE
HIGHER. BUT IT'S BEEN SO BY THE
BILL A MODERATE A V. COULD IN
CHOI AS I MENTION. IN OUR TOWN
IT IS FOR EXTRA LOW OVER LOW.
AND VERY LOW AND LOW INCOME.
TOMORROW THANK COUNTY. IT IS S.
BEING TAKEN CARE BY THE AND
PROBABLY TRUE TO HUNDRED ALL
LESS RENTS. YOU FOR CREATION OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND BY THE
AMENDMENTS BEING PROPOSED I
THINK WE'RE DEGENERATING ON
THAT PRIORITY EACH AND
EXPANDING IT IN AFFORDABILITY
AREA WHICH WILL NOT BE
ACHIEVABLE TO A LOT OF WORKING
FAMILIES HERE IN ORANGE COUNTY
AND THEN TRUST THEM. TO WE DO
THINK THAT WE DO NEED TO THINK
ABOUT THIS MORE CAREFULLY AND
THINK ABOUT THE IMPLICATIONS OF
THIS GONNA HAVE ALSO TWO OTHER
BASES THAT ARE ALREADY AGREEING
TO A HIGHER. PERCENTAGE AND THE
GREEN THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE
MORE DONE TO THE AFFORDABILITY
HERE LOCALLY. TO MAKE SURE THEY
WERE ADDRESSING OUR HOUSING
NEEDS AND AS I MENTIONED THE
PREDOMINANT BIG ISSUE FOR
DEVELOPERS IS THE ACQUISITION
OF LAND THAT THE CITY OWNED THE
LAND. AND TO THE SLA IT GIVES
IT A PRIORITY THAT WILL GIVE
MORE CERTAINTY THAT THIS
DEVELOPMENT POTENTIALLY COULD
ADDRESS THE AFFORDABILITY SO
WITH. THAT I WOULD LIKE TO ASK-
FOR THE YOU COMMIT TO. THE
OPPOSITE TO THE STILL AND.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I AND WE
APPRECIATE BEING WITH US TODAY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO OUR
SECOND LEAD OPPOSITION AGAIN WE
GIVE EQUAL TIME TO EACH SIDE
THIS IS AT PEDRO GRAVEL- HE'S
WITH THE NONPROFIT HOUSING
ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA PEDRO WE WELCOME YOU
TO COMMITTEE THE FLOOR IS YOURS
YOU ARE NOW LIVE YOU OF UP TO
THREE MINUTES. AND I'LL GIVE
YOU THIRTY SECONDS FROM GREAT
THANK YOU SO MUCH TERM ACQUIRED
VENTURE NEIL AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK. ON THE PEOPLE
TELEPHONE POLICY DIRECTOR WITH
THE NONPROFIT HOUSING
ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA OUR MISSION IS TO
CREATE A BAY AREA. EVERYONE HAS
A STABLE AND AFFORDABLE PLACE
TO CALL HOME. BEGIN BY SAYING
THAT WE APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD WITH
THE AUTHORS AND SPONSORS OF SB
SEVEN ONE NINE BUT
UNFORTUNATELY LIKE. OUR
COLLEAGUES FROM ORANGE COUNTY
AND MANY IN THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING COMMUNITY ACROSS THE
STATE. WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL UNLESS IT
IS AMENDED TO INCLUDE A 25%
AFFORDABILITY REQUIREMENTS TO
HOUSEHOLD. INCOME LEVELS. YOUR
CONCERN THE HARM SB SEVEN ONE
NINE WILL DO TO THE SURPLUS
LAND BACK TO WHICH MANY OF YOU
SUPPORTED. EXISTING
AFFORDABILITY COMMITMENTS AND
OTHER MILITARY BASE FOR THE
POLITICAL COST THE STATE AND
THE PRESIDENT IN FACT. IT IS
IMPORTANT TO CLARIFY CHIU
ASSERTIONS MADE BY THE MAYOR
AND SPONSORS- FIRST. SPONSORED
THE CIRCLE PLAN BACK NEVER
AGREED THAT MILITARY BASES
WORKS EXEMPT FROM THE SURPLUS
LAND. FACT THE LAW STATES THAT
UNLESS HOUSING IS EXPLICITLY
PROHIBITED ON THE LAND- THE
SURPLUS PLAN BACKED UP BY THE
SECOND ASSERTION ABOUT THE 50%
AFFORDABILITY REQUIREMENT. ONLY
COMES INTO PLAY AFTER A
PORTABLE HOLDEN DEVELOPERS HAVE
HAD A RIGHT OF FIRST REFUSAL.
THIS IS VERY CLEAR WHAT THE LAW.
FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY BY CAL.
SIX HOMELESSNESS ON ANY GIVEN
NIGHT. AND I NEED ONE POINT TWO
MILLION AFFORDABLE HOMES
CALIFORNIA EXPERTLY MARC
AFFORDABLE HOMES. NOT LAST.
THANK YOU SEVEN ONE NINE
UNDERCUTS THE SURPLUS PLAN
BACKED BY CREATING A MAJOR
EXEMPTION FOR SINGLE MILITARY
THINGS. PROVIDING AFFORDABILITY
REQUIREMENTS THE WHOLLY
INADEQUATE. FOR INSTANCE UNDER
THE PROPOSED AFFORDABILITY
SCHEME HEALTH CONVEYED CANADA
CREDIBILITY REQUIREMENTS BY
REQUIRING EITHER 20% OF THE
VALUE TO BE AFFORDABLE TO
MODERATE AND LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS. 15% AFFORDABLE TO
LOW AND VERY LOW. IN THE STREET
WITH THE MOB INCOME.
REQUIREMENT UNDER THE PLAN THE
AFFORDABLE RANGE FOR TWO
BEDROOM APARTMENT FOR MODERATE
INCOME HOUSEHOLD BEFORE IN
TUSTIN WOULD BE OVER THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH WHICH
IS NEARLY ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS
MORE THAN THE MEDIAN RENTS
INCOME AND RIGHT NOW FOR TWO
BEDROOM WHICH IS AROUND TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS. THIS WOULD
MEAN THAT COULD MEET SB SEVEN
ONE NINE THE COURT ABILITY
CONTRIBUTIONS I 20% MODERATE
WITHOUT PROVIDING ANY TRULY
AFFORDABLE. THANK YOU SEVERAL
NINE ALSO UNDER MAJOR FOR.
COMMITMENT THE FOURTEENTH
ECONOMIC. WITH OTHER ENABLE BE
WITH OTHER PIECES ACROSS THE
STATE. ALL OF WHICH ARE HIGHER
INCLUDING TREASURE ISLAND IN
SAN FRANCISCO A TWENTY SEVEN
PERCENT. THE CONCORD NAVAL
WEAPONS STATION. CONCORD AT
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT. ALAMEDA WE
USE- BAKED CLAMS AT 25%
AFFORDABILITY THIRTY SESSION
COSTS AND BE HELD TO A LESSER
STANDARD. SO WITHOUT ALL ALL
WRAPPED- WE ARE YOU STAND READY
TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSORS- BUT AT THIS TIME TO
REMAIN RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO
SB SEVEN ONE NINE THANK YOU AT
THE TIME. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY AS ALWAYS WE ARE
GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE IN
COMMITTEE INTO THOSE WHO WERE
IN SUPPORT AND IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU SO MUCH YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO BE SEEN IF WE HAVE
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL IN THE ROOM. HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM HERE AND SEEN
ON WE'RE NOT GOING TO CHECK IN
WITH ROOM TWENTY FORTY THERE'S
NO ONE IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
THIS TIME. WE'RE GONNA CHECK IN
WITH OUR PHONE LINES AND SAY
GOOD AFTERNOON TO MADAME
MODERATOR BETTER BATTERY OR
MATTER THAT I'M A MODERATOR I
SHOULD A- CERTAIN BRING IN SOME
CAFFEINE- IF YOU DON'T MIND AT
PLEASE KEEPING FOLKS UP. FOR
THOSE WHO WERE IN OPPOSITION.
OF SB SEVEN NINETEEN. THANK YOU
FOR AND- S. B. SEVEN. YOU MAY.
ONE AND THE ZERO NOW. ONE AND
THEN ZERO OF YOUR OPPOSITION SB
SEVEN NINETEEN. AND WE WILL GO
LINE OF THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
MARK STIVERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP YOU SHARE
THE POSITION OF THE KENNEDY
COMMISSION AND THEN PH THANK
YOU FOR CONSIDERING. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PHONE CALL NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO
FURTHER OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
SO MUCH I'M GONNA BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE LOOK I THINK THAT
I JUST REALLY QUICKLY ON THE
ISSUE OF A MAN'S- THAT THEY'D
AND I DON'T EVER WANT TO PUT
WORDS INTO CENTERS AND THAT
MEANS MATH WHAT ON THE
AMENDMENTS. AND THE NIMITZ DID
SLIGHTLY INCREASE THE
AFFORDABILITY REQUIREMENTS THAT
MUST BE MET- SO- LONG STORY
SHORT IT'S COMPLICATED BUT IT
DID SLIGHTLY INCREASE COMING
INTO COMMITTEE WITH THOSE
AMENDMENTS AND I KNOW THIS IS
AN ISSUE THAT SENATOR MAN IS
GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON IS
HE- WOULD MOVE THE BILL
FORWARD. I BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE
CENTER WIENER WHO WOULD LIKE TO
BE TO SPEAK IN POTENTIALLY-
VICE CHAIR CENTER WIENER. I
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN- THANK
YOU THE AUTHOR- I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY. AND
I KNOW THAT THE AUTHOR WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH- THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE. BY
CONCERNS BY- YOU KNOW SOMEONE
IS AUTHORED BILLS THAT HAVE HAD
AFFORDABILITY REQUIREMENTS AND
I KNOW THAT IT IS- IT IS.
COMPLICATED AND A LOT OF WAYS
BECAUSE WE ALL WANT TO HAVE THE
MOST AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IMPOSSIBLE FOR MAKING SURE.
THAT THE PROJECT IS STILL GOING
TO PENCIL OUT BECAUSE OF
PARTISAN PENCIL. THEN WE GET NO
MARKER RAY OR NO I KNOW
AFFORDABLE. AND AND I ALSO KNOW
THAT ON SOME OF THESE VERY
COMPLICATED SURPLUS LAND
PROJECTS A LOT OF SOME OF THEM
ARE NOT UNIQUE BUT THERE ARE
SOME LIKE THIS ONE APPEARS TO
BE THAT ARE. THAT CAN BE ARE
QUITE UNIQUE AND COMPLICATED IN
THEIR OWN WAYS AND I KNOW THAT
THIS IS A PROJECT THAT SHOULD
HAVE FRANKLY HAPPENED A LONG
TIME AGO AND HAS BEEN DELAYED
AND- HAS A REAL POTENTIAL TO
PRODUCE A LOT OF. HOUSINGS EVEN
THOUGH I. UNDER RISK BECAUSE OF
THE- OF THE THERE. LIVES
PERCOLATORS. BY FOR THEM SOME
OF THE SERVERS ALIGNED WITH
COMMON IN MANY WAYS- I ALSO
UNDERSTAND THE SITUATION HERE.
AND SOME HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE
BILL MOVE THE BILL- AND- AGAIN
I KNOW YOU'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO WORK. WITH THE FOLKS ARE
CONCERNED SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH WITH THE MOTION ON
THE FLOOR BY CENTER WE ARE NOW
GOING TO TURN OVER TO THE VICE
CHAIR GOOD AFTERNOON MR. MR
RICHER CENTER NIELSEN DID YOU
WANT TO SPEAK ON THIS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH I MISS CENTER
ATHLETE CENTER DRAWS A- YES-
THANK YOU I'M GLAD TO SEE THAT
AMENDMENTS ARE. COMING FORWARD
FOR THE ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN
RAISED BUT I TO HAVE- LARA. OF
CONCERNS ABOUT THE NUMBERS AND
THE AND THE PERCENTAGES OF WHAT
WILL BE- LOW. VERY LOW INCOME
AND HIGHER. UP PERCENTAGE FOR
MODERATE INCOME HIGHER
PERCENTAGE BUT IT WOULDN'T
INCLUDE MODERATE- AND I DON'T
WANT TO REPEAT WHAT EVERYBODY
ELSE HAS SAID BUT IN A- THIS IS
THIS WAS- PUBLIC LAND. I THINK
THAT'S THE CONSIDERATION WHICH
IS QUITE DIFFERENT FROM YOU
KNOW AN ENTIRELY PRIVATE
SECTOR- SITUATION WHERE WE
NEED. ON ONE WEEK I UNDERSTAND
THE ISSUE PENCILING OUT- IS
MUCH HARDER. BUT IN THIS CASE
IT'S PUBLIC LAND- SO. I GUESS I
WOULD SUPPORT IT BUT I WOULD
REALLY. BURJEEL AND NEED YOU TO
CONTINUE TO PUSH IN THE
DIRECTION OF A HIGHER
PERCENTAGE. ESPECIALLY FOR
LOWER OR VERY LOW OR AT LEAST
YOU KNOW THAT THE TWENTY
PERCENT- THAT SAYS FOR LOW OR
MODERATE MEANS THAT THE ENTIRE
20% COULD GO TO MODERATE ABOUT
RIGHT AND I AND THAT'S I THINK
THE PART THAT BOTHERS ME THE
MOST IS THAT THAT'S WHERE WE
COULD END UP SO I DIDN'T QUITE
CATCH EVERYTHING THAT- YOUR-
SUPPORTERS ARE EXPERT WITNESSES
SAID- BUT THAT'S THE BOTTOM
LINE HERE WITH ME AND I. I
REALLY BROUGH JUDE TO ADDRESS
THAT MORE SPECIFICALLY THANK
YOU SENAOR OTHERS THOUGH I
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION AND-
TEN SENATOR WIENER'S POINT WE
ARE WORKING CONSTANTLY WITH THE
STOCK WITH THE CITY TESTING TO
TRY TO INCREASE THOSE NUMBERS I
THINK ONE OF THE CHALLENGES IS
THERE SO MANY DIFFERENT PARCELS
TO BE DEVELOPED AND IT'S JUST
ABOUT FINDING FINANCING- BUT I
THINK- I DON'T PUT WORDS IN
MAYOR CLARK'S MOUTH BUT BUT I
BELIEVE WE'RE PREPARED TODAY.
TO COMMIT 215% AGGREGATE LOW
VERY LOW AND EXTREMELY LOW SO
15% OF THE ADVOCATE UNITS
BUILT- GOING FORWARD WOULD BE
IN THAT CATEGORY- AND SO IT
WOULD NOT BE AS YOU RAISE THE
CONCERN LIKE 20% JUST ALL IN
THAT MODERATE RANGE 15% AT
LEAST WOULD BE LOW VERY LOW AND
EXTREMELY LOW IS THAT CORRECT.
MAYOR CLARK. HI WITH PERMISSION
FROM THE CHAIR TODAY PETROL
BRAG. YEAH ALL DARI. SHARE I
KNOW PLEASE MADAM MAYOR PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU- YEAH I
THINK YOU'RE A GOOD MAN AND LET
ME REASSURE THE COMMITTEE THAT
OUR OUR COMMITMENT TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS THE
EXTREMELY STRONG AND PREVALENT
AND- WE ARE MUCH AWARE OF. THE
CHALLENGES HERE IN ORANGE
COUNTY WE HAVE A LOT OF RESPECT
FOR THOSE WHO ARE EVEN OPPOSED
TO THE DOWN AND WANT TO WORK
WITH THEM- BUT GALLAGHER
MINUTES CORRECT THIS IS NOT YOU
KNOW A GOTCHA GAME OVER WE'RE
GOING TO PUT IN A 20% MODERATE
THIS THIS IS AN EFFORT TO.
ACHIEVE YOUR GOALS BUT ALSO A
LITTLE BIT OF FLEXIBILITY GIVEN
THAT WE HAVE SO MUCH-
INVESTMENT TO MAKE AN
INFRASTRUCTURE AWESOME ON THAT
LAND. SO- YOU ARE CORRECT IN
THEIR DEMAND. AND A I AM JUST
THE STATE WE ARE COME TO WORK.
WITH THOSE OPPOSE THE BILL. ON
A ON GOING BASIS AS THIS BILL
CONTINUES TO PROCEED TO THE
FLOOR. ASSEMBLY GET SENATE
COMMITTEE TODAY. THANK YOU SO
MUCH VERY GRATEFUL ALL RIGHT
AGAIN IT CAN BE EITHER 20% LOW-
IN MIND OR 50% LOW AND VERY LOW
AND THAT IS WHERE I CENTER
MEANS IS- IS THAT NOW IN
GRATEFUL FOR HIS WORK ON THIS
AND AGAIN WITH CENTER MAN- HE
CONTINUES TO WORK- ON ON THIS
ISSUE AS WE MOVE FORWARD SO
VERY VERY GRATEFUL TO ADD TO
THE GOOD SENATOR FOR HIS
COLLABORATIONS INFORMED ALL
RIGHT. WE HAVE A MOTION WITH
THE MOTION ON THE FLOOR THE
MOTION ON THE FLOOR BYE BYE
CENTER WIENER ON SB SEVEN
NINETEEN CINNAMON WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU ALL
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I JUST WANT TO
REITERATE A POINT THE CENTER
WIENER MADE THAT WE NEED
CRITICALLY- AFFORDABLE HOUSING-
BUT THAT THIS PROJECT REALLY
HAS BEEN HELD UP SHOULD HAVE
BEEN COMPLETED MANY YEARS AGO-
AND RIGHT NOW WE'RE IN SORT OF
A CROSSROADS WHERE. WE CAN
EITHER CHOOSE TO BUILD A GOOD
AMOUNT OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
WITH A CITY COUNCIL THAT IS
COMMITTED TO THAT WITH ME
PUSHING CONTINUOUSLY TO TRY TO
INCREASE THOSE NUMBERS OR WE
CAN LET THIS SIT IDLE AND
UNDEVELOPED IN I WOULD URGE YOU
TO CONSIDER THE UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THE TUSTIN
LEGACY SIDE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH CENTER MAIN ALL RIGHT
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE WE GOT A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY CENTER
WIENER WE'RE NOT GOING TO TURN
IT OVER TO MR NOW TO GET A READ
THE MOTION THAT'S IN FRONT OF
THE COMMITTEE. IN CALL THE ROLL
MISTER GRAHAM. THE MOTION IS
TO. A CEMENT. BEFORE AMENDED.
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR
MCGUIRE. HI WATER BY SENATOR
NIELSEN. NIELSEN HI SENATOR
DORADO DORADO HI SENATOR
HERTZBERG. SENATOR WIENER
WIENER HI BORDER ZERO. THANK
YOU SO MUCH CENTERMAN WE'RE
GONNA KEEP THIS BILL OPEN TO
ALLOW THE MAJORITY LEADER AND
ON WHEN HE GETS INTO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS CAN I THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU CENTERMAN PROCEED TO
WORK. THANK YOU GENTLEMEN ARE
COULD BE MOVING ON TO SENATE
BILL SEVEN EIGHTEEN THAT CENTER
CORTESE. FOCUSING ON PUBLIC
INVESTMENT AUTHORITIES WE
APPRECIATE CENTER CORTESE SAID
PATIENTS HERE TODAY AND HANG IN
WITH US. WE ALWAYS LOVE HAVING
THE GOOD SENATOR FROM SAN JOSE-
IN COMMITTEE. SECRETASE WHEN WE
ARE DONE WITH THE DISINFECTANT
AND THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR DOING
THAT BY THE WAY OKAY VERY
APPRECIATIVE. BUT WE ARE GOING
TO TURN OVER USED TO THE FLOOR
IS YOURS ON SB SEVEN EIGHTY
MEMBERS I'M GONNA NEED TO STEP
OUT FOR ABOUT FIVE MINUTES TO
GO TO A QUICK MEETING. AND I'LL
BE RIGHT BACK IT'LL TURN THE
GAVEL OVER TO THE VICE CHAIR-
BUT I'LL BE BACK IN ABOUT FIVE
MINUTES AND I DO APOLOGIZE
CENTER CORTESE THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. ON SEVENTY. OKAY
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN SANDERS- I
THINK YOUR PATIENTS THIS
AFTERNOON PROBABLY FOR EXCEEDS.
MINE TODAY I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT SB SEVEN EIGHTY A BILL
THAT IMPLEMENTS. CHANGES TO
BOTH ENHANCE INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCE DISTRICTS. ALSO KNOWN
AS HE I. F. D.'S. ON A
COMMUNITY REVITALIZATION
INVESTMENT AUTHORITY LAW. ALSO
KNOWN AS C. R. I. A.'S. HI THIS
IS TO HELP CITIES AND COUNTIES
USE THESE TOOLS TO FINANCE
LOCAL DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS.
SINCE THE ELIMINATION OF
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES IN
TWENTY ELEVEN. THE LEGISLATORS
ENACTED SEVERAL TAX INCREMENT
FINANCING TOOLS TO SUPPORT
INFRASTRUCTURE AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT TO ADDRESS
OUR HOUSING CRISIS. HE I HAVE
THESE IN C. R. I. A.'S HAVE A
MURSI'S TOOLS THAT ALLOW LOCAL
AGENCIES TO USE TAX INCREMENT.
OR PARTICIPATING ENTITIES TO
FUND INFRASTRUCTURE AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS.
HOWEVER THE MINIMAL UPTAKE OF
BOTH THE IVIES AND CRA'S IS
PROVING THAT THEY'RE OVERLY
CUMBERSOME TO ESTABLISH AND
OPERATE. WITH A HOUSING CRISIS
RAVAGING CITIES AND COUNTIES
ACROSS THE STATE THREE
REVITALIZATION OF THESE TOOLS
IS WELL OVERDUE. SB SEVEN
EIGHTY MAKE SEVERAL CHANGES TO
E. I. F. T. AND C. R. I. A LAW.
THAT WILL ENABLE LOCAL AGENCIES
TO USE THESE TOOLS TO
EFFECTIVELY STIMULATE
DEVELOPMENT IN THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. AMONG OTHER
IMPORTANT BUT MINOR CHANGES THE
BILL STREAMLINES THE PROCESS
FOR AMENDING EXISTING PLANS.
EVERY RIGHTS THE TENURE PROTEST
PROCESS IN C. R. I. A LAW TO
MAKE C. R. I. A.'S IN E. I. F.
D.'S MORE VIABLE FOR LOCAL
AGENCIES TO CREATE AND OPERATE-
TAKES UP THE AMENDMENTS THE
REFLECTED IN COMMENTS SIX OF
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. ANYONE
THINK THE CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
CONSOLES FOR WORKING WITH US
EXTENSIVELY ON THIS BILL. BUT
HERE WITH US TO SUPPORT OUR
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT. IS GROUP
BACKS SODA FROM CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR LOCAL ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. AND MICHAEL LANE
FROM SPUR IN I BELIEVE WE ALSO
HAVE A DENTURE. AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER TECHNICAL QUESTIONS SO
SHOULD THEY COME UP- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR RIVAL. ONE FOUR.
SUPPORT TESTIMONY. GOOD
AFTERNOON VICE CHAIR IN
SENATORS CAN YOU HEAR ME OK.
YES GREAT THANK YOU MY NAME IS
KIRK BAXTER HOTEL AND I'M THE
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
LOCAL ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
CALIBER PRESENTS OVER EIGHT
HUNDRED LOCAL ECONOMIC
DEVELOPERS AND STAKEHOLDERS
UNDER THE BOOTS ON THE GROUND
PROFESSIONALS THAT ARE HELPING
BUSINESSES THRIVE GROWING LOCAL
ECONOMIES AND CREATING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CALIFORNIANS.
OUR MEMBERS UNDERSTAND THE
VALUE OF THE BENEFITS THAT TAX
INCREMENT FINANCING CAN BRING
TO LOCAL ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
EFFORTS INCLUDING HELPING
SUPPORT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
SOLUTIONS AS WELL AS BUILDING
AND REPAIRING INFRASTRUCTURE.
MANY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
EXPLORING USING EFT FOR
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT AS WE LOOK TO
ECONOMIC RECOVERY AND OTHERS
ARE CONSIDERING CREE AS WHICH
HAVE A SPECIFIC FOCUS ON
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. SO LAST
FALL PALETTE CONVENE A WORKING
GROUP OF ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
PRACTITIONERS TO REVIEW THE
EXISTING TAX INCREMENT
FINANCING TOOL. FOR SUGGESTED
IMPROVEMENTS TO MAKE THESE
TOOLS MORE WORKABLE ART ARE
CONTAINED IT SB SEVEN EIGHTY
AND THE COMMITTEE THAT THE
TELCO SPECIFICALLY ANALYSIS AS
WELL. WE APPRECIATE SENATOR
CORTESE AND HIS STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH KHALLID ON THESE
ISSUES WE ALSO THINK THE
COMMITTEE GAP AND THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES FOR THEIR
SUGGESTIONS. BY VARIOUS
CLARIFICATIONS AND IMPROVEMENTS
WHICH ARE NOW REFLECTED IN THE
BILL INCLUDING WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT FOR SB.
SEVEN EIGHTY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ANDREW DO WE ONE MORE
WITNESS WE HAVE A DANIEL.
CARRICO. MICHAEL LANG WAS BURKE.
MISTER LANE IS THE OTHER LEAD
SUPPORT WITH MR CEDAR IS ONLY
AVAILABLE FOR TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS OKAY AND- WOULD. GIVE
ACTUAL HODA. JUST WENT BY HERE
HELLO THE NUMBERS MICHAEL LANG
WITH THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA
PLANNING URBAN RESEARCH
ASSOCIATION. PUBLIC POLICY
THINK TANK KNOWN AS FOR. AS
ALWAYS THE COMEDIAN ALSO QUITE
COMPREHENSIVE AN EXCELLENT.
WITH THE DISSOLUTION OF
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES IN
TWENTY ELEVEN ALL OF US TO
SPENT THE PAST DECADE WORKING
ON REPLACEMENT TOOLS FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT CAN ALLOW FOR
BROWN TO REMEDIATION.
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS AND
UPGRADES ASSEMBLAGE OF PARCELS
AND PRODUCTION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. WE HAVE WORKED ON THE
IFT IS CREE AS NIFTY IS AN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AUTHORITIES.
IN ORDER TO RECREATE AT LEAST
SOME OF THE EFFICACY OF TAX
INCREMENT FINANCING. WE
AVAILABLE REDEVELOPMENT
UNFORTUNATELY WHILE I'M AWARE
OF DOESN'T THE JURISDICTION OF
TAKING A HARD LOOK AT SETTING
UP THESE TYPES OF DISTRICTS YOU
AND USING THESE NEW TOOLS ONLY
A HANDFUL OF ACTUALLY FOLLOW
THROUGH US UNDERLINED THE NEED
TO LISTEN TO LOCALS AND
CONTINUE TO IMPROVE AND PERFECT
THESE TOOLS. SB SEVEN EIGHTY
WILL MAKE YOUR AFTER USING CREE
AS MORE USER FRIENDLY ANOTHER
TACTIC WHAT IS NEEDED RIGHT
NOW. TO ALLOW THESE TOOLS TO BE
USED MORE WIDELY WE URGE AN AYE
VOTE. THAT WILL BE THE ALL OF
YOUR SUPPORT WITNESSES AND
SENATOR. A YES FOR SURE THAT'S
THE TO LEAD SUPPORT WITNESSES
AGAIN MISTER KIRK WILL BE ON
THE LINE BUT AVAILABLE LATER
WHEN YOU- WHEN YOU COME BACK TO
COMMITTEE IF THERE'S ANY
DISCUSSION OR QUESTIONS SOME.
THE LEGISLATIVE WITH RIGHT BACK
PLEASE WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION IS THAT CORRECT.
NONE THAT I'M AWARE OF RIGHT.
LET'S SERVICES THAT I HAVE THE-
MODERATOR PLEASE CHECK ONLINE.
YOU HAVE ANY INTO FOUR SUPPORT
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU IF YOU
WERE IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
EIGHTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN ZERO
FOR SB SEVEN EIGHTY IN SUPPORT.
WE WILL GO LINE OF- WE WILL GO
TO THE LINE OF ONE SIXTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONE ONE SIXTEEN.
AM I ONE ONE SIXTEENTH- WE TOOK
THREE HOURS TO GET THROUGH.
CALLING TO SUPPORT GROWTH OKAY
SB. SIX FIFTY EIGHT. WORK OUT
OKAY BUT THAT IS NOT THE ONE
I'M IN THE COMMITTEE ON MAN. SB
SIX FIFTY EIGHT I'M TRYING
SUPPORT HER BILL RON CORTESE SB
SEVEN EIGHT ALL. WELL IT'S NOT
INTUITIVE FOR CALIFORNIA TWO
HOURS TO GET A LINE. BUT I WANT
TO SPEAK ON GROW SHE WAS JUST
WATCHING AND I COULDN'T GET
THROUGH I KEPT PUSHING ONE ZERO
ONE ONE GIVE ME A LINE BUT I
DID IT YESTERDAY IN THE
ASSEMBLY AT WORK JUST FINE.
ACTUALLY CALLING ABOUT GROW
THIS BILL I'M BIG SUPPORTER
GROW BA GROW FOR GOVERNOR.
GOVERNOR SB SIX FIFTY EIGHT
THAT'S WHAT I WANT TO SUPPORT
THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY MORE
MODERATOR IN SUPPORT WOOD
MISTER EIGHT THANK YOU OF THE
NEXT PLAN OF ONE OH WAIT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON-
MISTER MEMBERS JASON RILEY
CALIFORNIA CITIES WE ARE
PLEASED TO SUPPORT THE MEASURE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO
LINE OF EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
TEACHER MEMBERS ROD WHEELER FOR
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON.
PORT SB. SEVEN EIGHTY. THANK
YOU MEXICO LINE OF ONE
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS IS MAX
PERRY ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
WEST SACRAMENTO AND WE ARE ALSO
IN SUPPORT THANKS. THANK YOU AN
EXTRA LINE OF ONE FOURTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I THANK YOU RUN A
CONCEALABLE CRUISE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BOARD ACTION FUNDS
WERE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND
ONE SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE SIXTEEN. AND MY ONE ONE
SIXTEEN. YOU READY TO GO ONE
AND MY NAME. THE BILL SCENE I
WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE CAR TO
BE BUILT. STRONG OPPOSITION TO
THE COURTS OF THE BILL BUT I'M
IN SUPPORT OF THE GROUP. YOUR
SELF WE'RE GOOD E'RE IN
SUPPORT TESTIMONY NOW YOU WILL
BE SHORTLY UP IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. SHOULD
HAVE A COURTESY BILL. WE WERE
ON THAT. WE'RE WE'RE
ENTERTAINING SUPPORT TESTIMONY
RIGHT NOW OPPOSITION TESTIMONY
WILL BE SUBSEQUENT TO THIS
SUPPORT TESTIMONY. THANK GOD WE
HAVE NO MARCH SUPPORT IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT THEN
MA'AM ARE YOU ON STILL FOR
OFFERING YOUR OPPOSED THE
TESTIMONY RESEARCHER.
PRESERVATION OF AMERICA I THINK
WE HAVE TO ASK FOR FORTY TWO OR
THREE IN TWENTY FORTY AS WELL.
CUT. SEVEN ZERO GO GO GO AHEAD
AND. THE TESTIMONY. FIFTY I
DON'T THINK WE ASKED IF THERE
WAS ANYONE TO SUPPORT TESTIMONY
IN FORTY TWO OF THREE OR TWENTY
FORTY. BUT THAT'S ALL I'M SORRY
WITH THAT WE DIDN'T YES YES AND
DOES WELL WE DO NOT. SEE ANY
HERE IN THIS ROOM- THAT WOULD
BE A IN SUPPORT TESTIMONY. NO
ORDER LET'S GO TO TWENTY FORTY.
AND NOBODY SEEMS TO BE IN THAT
ROOM EITHER OKAY THE RESTAURANT
AND THEN. WOULD THERE BE ANY
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY IN EITHER.
THIS ROOM OR IN TWENTY FORTY I.
DON'T SEE ANYBODY NEEDS A PLACE.
PHIL THAT'S NOT THE ISSUE. DO
WE HAVE OR OTHER PERSON WHO
WANTED NOW TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. IF YOU WERE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN EIGHTY
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. NINE ONE SIXTEEN. THING
I'M TRYING TO SPEAK IN. THE
GROWTH BILL AND IN OPPOSITION
TO THE COURT THE BILL. I WIENER
AND SHARING ALL OF THE SUDDEN
EXIT NIELSEN SUPPOSED TO
CHAIRED SINCE MCGUIRE LAST.
THANK YOU GET THROUGH NOBODY
CAN GET A LINE ONE ZERO WE
PRESS ONE ZERO ONE ZERO NOBODY
CAN GET THROUGH WHAT ARE YOU
JUST TRYING TO CUT PEOPLE OFF
LIKE YOU DID WITH O'DONNELL
YESTERDAY WHEN HE GOT OFF KILEY.
TRYING TO CALL AND NOBODY CAN
GET THROUGH. ALL WE- WENT NAY
WIENER CHEERING THEM YOU ARE
COMING THROUGH LOUD AND CLEAR.
AND THE GIRL WILL IS NOT BEFORE
US. THE CORTES A BILL IS BEFORE
US AND YOU'RE WELCOME TO GIVE
US YOUR TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION
TO THE CORTES SHE BILL SB SEVEN
EIGHTY IF CERTAINLY YOUR DESIRE.
AGAIN IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
AND I. THEN THE INDUSTRY.
WORKING PEOPLE. AND AGAIN IF
YOU WERE IN OPPOSITION OF SB
SEVEN EIGHTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT HERE WE
HAVE AN OBLIGATION. DO WE HAVE
ANY FURTHER OPPOSITION IN THE
QUEUE OPERATOR. THERE IS NO
FURTHER OPPOSITION IN Q. NO
MORE ALL RIGHT IN THE. BROUGH
THAT SAID THEN- LET'S COME BACK
TO COMMITTEE MOVABLE. WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM SENATOR WINNER TO
MOVE THE BILL. WOULD THERE BE
ANY IN THEM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WISHING TO COMMENT OR
OBSERVER ASK QUESTIONS OF THE
WITNESSES. SHINGEN WHERE MOTION
FOR CENTER CORTES IF YOU'D BE
SO KIND AS TO GIVE US YOUR
CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER SURE
ENOUGH THANK YOU SENATORS FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. IF. YOU HAVE TO EXCUSE
ME I HAD SOME MAJOR SURGERY
LAST WEEK AND ONE OF MY YEARS
HAS GIVEN ME A LESS SERVICE
THAN NORMALLY AND DASH. THIS
UNDERSTANDABLE IN- I JUST CLOSE
BY THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. OF A
THINKING OF THE OTHER SENATORS
HERE. AND BY RESPECTFULLY
ASKING FOR YOUR AYEVOTE AND
I'M SORRY IF I WASN'T MEDIAN
AND ENOUGH TO THE MICROPHONE
EARLIER THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR. AND WOULD YOU CALL THE
ROLL. MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMENDED AND
WE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HOUSING SENATOR MCGUIRE.
SENATOR NIELSEN HI NIELSEN HI
SENATOR DORADO DORADO HI
SENATOR HERTZBERG. SENATOR
WIENER WIENER HI THREE ZERO
PLAYSET THE LONG CALL. THANK
YOU WILL. AND I BELIEVE THAT
WITH THAT COMPLETES OUR AGENDA
BUT WE SHOULD WAIT TILL THE
CHAIR RETURNS. OKAY.
CENTER
WHERE YOU HAVE TO BILLS. AND
WILL NOT RETURN THE CHAIR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER VICE
CHAIR IN DEAD. IT INTELLIGENCE
LAYS IN GERMAN I APOLOGIZE I TO
GO TO A QUICK MEETING. SO FIRST
AND FOREMOST I WANNA TAKE A
MOMENT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
SENATOR WIENER CENTER WINNER
AND I HE'S VERY CAPABLE STAFF
TEAM AND THE TEAM FROM
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE A OF
COURSE LED BY ANTON FAVORING
CHARBAGH ON THIS SPECIFIC ISSUE
HAVE BEEN MEETING ON FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT. THERE ARE
SEVERAL AMENDMENTS THAT ARE IN
FRONT OF THE COMMITTEE TODAY ON
SENATE BILL FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT-
THAT WILL EXEMPT STATE AND
LOCAL HISTORIC DISTRICTS
REMOVED- IT SINGLE FAMILY ZONES
BY SPECIFYING THE BILL MUST BE
ZONED FOR MULTI FAMILY
RESIDENTIAL OR MIXED USE BY
LOCAL GOVERNMENT IT STARTS NOW.
AT THREE UNITS INSTEAD OF TO
ENSURE THAT IT APPLIES TO MULTI
FAMILY PROJECTS- WE ARE
LIMITING AT THE BILL THANKS TO
THE COLLABORATION BY THE WAY I
WOULD SAY WITH THE CENTER
WIENER WE ARE ABLE TO COME TO
CONCLUSION ON THAT FOCUSING ON
URBANIZED AREAS IN URBAN
CLUSTERS VERSUS. RURAL AND OF
COURSE REMOVING A LOT SIZE
PROVISIONS- IS WELL AGAIN THIS
IS ALL BEEN IN COLLABORATION
WITH SENATOR WIENER AND I WANT
TO TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO SENATOR WIENER WE HAVE
WORKED ON SEVERAL BILLS
TOGETHER OVER THE YEARS- AAN DE
HE'S ONE OF THE BEST- ON BEING
ABLE TO WORK WITH EACH OTHER
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU SIR- AND WANTED TO BE ABLE
TO. SAY TO THE COMMITTEE YOU
NOW HAVE AN IMMENSE IN FRONT OF
YOU HONESTLY FOR SEVENTY EIGHT
I JUST WANT TO READ THEM ALOUD
IS WELL IN AND TURN IT OVER TO
SENATOR WIENER TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE A STATEMENT AND THEN-OBVIOUSLY I'D SAY ANYTHING IN
REGARD TO WHAT I JUST SAID. IN
THAT COLLABORATION THAT WE'VE
HAD COMING INTO COMMITTEE TODAY
CENTER WHERE THE FLOOR IS YOURS
ON SB FOUR SEVENTY THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND-
IN ADDITION TO WHAT YOU SAID
WERE ALSO THE F. A. R. WILL BE
ONE POINT OH FOR THREE TO SEVEN
UNITS AND ONE POINT TWO FIVE
THREE TO TEN- AND- THE LOT SIZE
PROVISIONS. WILL BE AS LONG AS
THEY'RE IN THE BILL NOW WILL BE
REMOVED ON THERE WILL BE A NEW
REQUIREMENT. PROHIBITING LOCAL
AGENCIES FROM THE NINE YOUR
PRODUCT. SOLD BECAUSE EXIST LAW.
HAS A NON CONFORMING SIZE. AND
THERE ARE ALSO SOME- TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS. RELATING A LOT
COVERAGE. SO THEY ARE ON THE
DOCUMENT YOU JUST HANDED OUT-
AND- MISTER JOHN. MISTER
CHAIRMAN I WANT TO THANK- YOU
IN YOURSELF FOR WORKING WITH US
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO. ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES. AMENDMENTS TO
SENATE BEFORE SEVENTY EIGHT. IT
IS A VERY SOLID AMENDMENTS AND
IT'S- A ROBUST BILL IN A TINY
TIGHTENED UP AND SO WE REALLY.
PLEASE SHARE YOUR WORK WITH US
TO MAKE IT A STRONGER AND
BETTER BILL- SO COLLEAGUES SB
FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT IS ONE OF
THOSE VERY- TECHNICAL AND WONKY
BILLS SITES ALSO- IMPACTFUL- IT
HAS TO DO WITH FLOOR AREA RATIO
WHICH IS ABOUT. A SQUARE
FOOTAGE COPS- THAT ARE PLACED
ON BY CITIES FROM TIME TO TIME-
AND ALSO PARCEL SIZES. AND
REALLY WHAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT-
IS FUNDAMENTALLY MAKING SURE
THAT WHEN A CITY IS SUPPLIES TO
SMALL MULTI UNIT BETWEEN THREE
AND TEN YEAR NOTES. MAKING SURE
THAT WHEN THE CITY HAS LOCALLY
ZONES. FOR THREE TO TEN UNITS
SO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ONE OF
CITY HAS MADE A DECISION THAT A
LOT IS ZONED FOR SOMEWHERE
BETWEEN THREE AND TEN UNITS.
THAT PEOPLE ARE ACTUALLY ABLE
TO BUILD. THOSE THREE TO TEN
UNITS- AND THAT- AND THAT
SQUARE FOOTAGE REQUIREMENTS I
DO NOT. TAKE WITH ONE HAND WHAT
HAS BEEN GIVEN WHAT THE OTHER
THIS IS FUNDAMENTALLY ABOUT
SUSAN SHARING THAT WHEN THE
CITY HS ZONES. FOR THREE TO
TEN UNITS THAT YOU CAN ACTUALLY
BUILD THREE TO TEN UNITS- THERE
ARE SOME VERY RESTRICTIVE
SQUARE FOOTAGE CALLED FLOOR
AREA RATIO F. A. R.
REQUIREMENTS. THAT ARE SO
RESTRICTIVE BETTER CITY SAY
ZONES A LOT FOR SIX UNITS IN
THEIR GENERAL PLAN AND ZONING.
BUT IT IS PHYSICALLY IMPOSSIBLE
TO BUILD. ANYWHERE CLOSE TO SIX
UNITS BECAUSE OF THOSE OTHER.
REQUIREMENTS THIS BILL DOES NOT
WANT TO BE CLEAR. THIS BILL
DOES NOT. LOCAL ZONING WHATEVER
THE CITY HAS OWNED FOR THREE
FOUR FIVE SEVEN UNITS TEN
UNITS. THAT WILL APPLY WE DON'T
CHANGE IT ANYWAY IT DOES NOT
CHANGE THE APPROVAL PROCESS. IN
ANY WAY IT DOES NOT CHANGE THE
HEIGHT LIMITS OR THE SETBACKS
IT IS NOT CHANGED DESIGN
STANDARDS- IT IS LIMITED TO
JUST MAKING SURE. THAT PEOPLE
CAN BUILD WHAT A CITY HAS LOCAL
HE SAID YOU CAN BUILD IN TERMS
OF THE NUMBER. OF UNITS. AND
SO- THAT THAT'S THE BILL-
INSURER IT DOES NOT AFFECT
SINGLE FAMILY ZONES IN ANYWAY
IT TARTS. WHERE THIS IT'S IT
STARTS IN AREAS WHERE THE CITY
HAS OWN FOR THREE UNITS ARE
MORE. SO SINGLE FAMILY ZONES
ARE NOT IMPACTED IN ADDITION
RURAL AGRICULTURAL AREAS. ARE
NOT IMPACTED IN ANY WAY THIS IS
ABOUT URBANIZED. AREAS THAT
HAVE BEEN ZONED ALREADY LOCALLY
OFFER MULTI. UNIT SO COLLEAGUES
I APPRECIATE YOUR- YOUR TIME.
WE SHOULD THE COMMITTEES WERE
WITH US AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY HOUSE FOR AN IPO-
WITH ME TODAY ARE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM OUR TO.
OUR SPONSORS OF THE RESTAURANT
TODAY WITH CALIFORNIA YIMBY AND
MICHAEL LANE- FROM SPUR. THANK
YOU SO MUCH CENTER WIENER ALL
RIGHT LAYS IN GERMAN WE'RE
GONNA GO TOWARD LEAD IT
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT WE'RE GONNA START
WITH LUCENT MERON DAY FROM
CALIFORNIAN B. LEWIS WE WELCOME
YOU TO COMMITTEE YOU HAVE THREE
MINUTES. IN THE FLOOR IS YOURS
SIR YOU'RE NOW LIVE. A GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
LEWIS BONTA ã LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FOR CALIFORNIA IN THE-
FIRST REALLY WANT TO THANK YOU
CENTER REQUIRE AND OF THE
COMMITTEE STAFF. FOCUSED
ATTENTION TO DETAIL AND
PROPAGATE RENT AND REALLY HARD
TO SPENDING A LOT OF TIME WITH
US ON THIS BILL- GOOD OUT THERE
WE ARE MENTIONED THE COR BUT
BEFORE SEVENTY EIGHT IS A
REFLECTION OF CALIFORNIAN BEES
AND JUST. WELL BROAD GROUP OF
ORGANIZATIONS COMMITMENT TO
RESOLVING CALIFORNIA'S
HISTORIC. THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION HOMES SHORTAGE THE
TOOLBOX THAT HAS MANY TOOLS IN
IT. A PROMINENT PROMINENTLY
AMONG THEM THE TOOL OF MISSING
MIDDLE HOUSING. UNDER THE
MIDDLE HOUSING OFTEN REFERRED
TO AS FOR FACT IS. AN EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT TYPE OF HOUSING THAT
OFFERS SOME OF THE MOST
NATURALLY AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
CALIFORNIA CITIES TODAY.
RESEARCH RESEARCH RESEARCH FROM
THE UC BERKELEY BERKELEY TURNER
CENTER- FIND LOW PERMISSIBLE AT
A ARTS AND HIGH LOT SIZE
REQUIREMENTS INCREASE THE COST
OF THAT MISSING MIDDLE HOUSING-
WHICH AT THE UPPER. SEVENTY
EIGHT- WILL HOPEFULLY REFORM.
OPTIMISING MIDDLE. I WOULD
OFTEN THAT IS NOT PROPERLY
ENOUGH TO HOW. A BIG. LAW
DISPATCH IMPORT TO MAKE THAT WE
ARE GETTING. RULES LIKE THIS
RIGHT- SO THAT WHERE CITIES
PLAN FOR THE HOUSING WE CAN
ACTUALLY REASONABLY EXPECTED
TO. COME INTO EXISTENCE. I
THINK BETTER WE ARE DID A VERY
CAPABLE JOB DESCRIBING THE BILL
BUT I'D BE HAPPY TO HELP WITH
ANY QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE
MIGHT HAVE. AGAIN WOULD RUN
THEY WOULD CALIFORNIA BE HERE
URGE YOUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR SB
FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH IS RIDING WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY WE'RE
NOT GONNA GO TO MICHAEL LANE
MICHAEL LANE IS WHISPER YOU
HAVE THREE MINUTES SIR I'LL
GIVE YOU A THIRTY SECOND PROMPT.
YOU ARE NOW LINING COMMITTEE
GOOD AFTERNOON. GOOD AFTERNOON
YOU'RE MCGUIRE MEMBERS MICHAEL
AND THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA
PLANNING IN URBAN RESEARCH
ASSOCIATION. A PUBLIC POLICY
THINK TANK KNOWN AS FOR. FIFTY
FOUR SEVENTY AGREED WITH THE
CALL THE TRUTH AND DOWNING-ACTS. BECAUSE IT WILL REQUIRE
THE WHAT THE ZONING ALLOWS IS
ACTUALLY WHAT CAN BE BUILT ON A
LOT. UNFORTUNATELY LOW F. A.
ARE IN HIGH MINIMUM LOT SIZES
CAN VITIATE ZONING AND
UNDERMINE MODEST COMPACT. AND
SUSTAINABLE INFILL. DEVELOPMENT
AND JUST THREE TO TEN UNITS.
OUR PROFESSIONAL ARE AND
PLANNERS INSIST THE DETAILS
MATTER. NEIGHBORHOOD MULTI
FAMILY ZONING IS NECESSARY BUT
NOT SUFFICIENT TO DELIVER
MISSING MIDDLE HOUSING. IS MORE
AFFORDABLE BY DESIGN. AS BEFORE
SEVENTY EIGHT WILL PROVIDE MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR AFFORDABLE
MISSING MIDDLE HOUSING. AND WE
ARE DRIVING OF THE CENTER. SH
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER MAINLY
APPRECIATE THAT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE WE'RE NOT
GOING TO BE CHECKING IN TO SEE
IF WE HAVE ANYONE ELSE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. GOOD AFTERNOON SIR
AND THANK YOU FOR HANGING WITH
US DURING THE COMMITTEE TODAY.
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
ALEX TORRES WAS STRATEGIES
THREE SIXTY ON BEHALF OF THE
HOUSING ACTION COALITION IN
VERY STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A TAURUS
THANKS FOR BEING WITH US HERE
IN COMMITTEE WERE NOW GOING TO
BE GOING NOW TO. ROOM TWENTY
FORTY HEARING SEEN KNOWN IT IS
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR SEVENTY
EIGHT. WE'RE NOT GOING TO CHECK
IN ON OUR TELECONFERENCE WIND
WE'RE GOING TO ASK THE
MODERATOR META MODERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY
INDIVIDUAL. WHO IS IN SUPPORT
OF SB. FOUR IS SEVENTY EIGHT
NOW. THANK YOU IF YOU SUPPORT.
OF S. B. FOUR SEVEN EIGHT. MY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE
WILL GO LINE OF A. SEVENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRED MEMBERS OF
THE MATTER NOT A PUBLIC AFFAIRS
CALLING ON BEHALF OF HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA.
COUNSELED TMG PARTNERS IN THE
COMPUTER COALITION IS DRUNK
APART THANK YOU. YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR PHONE CALL LET'S GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOUR NEXT ONE WILL GO TO IS ONE
TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MISTER CHAIRMAN THIS IS BOB
NAYLOR REPRESENTING FEELS DEAD
AND COMPANY IN ORANGE COUNTY
BUSINESS STRONG SUPPORT OF THE-
CALIFORNIA YIMBY OBJECTIVES- IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF. SB FOUR
SEVEN EIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU
BOB LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU OF THE LINE
OF NINETY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
HENRY HOOKER. I LIVE IN SANTA
CRUZ AND I CALL AND
REPRESENTATIVES OF SANTA CRUZ
SENIOR. I'M INCLUDES ASKING
CLINTON TO QUOTE A BEST BEFORE
SEVENTY EIGHT THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR PHONE CALL
TODAY THAT'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. THANK YOU A LINE OF
NINETY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
I MEAN IN THE BEGINNING I AM IN
UNION CITY I MAKE YOU PAY FOR
EVERYONE AND I AM ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR SEVEN EIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PHONE CALL
TODAY NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU OF
A LINE OF ONE TWELVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I'M AN INSTRUCTOR
BURKE HIMSELF ASKING RESIDENTS
FOR RESPONSIBLE GROWTH AND WE
ARE STRONGLY COURT S. B. FOUR
SEVENTY THANKS FOR MUCH THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PHONE CALL NEXT
CALLER. THANK YOU WITH A LINE
OF ONE TWENTY. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN YES. GOOD AFTERNOON
INSURANCE MAY MEMBERS MY NAME
IS JORDAN CRIMES I MAY
RECOMMEND OF THE CITY OF SAN
MATTEO AND SUCH THIRTEEN-
REPRESENTING HOUSING ADVOCACY
GROUPS AND SO FOR EVERYONE HERE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT THANKS SO MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PHONE CALL
TODAY NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU
WILL GO TO LINE OF ONE THIRTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AFTERNOON
KIMBERLY DONE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE
VERY GRATEFUL FOR YOUR PHONE
CALL NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU
WHAT A LINE OF ONE TWENTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEDICARE MEMBERS
BRIAN WHITE WHAT KßT PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF THE
MODULAR BUILDING INSTITUTE ALSO
IN SUPPORT THANKS BRIAN NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU WE
WILL GO LINE OF ONE EIGHTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS TOMMY ATLEE
I'M A RECENT COLLEGE GRAD
LIVING IN LOS ANGELES-
REPRESENTATIVE BY- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MIGUEL SANTIAGO AND
SENATE DISTRICT THREE AND I'M
IN STRONG SUPPORT SB FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT. CONGRATS THANKS
SO MUCH FOR CALLING IN LET'S GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU
WITH A LINE OF ONE TWENTY EIGHT.
HI MY NAME IS CAROLINE I'M
REPRESENT INTENDED FOR EVERYONE
LIVING AND HOW OFTEN THE SENATE
DISTRICT THIRTEEN AND I SUPPORT
WE SUPPORT AT THE POINT SEVEN
EIGHT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR PHONE
CALL NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU WILL COME FROM A LINE OF
ONE TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS FRANK
ONE OF THE POINTS FOR EVERYONE
FROM SENATE-DISTRICT TWENTY SIX
I'M CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT
SB FOR SOME OF THE- THANK YOU
SO MUCH THAT'S GOING TO OUR
NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU WILL GO
ONLINE OF ONE TWENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS A MAN WITH GENERATION
HOUSING BASED ON MY COUNTY ALSO
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF IT BEFORE
SOMETHING WAS GOOD ERASES
VOICING COMMITTEE THANK YOU
SINCE IT'S GOING TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. THANK YOU WILL GO ITEM
NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS LIKE PULLING WITH
THE ACTION AND YOU PLAY-
CALLING YOUR SUPPORTED THE S.
B. SEVEN EIGHT. FOUR SEVENTY
EIGHT. GOOD THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR PHONE CALL LET'S GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU WILL
GO A LOT OF ONE THIRTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
ARIANNA CALLING FROM OAKLAND
WITH EAST BAY FOR EVERYONE
CALLING IN SUPPORT. THANKS VERY
APPRECIATE THE PHONE CALL LET'S
GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER. I'M
EXCITED THAT NINETY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WHY NINETY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LET'S GO TO
NEXT ALL OUR MONEY IN A
MODERATOR. AT ONE THIRTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON- THIS IS A PROBLEM ON
A COLD SANTA CRUZ- CALLING ON
BEHALF OF INDIAN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANKS FOR CALLING IN FROM
SANTA CRUZ IT'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. THANK YOU ONE SIXTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
ANDREA HAD STRONG AND I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF A SPEAKS
FOR SEVENTY EIGHT. I HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF ATTENDING A
HOUSING CONFERENCE WITH SENATOR
WIENER A LITTLE OVER A YEAR AGO
AT THE MASONIC TEMPLE. ANISUR
SOMETHING HE SEEMS TO KNOW A
LOT ABOUT ITS HOUSING THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH APPRECIATE
THE PHONE CALL LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORT QUEUE
AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT WE
APPRECIATE A META MODERATORS
AND BE BACK WITH YOU HERE IN
JUST A MOMENT WE'RE NOW GOING
TO GO TO THOSE WHO MAY BE
OPPOSED TO SP FOUR SEVENTY
EIGHT. BUT WE CURRENTLY DO NOT
HAVE A LEAD. OPPOSITION
WITNESS. ON FILE HERE TODAY. SO
WE'RE GOING TO SEE IF WE HAVE
ANY INDIVIDUALS WHO WOULD LIKE
TO BE TO SPEAK AT. OPPOSED TO
THE BILL AT THIS TIME IN THE
HEARING ROOM WE DO NOT SEE ANY.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. CHECKING IN ON
ROOM TWENTY FORTY WE DO NOT
HAVE ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY PREPARED TO BE ABLE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. WE'RE NOT
GOING TO GO BACK TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE. MADAM
MODERATOR IF YOU WANT TO QUEUE
UP ANY INDIVIDUAL. WHO WOULD
LIKE TO GO TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR SEVENTY
EIGHT. PLEASE DO SO NOW. THANK
YOU IF YOU WERE IN OPPOSITION
OF SB. FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
ONE AND THEN ZERO OF YOUR IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. OR. SEVENTY
EIGHT. ONE MOMENT WHILE WE
GATHER NUMBER ALL RIGHT AS WE
ARE WAITING FOR THE MODERATOR
WE WANT TO REMIND FOLKS IF
YOU'D LIKE TO GET A JOIN US IN
COMMITTEE TODAY IN CALLING IN
ON ANY OF THE BILLS.
1-844-291-6364 IS OUR NUMBER
THAT CODE IS. SEVEN THREE SIX
TWO EIGHT THREE TWO MADAME
MODERATOR LET'S CHECK IN ON OUR
OPPOSITION CALLERS TO SB FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT. THANK YOU WITH A
LINE OF A- ONE FORTY TO YOUR
LINES OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MY NAME IS- DR HOLLY
OSBORNE A REGISTERED
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEER IN
CALIFORNIA AND I'M ALSO A
MEMBER UNITED NEIGHBORS. AND
I'VE BEEN WATCHING THIS BILL
BECAUSE UP UNTIL OF. THANK YOU
HOURS AGO IT WAS STILL BLANK ON
A TWO MOST IMPORTANT PARAMETERS
AND YOU CAN JUST FILL THE MAN
OVER THERE SAID YOU FEEL THE
MAN BUT I DON'T KNOW WHATTHEY
ARE AND I WANTED TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL AND THE
FACT THAT IT WASN'T EVEN. READY
IT IS I DON'T UNDERSTAND OF ALL
THESE PEOPLE CAN SO ARDENTLY
SUPPORTED WHEN THEY CAN'T
POSSIBLY KNOW WHAT WAS IN IT
AND I DO NOT THINK THE BILL WAS
READY TO BE PRESENTED TODAY.
THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PHONE CALL WE'LL TALK AGAIN
ABOUT THAT IN JUST A FEW
MOMENTS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PHONE CALL WE APPRECIATE YOU
CALLING IN LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER MATT A MODERATOR. THANK
YOU WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND A MODERATOR AND I DO
APPRECIATE THAT THE CONCERN
THAT WAS JUST EXPRESSED- AND-
LOOK. HERE'S WHERE WE'VE BEEN
WE'VE BEEN IN. DISCUSSIONS IN
ACTIVE DISCUSSIONS FOR THE
LAST. COUPLE WEEKS NOW AND OUT
WORKING OUT THE DETAILS OF THIS
BILL- AND- IT IS INCREDIBLY
COMMON. HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE BILLS- THAT
ERROR OF BEING AMENDED. COMING
INTO COMMITTEE- AND WE
PRESENTED TO EACH OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WITH AN
AMENDMENT SHEET THAT IS.
CURRENTLY IN FRONT OF US.
HIGHLIGHTING EACH OF THE
AMENDMENTS. HERE YEAH AND IT'S
PRESENTED WITH THE SENATOR. SO
LET'S TURN IT OVER TO THE
MAJORITY LEADER MR MAJORITY
LEADER DID YOU WANT TO SAY A
FEW WORDS. ON SB FOUR SEVENTY
PLEASE HAVE SOME QUESTIONS FOR
THE AUTHOR. BECAUSE LAST NIGHT
I WAS A HARD NO ON THIS BILL
AND THIS WAS JUST EXPRESSED.
BECAUSE OF THESE AMENDMENTS
WHICH I WANT TO BE CLEAR ON. IF
I COULD JUST TAKE A MOMENT SIR
BUT WITH RESPECT TO THAT AND I
YOU CAN EXPRESSED IT BUT I WANT
TO. PERSONALLY MASS THOSE
QUESTIONS IF IT'S OKAY WITH YOU
THANK YOU SIR FIRST. THIS
MEASURE DOES NOT APPLY TO
SINGLE FAMILY- REPRESENTING
CORRECT THAT'S CORRECT SECOND
TO DOES NOT APPLY TO DO SUPER
DUPLEX OWNING IS THAT CORRECT
THAT'S CORRECT THIRDLY IT
INCLUDES THE HISTORIC. WHAT
OVERLAYS OWNS INTERESTS IN IN
EXEMPTS THOSE ARE CORRECT
THAT'S ORRECT OKAY AND- SO IT
REALLY IS A- THIS NOTION AS YOU
EXPLAIN TRUTH IN ZONING SO THAT
HARMONIZES. THE ZONING OF AREAS
THAT THAT ARE MULTI FAMILY HAVE
THREE TO TEN BUT THAT THE FAA
ARE THE- FLOOR AREA-
REQUIREMENTS WOULD IT YOU KNOW
THE IT TO HARMONIZE IS THAT IS
WHAT WE'RE REALLY DOING IS THAT
CORRECT. THAT'S CORRECT AND YOU
HAVE AN OPINION OR ANY THE
EXPERTS YOU CONSULTED WITH HAVE
AN OPINION. IS WHAT IMPACT THEY
THINK THIS MIGHT HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY
THE OBJECTIVE HERE. IS TO
INCREASE HOUSING RIGHT THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE ALL TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH IS THERE ANY SENSE
THAT YOU HAVE FROM ALL THE
HOMEWORK THAT YOU'VE DONE OVER
THE YEARS AND THE HOUSING
SPACE. AS TO JUSTIN. MY DAD
USED TO SAY EYEBROW TEST WHAT
DO YOU THINK IMPACT THIS MIGHT
HAVE I MEAN I THINK IT WHAT IT
WILL DO. SO IF YOU LOOK THE
TURNER CENTER HAS ACTUALLY DONE
SOME REALLY GOOD WORK. ON
COMPILING F. A. R. REQUIREMENTS
AROUND THE STATE THERE CITIES
THAT DON'T HAVE A FOR YOUR
REQUIREMENTS AT ALL THERE
CITIES THAT HAVE- YOU KNOW. I
FOR YOUR REQUIREMENTS ALONG THE
LINES OF WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING
AND INNER CITIES THAT HAVE
LOWER F. A. OURS THE WHAT IT'LL
DO IS IT'LL SO WE REQUIRE
CITIES TO DO HOUSING ELEMENTS.
THAT SAY WHERE THE MULTI UNIT
IS WHAT'S GOING TO GET BILL
WHERE WHAT IT WILL DO IS I MEAN
THAT THAT HOUSING ELEMENT WILL
HAVE MEANING. THAT WHEN THEY
SAY THAT THE ZONE FOR ACCIDENT
REALLY MEANS I ALSO WILL HAVE A
REAL IMPACT THIS ISN'T LIKE A
TIDAL WAVE BUILDS OR ANYTHING
LIKE THAT. BUT IT WILL. ENABLE
A NUMBER OF THESE SMALLER
PROJECTS TO ACTUALLY GET THOUGH
THIS IS JUST ONE. ELEMENT RIGHT
THERE ARE OTHER THANK YOU KNOW
ISSUES THAT THE BILL DOESN'T
DEAL WITH BUT IT'S ONE AREA
THAT WILL MAKE THESE ZONES
PLANS. HOUSING PLANS ACTUALLY
MEANINGFUL BUT MR CUSTOMER
QUICK QUESTION. LIESER FLOOR
ERROR RATIO. WE DO. THE FOR
THREE SO UNITS TO ONE OCHRE
CORRECT. AND THE FLOOR AREA
RATIOS REDUCED ONE POINT TWO
FIVE H. TEN USE THAT CORRECT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THANK YOU MR THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR SURGERY LEADER APPRECIATE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO GO TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS COMMENTS PLEASE
CENTER PROJECT BUT BEFORE YOU
DECIDE LIKE MR ON A FIVE. WHAT
IF I WANT AND I JUST WANT TO
TELL YOU. LOOK I JUST SOUNDS
GOOD TO ME I JUST IF I COULD IS
ADAM RESPECT I'M TO VOTE FOR
THIS TODAY. TO KEEP THIS MOVING
BUT I JUST WANT TO RESERVE THE
RIGHT TO REVIEW THE DETAILS AS
THIS. CAME IN THE LAST MINUTE
AND WE'RE TRYING TO GO THROUGH
IT TO MAKE SURE IT DOESN'T WE
THINK IT DOES SO I WILL.
ACCOMMODATE THE- AUTHOR TODAY
BUT I RESERVE THE RIGHT IS IT
REALLY GETS TO THE FLOOR. TO
CHANGE MY OPINION. DEPENDING
UPON THE DETAILS AS I. REVIEW
THE STUFF I THINK IT'LL BE OKAY
BUT I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE I
GOT IT RIGHT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SANTA ROSA. THANK YU-
FIRST I DO WANT TO. ACKNOWLEDGE
AND THANK THE AUTHOR. OF FOR
CONTINUING TO MEET AND TO
ADDRESS THESE. THESE ISSUES I
KNOW THIS IS A- AN AREA OF
EXPERTISE FOR YOU- SO I- I
STILL HAVE SOME OUTSTANDING
CONCERNS YOU AND I WILL
CONTINUE TO TALK ABOUT IT
THAT'S WHAT YOU'VE TOLD ME-
INDIVIDUALLY- BUT I WANT TO LAY
OUT HERE- FOR FOLKS TO
UNDERSTAND WHERE I'M COMING
FROM. A AND MY DISTRICT IN IN
LOS ANGELES WHICH IS NORTHEAST
LA EAST LA BOYLE HEIGHTS- MY
DISTRICT 77% OF THE RESIDENTS
RENT. THAT'S MORE THAN ANY
OTHER ARM DISTRICT IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA 77% MY CONCERN
IS- AND WE HAVE TO FIND A WAY
TO ADDRESS THIS IS ONLY MAKE
CHANGES LIKE THIS. IN MY
DISTRICT WHERE THERE'S
OVERCROWDED- IT'S OVERCROWDING
NOT JUST FROM IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD BUT THERE'S IT'S
ALSO OVERCROWDING INSIDE. THE
DWELLINGS THE APARTMENTS- AND
WHAT THIS PRESENTS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY- FOR FOLKS TO COME
ALONG. BY DEMOLISH DISPLAYS-
BECAUSE THEY'LL BE ABLE TO MAKE
A HUGE PROFIT FROM IT AND SO
THIS IS THE CONCERN THAT I
CARRY ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNITY- AND IBM I'M GRATEFUL
THAT THE AUTHORS SAID HE WOULD
CONTINUE TO MEET WITH THIS- I
DON'T HAVE SPECIFIC. LANGUAGE
TO ADDRESS THAT- BUT I'M SURE
WE COULD COME UP WITH IT SO I'M
GOING TO SUPPORT TODAY-
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE YOU. CHAU
ALWAYS SHOW THE WILLINGNESS TO
SIT DOWN AND TALK- BUT- I TO
I'M LOOKING FOR A SOLUTION FOR
THAT BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT THIS EVERY TIME A HOUSING
BILL COMES UP- AND I WANT TO
MAKE SURE. JUST AS YOU BIG THEN
EXEMPTED DUPLEXES EXEMPTED A
LOCAL HISTORIC DISTRICTS IT'S
LIMITED TO URBANIZED AND URBAN
CLUSTERS NO RURAL I MEAN
THERE'S ALL THESE. EXEMPTIONS
AND IT GETS TIGHTER AND TIGHTER
INTO CERTAIN AREAS SO. THOSE
ARE MY CONCERNS AND I'M I'M
GLAD WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO
TALK THANK YOU- FROM AMATEUR
RESPOND THANK YOU CENTER THERE
ARE SERVER THAT OF COURSE WE I
LOOK FORWARD TO CHATTING A
COUPLE OF THINGS WHEN WE SAY
THE URBANIZED AREAS URBAN
CLUSTERS EVEN THOUGH YOU'RE
DISTRICT OF MY DISTRICT ARE
OBVIOUSLY. VERY URBAN IT'S WELL
BEYOND THAT I MEAN IT'S A IT'S
SUBURBAN AREA IT'S BIG SWATHS
OF THE STATE WHICH DOES. NOT
MAKE CLEAR THAT LIKE RURAL
AGRICULTURAL AREAS OR NOT-
INCLUDED- AND IN TERMS THIS
PLACEMENT JUST TO BE CLEAR-
THIS BILL THE AS USUAL A LOT OF
TIMES WHEN WE TALK ABOUT-
DISPLACEMENT APPEAR
DISPLACEMENT. IT'S ABOUT ONE
AREA IS BEING REZONED SO IT'S
NOW IT'S OWN FOR TWO UNITS WERE
GOING TO CHANGE THAT TO TWENTY
UNITS WRITES OR CREATES
INCENTIVES TO. REDEVELOP WAR WE
STREAMLINE THE APPROVAL PROCESS
SO IT DOESN'T HAVE TO GO
THROUGH. SEQUEL ANYMORE BOB AND
IN THE BILL THAT I'VE AUTHORED
THAT DO THAT THE CHANGES OWNING
OR THAT EXPEDITE THE APPROVAL
PROCESS I ALWAYS INCLUDE ANTI
DEMOLITION. PROTECTIONS IN
THERE WE CAN ALWAYS HAVE A
DISCUSSION ABOUT WHAT THE SCOPE
OF THOSE SHOULD BE BUT TO ME
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT I DON'T
WANT BILLS THAT I AUTHOR. TO
LEAD TO DISPLACEMENT OF PEOPLE
AND KNOCKING DOWN OF SOUND
HOUSING THE PEOPLE WERE LIVING
IN OUR PEOPLE GET EVICTED AND
THEN A YEAR LATER THEY-
DEMOLISH IT. ON SOME VERY
MINDFUL OF THAT- BUT THE EASIER
THIS BILL- I GET IT ALL IT DOES
IS SAYS IF THE ZONING IS
ALREADY IN PLACE. BENTOS HONOR
THAT'S OWNING AND IT DOESN'T
IMPROVE PROJECT AT ALL SO- BUT
WITH THAT SAID I DO LOOK
FORWARD TO SITTING DOWN WITH
YOU BECAUSE I THINK YOU AND I
HAVE A SHARED GOAL. BUT SAYING
THAT NEW HOUSING SHOULD BE.
ADDITIVE TO WHAT'S ALREADY
THERE AND NOT REPLACING THE
RESIDENTS ALREADY LIVING THERE
THAT'S NOT THE GOAL THAT I HAVE
AND. I KNOW IT'S NOT TO GO TO
YOUR HOUSE OR THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH TO DRAWS. ALL
RIGHT. JENNA COMMITTEE WE EVER
HEARD FROM A COUPLE OF OUR
MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO BE TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS OTHERWISE
WOULD LIKE TO BE TO SEE. ARE WE
WERE MOTION BY. THE MISTER
MAJORITY LEADER IN THANK YOU SO
MUCH AGAIN CENTER WIENER THANK
YOU FOR THE CONTINUED
COLLABORATION KNOW THAT WE HAVE
A LOT MORE WORK IN FRONT OF US
AND MANY MORE ISSUES- AND
ALWAYS ENJOY WORKING DE SER
WILL TURN IT OVER TO YOU FOR A
FINAL WORDS IN A CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH SOONER
WIENER ALRIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION
ON THE FLOOR EMOTIONAL FLOOR BY
MAJORITY LEADER HERTZBERG WE'RE
NOW RIGHT WE'RE NOW GOING TO
TURN IT OVER TO MR NOW FOR THE
FORMAL MOTION. AND. CALL THE
MOST IS TO PASS AS A MAN. BUT
FIRST AMEND AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HOUSING. SENATOR
MCGUIRE BY. WIRE HI SENATOR
NIELSEN. NIELSEN NOW SENATOR
DORADO DORADO HI SENATOR
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG BY SENATOR
WIENER RIGHT WIENER HI FORTY
ONE THAT'S FOR ONE VOTE LAYS IN
GERMAN THAT BILL IS OUT WE'RE
CLOSING THE ROLE SO I THANK YOU
SO MUCH BILLS OUT CLOSE THE
ROLE HONESTY FOR SEVENTY EIGHT.
ALRIGHT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IT
IS THE SENATOR SCOTT WIENER
SHOWN HERE- WE'RE GONNA BE
GOING TO- I DOUBLE HEADERS
WHICH IS NOW S. B. SIX
SEVENTEEN ITEM THIRTEEN. WE ARE
CURRENTLY PASSING OUT
AMENDMENTS WE WANTED YOU FOR
THIS. WE'RE GONNA BE PASSING
OUT THE MAIN ON AS SIX SEVEN.
THE AMENDMENTS IN FRONT OF US
HAVE BEEN NEGOTIATED I'M GOING
TO GO THROUGH THEM VERBALLY
SAID THAT JUST KEEP ROLLING AND
THAT'S OKAY ISN'T THAT GOOD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AT CITIES OF
FANTASTIC SEARCHING OUT HERE IN
THE SENATE SO HERE ARE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE IN FRONT OF
THE COMMITTEE TODAY. RESERVE
REVISE THE EXEMPTION IN THE
BILL TO COVER COUNTIES WITH.
LESS THAN A HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND POPULATION IN ALL
CITIES WITHIN THOSE COUNTIES
INSTEAD OF ONLY CITIES AND
LESS THAN TEN THOUSAND INCREASE
SHOULD THE WORK. THAT HAS GONE
INTO THAT CLARIFY THAT IN IN
PERSON INSPECTION CAN BE
REQUIRED IF THE INSPECTOR
CANNOT VERIFY COMPLIANCE BY
REMOTE MEANS NUMBER THREE.
PROVIDE THAT NOTHING INCREASES
OR AFFECTS LOCAL GOVERNMENT
LIABILITY THERE IS ALSO SEVERAL
TECHNICAL CHANGES IN THERE IN
THE UNITED CENTER WIENER
OUTSIDE OF THE COMMITTEE HAS
ALSO BEEN WORKING ON ADDITIONAL
AMENDMENTS WITH SOME ADDITIONAL
GROUPS ON OR TURN IT OVER TO
CENTER WIENER TO PRESENT THE
BILL. INTO DISCUSS THOSE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR CHAIRMAN AGAIN THANK YOU SEE
YOU IN A GREAT FOR WORKING WITH
US AND I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS- IN
ADDITION- WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
DILIGENTLY. WITH IDW AND SOME
OF THE OTHER- OPPONENTS- ONE
AMENDMENTS AND I- WE HAVE- I
THINK ESSENTIALLY HAVE AN
AGREEMENT ALTHOUGH WE'RE STILL
WORKING ON TO SOME VERY
TECHNICAL- ASPECTS OF IT THE
MOST IMPRESSIVE UNIFICATION ASK
FOR THE AGREEMENT. IS WE'VE
AGREED- TO REMOVE- THE VIRTUAL
READING OR RELAXING OR VIRTUAL
REMOTE INSPECTION PIECE FROM
THE BILL ENTIRELY SO THE BILL
WOULD BE FOCUSED ON- THE- BASED
ON- ON AUTOMATIC- OR AUTOMATIC
BUT ONLINE. PERMITTING AND WE
WILL BE ROOM. THE REMOTE AND-
PIECE THERE ARE OTHER ASK. OF
AMANDA THAT WE- BEEN WORKING
WITH ON WATCH HIS CLIMB ON- AND
I THINK CAN AGAIN IS HOT- SOME.
DETAILS TO FINALIZE BUT I- MR
WATCHING HIS CLIENTS WORKING
CONTINUE TO FINALIZE THE
LANGUAGE AND- AND THEN ON IT
WOULD I WOULD ANTICIPATE TAKING
THOSE AMENDMENTS- IN THE-
ENERGY COMMITTEE IN A FEW
WEEKS- IF. BILL PASSES OUT
TODAY. BY THE COLLEAGUES- THIS
IS PIECE SEVENTY- IS A BILL-
DESIGNED TO- TO OUR FACILITATE
THE PERMITTING OF- OF. THOSE OF
SMALL SOLAR AND ENERGY STORAGE-
INSTALLATIONS ON. RESIDENTIAL
ROOFTOP THIS ISN'T ABOUT LIKE
LARGE SCALE IS ABOUT SMALL
INSTALLATIONS. ON THIS
LEGISLATURE YEARS AGO PASSED
LEGISLATION TO STREAMLINE. THE
PERMITTING- BUT WE STILL HAVE
SITUATIONS WHERE IT CAN THE
PRINTING PROCESS CAN BE VERY
DELAYED FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS- WHICH INCREASE COSTS
FOR HOMEOWNERS AND JUST DELAYS.
THE INSTALLATION OF SYSTEMS
THAT ARE VERY IMPORTANT IN
TERMS OF. MEDIA CLEAN ENERGY
GOALS INCREASING RESILIENCY AS
WE LOOK FORWARD- TRAGICALLY TO
WHAT I HOPE WILL NOT BE ANOTHER
BAD WILD FIRE SEASON BUT- IT
PASSES PROLOGUE- YOU KNOW. WE
NEED TO BE. PREPARED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY THE U. S.
DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY AND
CONSULTATION WITH A WIDE ARRAY
OF STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING CODE-
CODE ORGAN. BUILDING CODE
ORGANIZATIONS AND SO FORTH- HAS
CREATED- AN OPTICAL SOLAR OP-
THAT. OUR CITIES CAN USE TO.
BASED ONLINE- EXPEDITED
PERMITTING- THIS OP BASED
ONLINE PERMITTING HAS SOME
CITIES ARE ALREADY ADOPTING IN
ADOPTED A LA- AS EITHER A
DOCTOR IS MOVING TOWARDS
ADOPTION OF ITS OWN VERSION.
BILLS IS NOT TO SAY YOU HAVE TO
USE A PARTICULAR APPLE THAT WE
ANTICIPATE PEOPLE. WILL
GENERALLY USE SOLAR OUT BECAUSE
US DEPARTMENT RG DID A GREAT
JOB. ON THIS OP THE OP IS FREE-
BUT WE ALSO HAVE IN THE BILL-
THERE'S A PARALLEL BUDGET. ITEM
THAT IS MOVING FORWARD TO
REPURPOSE AND SOLAR RELATED
FUNDING. TO THE CITY'S CAN
ACCESS GRANTS. TO DEFRAY ANY
COSTS THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
SETTING UP- THE PROGRAM. THERE
IS A SICK OUT TO DO THIS- AND
FRANKLY AS WE ALL SOMETIME
THERE'S INERTIA- AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL AND THERE MAY BE SOME
OFFICIALS THAT. WANT TODO IT
BUT THIS WILL BE A PUSH TO
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENT THE BILL
DOES NOT HAVE PENALTIES FOR NOT
DOING IT WE'RE NOT LOOKING TO
BE PUNITIVE. BUT THIS IS A PUSH
TO GET MORE CITIES- TO ACTUALLY
DO THIS AND WE THINK THAT- IT
WILL BE GOOD FOR CITIES ARE
STILL GOING TO GET THE SAME-
PERMIT FEES THAT THEY WOULD
HAVE GOTTEN WITH- THE CURRENT
WAY OF DOING THINGS- AND AS
THE- CITY OF SAN JOSE- LEARN
WHEN THEY IMPLEMENTED THIS.
THEIR PERMIT NUMBERS WENT UP BY
6100% SEVENTY MORE SOLAR. I'M
MORE PERMIT FEES. FOR THE CITY-
SO WE THINK THERE'S A GOOD STEP
FORWARD- FOR OUR CLIMATE GOALS-
AND FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
INTERESTED IN SOLAR AND ENERGY
STORAGE. I THINK I WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR I WANT TO THANK
GOD BY. MR WATCHING HIS CLIENTS
IN THE WHOLE GROUP FOR WORKING
TOGETHER. TO HAVE A BILL THAT I
THINK IS GOING TO BE VERY
IMPACTFUL I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE- AND WITH ME
TODAY TESTIFIED. PARTNER TO
SUPPORT TO THE CHIEF OF POLICY
APPS BURKE. AND RICHARD BURR
WHO IS THE FOUNDER OF SOLAR AND
FIRE EDUCATION SAFE. THANK YOU
SO MUCH IS CENTER WIENER AGAIN-
IS TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF
THE- AMENDMENTS THAT ARE IN
FRONT OF A CITY ARE IN FRONT OF
YOU ON THE PIECE OF PAPER
THAT'S BEEN HANDED OUT THE
SUBMITTAL- THERE ARE. TENDING
AND WOMEN SET WOULD BE TAKING-
IN THE NEXT COMMITTEE THE
ENERGY COMMITTEE AND I KNOW
WE'LL HEAR. FROM A WITNESS ON
THAT IS WELL SUITED TO GENERAL
LET'S GO TO OUR SUPPORT
WITNESSES LET'S START WITH
RICHARD BURTON HE'S THE FOUNDER
OF SOLAR IN FIRE EDUCATION. MR
BURKE YOU HAVE THREE MINUTES
I'LL GIVE YOU THIRTY SECOND
PROMPT YOU ARE NOW. LIVE IN
COMMITTEE PLEASE PROCEED. OKAY
YEAH OFTEN LEARN AND THANK YOU
FOR THE UP. TO VOTE MY STRAW
SUPPORT FOR S. B. SIX. BUT MANY
WHICH BOOK I'M A PROUD MEMBER
OF INTERNET ASSOCIATION OF
FIREFIGHTERS. AND I'VE BEEN A
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTER FOR
OVER THIRTY YEARS. I RETIRED IN
JANUARY OF THIS YEAR FOR
CONTINUE TWENTY FIVE FIRES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. MY SOUL ON
FIRE EDUCATION PROGRAM THAT I
DEVELOPED FOUR YEARS AGO HAS TO
OVER A THOUSAND FIREFIGHTERS IN
CALIFORNIA. I HAVE TWO ACCOUNTS
ONE LONG BEACH FIRE. SAN DIEGO
PASADENA FIRE RIVERSIDE
SACRAMENTO METROS BY. MANY
OTHER TO CALIFORNIA. MY SHAPE
PROGRAM TEACHES FIVE FIVE OTHER
STATES MEDICAID A RESIDENTIAL
STRUCTURE FIRE THAT INVOLVES
ONLY PANELS. AND ENERGY STORAGE
SYSTEMS. DIRECTIONAL SB SIX.
ONE NO I'M SORRY FIVE FIVE
DOLLARS BUT WILL ALSO SEND
CIVILIAN LIVES AND HIS WIFE. SB
SIX SEVENTEEN WELL IN HOPES
THAT WE READY. SAFETY THAT
CALIFORNIA A- THE UNIFORM AND-
HOUSE. ESPECIE SEVENTY. WE BE
CRITICAL TO FIRE. FOR IS TO
CALL MR ON AID MY TO THE-
EVERYBODY ON THE SAME PAGE IT
SAYS LIVES. SB SIX ALSO AND I
ONE COMES TO BUILD HAD. RISK
ASSESSMENT OF THAT CAN. SO THEY
CAN THE COW STRATEGY TACTICS ON
THE STABILIZE. FIREFIGHTERS.
CONCENTRATING THE S. B. SIX
WILL LOW COME ALSO IF. PART
FIVE. EDUCATION AND FOR LIVE
AND THERE'S WILL ENABLE GOT
STILL TRYING TO. AND SKILLS
NEEDED TO SEE. THE OF LIGHTS
SYSTEMS. SEWER BACK SAVES LIVES
SENATE BILL SIXTY SIX SEVENTEEN
WHEN THIS. OKAY TO LET WHAT
HAPPENED REPORT THEM. FROM
DEVASTATING POWER OUTAGE THE
AND LANGUAGE STATE. TO RAPIDLY
AND SAFELY IN A UNIFORM MANNER
BUT TRYING TO CONNECTIONS TO
SOLAR PNELS AND BATTERY
STORAGE SYSTEMS ON THE HOMES
WILL HAVE A DIRECT EFFECT NOT
ONLY ON PROTECTING THEIR LIVES
BUT THE LIVES OF MY FIREFIGHTER
BROTHERS AND SISTERS WHO
PROTECTED GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH HERTZBERG APPRECIATE
YOU CALLING IN TODAY WERE NOW
GOING TO BE GOING TO OUR NEXT
AND FINAL- WE DO SUPPORT
WITNESS IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
SEVENTEEN. AND THAT'S AND NICK
JUST. IT'S WE'RE GOING TO DO
NICK THE OF POLICY FOR SPUR WE
WELCOME AT NICK TO COMMITTEE
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR WE ALSO
APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THE TIME.
COMING INTO COMMITTEE TO BE
ABLE TO MEET WITH US NICK THE
FLOOR'S YOURS YOU HAVE THREE
MINUTES AND- YOU ARE NOW LIVE
IN COMMITTEE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH- JAMEK WIDENING JUST UP
WITH- FROM SPA AND I JUST
WANTED TO THANK YOU. AND YOU
COMMITTEE STOCK ON. WHAT COULD
NOT SORRY PRODUCTIVELY ON THE
BALLOT SPENT TIME ON IT AND-
ARE MADE BY BILLS ARE TAKING.
MUCH I ALSO WANT TO THANK. MR
WATCHING THE CLIENTS- AS WELL
I'M STORAGE COSPONSORING SB SIX
SEVENTEEN WITH ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA. BECAUSE WE HAVE
MORE WORK TO DO TO ADDRESS THE
CLIMATE CRISIS. THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION ESTIMATES FOR
CALIFORNIA WILL NEED TO TRIPLE
THE AMOUNT OF SO LET ME TALK A
GOOD PERCENT CANNELLA. CRITICAL
THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE WAY TO
EXCEL THE OF SOME OFF THE- TO
MAKE A QUICK AND SHE- TO.
SIMPLE THAT THE WE STOP SOME SO
POSTAL SYSTEMS. THERE IS A WAY
TO GO. DESPITE LEGISLATIVE
REFORMS THE SOFT COSTS MAKE
TYPICAL RESIDENTIAL ROOFTOP
SOLAR SYSTEM. I RECOMMEND
INDIRECTLY ASSOCIATED WITH
CHRONIC PAIN CAN BE SEVERAL.
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER TYPICAL
HOMEOWNER. MUCH OF THIS IS GOOD
BY THE PER. TIME OF HOW LONG IT
TAKES TO GET UPON. WHICH OF
STATE STUBBORNLY HIGH OVER THE
PROSPECT. THE SOLUTION THAT
WE'RE PROPOSING IS BUILT ON THE
CONTRACTED JURISDICTIONS LIKE
SAN JOSE LOS ANGELES AND SAN
LUIS OBISPO IN ORDER TO MAKE
THE PUBLIC IN POTENTIAL NEW TOP
SODA AND SODA PLUS STORAGE
SYSTEMS. SO ACCESS ACTTAKES
UPON THE LEFT OVER FROM THE NEW
HOMES SO THE PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAM THAT YOU'VE ALREADY
BEEN APPROPRIATED INCREASE
ACROSS PROGRAM FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO AUTOMATE SOME.
FUNDING WILL BE NON. ADMITTED
NOT EVERY COMPANY CITY AND
COUNTY TO RECEIVE THE GROWTH.
TO DECELERATE DEDUCTION OF
AUTOMATED PERMITTING THE
NATIONAL RENEWABLE ENERGY LAB
ABROAD TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS DEVELOPED A
THREE YOU KNOW TO SOFTBANK
WHICH SENATOR WIENER MENTIONED
COLD SO LOCAL TO MAKE IT PUBLIC
PROCESSING. THE STOCK WAS
DEVELOPED THE COUNTRY MISTRESS.
THE BUILDINGS YOU'RE GONNA.
INCLUDING THE INTERNATIONAL. OF
ELECTRIC INSPECTOR. THE
NATIONAL PIPER ASSOCIATION I
MEAN CONNECTS CULTURE. I THINK.
OVER A HUNDRED TWENTY DOLLARS.
CLIMB CHECK. ULTIMATELY LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ARE NEED TO BE
MADE I'M NOT TO USE THE- WHAT
SEVENTEEN CALIFORNIA AT THE
OPEN TO TAKE MADE STRIDES TO
POWERING ALLSTATE A HUNDRED
THAT. ADMITTED ADDITIONAL.
RESPECTFULLY LOOK DR ON THIS.
YOU SO MUCH YOUR ENGAGEMENT IN
ALL YOUR WORK SIR WE APPRECIATE
YOU BEING ARE THEY SAID THOSE
OUR TWO. LEAD WE IN SOME OF SIX
SEVENTEEN WE WANT TO ALSO
RECOGNIZE TAURUSES TAURUSES
BEEN SITTING WITH THIS FROM THE
VERY BEGINNING SERVICE SO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND FOR
HANGING WITH US TODAY THE FOR
YOUR SIR. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- ONCE AGAIN ALEX TORRES
WITH THE HOUSING ACTION
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
AGAIN THANKS FOR HANGING WITH
US THAT WE'RE GOING TO SEE IF
ANYONE ELSE IS GOING TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SIX SEVENTEEN IN
THE HEARING ROOM TODAY. XENON
ARE NOT GOING TO GO TO THE
LONELY I ROOM IT'S ROOM TWENTY
FORTY NO ONE IS THERE WE'RE NOT
GOING TO GO TOWARD
TELECONFERENCE LINE WE'RE GONNA
ASK THE MODERATOR TO PLEASE
QUEUE UP AT A MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE QUEUE UP. ALL IN SUPPORT
OF SB. SIX SEVENTEEN NOW. THANK
YOU AND IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF SB SIX SEVENTEEN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE
WILL GO TO LINE OF I. TWENTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OWNERS DON'T
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOLAR AND STORAGE
ASSOCIATION ENTHUSIASTIC
SUPPORT BASE GAME THINGS ARE
GONE IN FOR YOUR WORK THAT SAID
GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU A LOT OF THIRTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
SILVIO FERRARI ON BEHALF OF
SUNPOWER CORPORATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PHONE CALL LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER. THEY'LL COME FROM
ONE TWENTY SEVEN. MISTER JERRY
MEMBERS BUILDING AT THE LEAD TO
SHANTI HADN'T BEEN ABANDONED
ENERGY ECONOMY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH SYLVIA
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE TWENTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS LAUREN
CALLING ON BEHALF OF SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX SEVENTEEN
THANK YOU THANKS LAURA
APPRECIATE IT LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER. AND ONE FIFTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TURN MEMBERS
TELL HOW THAT WOULD END WITH
WIDENING GROUP ON BEHALF OF
NEXT IN CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PHONE CALL. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
ONE FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS KEVIN NOT
REPRESENTING FOR THE CANAL
YOU'D COME IN ACTION AND WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SIX
SENDING. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE'RE ABOUT TEN CALLERS
CENTER- IN THE QUEUE LET'S GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER. THIRD ONE
FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BURKE
NIKITA KARATE WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PHONE CALL NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WELCOME FROM A SEVENTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AFTERNOON AGAIN- JERRY MEMBERS
OF THE NOT IN ATLANTA PUBLIC
AFFAIRS CALLING ON BEHALF OF
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY GREATER
SAN FRANCISCO AS WELL HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU FOR BEING
WITH US TODAY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PHONE CALL NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI THIS IS LARA THE
HANDS CARE ACTOR ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA WHERE PRACTICAL
KENTUCKY SIX ONE SEVEN AND
CALLING ON THE COURT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PHONE CALL LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. THANK YOU ONE FIFTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FOR GOOD
AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MEMBERS
IGOR TRAVELED FOR MORE BUCKLEY
WENT PARK COMMISSIONER CURRENT
BARCLAYS OWNING PART
COMMISSIONERS IN INTO THE
AFFECTS APART THANKS ARE
APPRECIATED NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THAT'D BE ONE FIFTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI LILIAN MARCUS
WITH THE CENTER FOR SUSTAINABLE
ENERGY CALLING INTO COURT SB
SIX SEVENTEEN THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR PHONE CALL LET'S GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER. ONE FORTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CLEVELAND CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE DAIRY COUNCIL IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PHONE CALL MEMBERS WITH ABOUT
FIVE MORE IN THE QUEUE AT
THAT'S GOVERNOR'S CALLER PLEASE.
ONE FORTY FOUR YEAR. THEY HUNG
UP ONE FIFTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU JOURNAL WIRE
THIS IS KAREN BANKER WITH I'M
RUN EXPRESSING OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR SB ONE SIXTY SEVEN
THANK YOU FOR CHECKING IN TODAY
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER.
ONE FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AFTERNOON THIS IS AARON
SCHOCK CALLING FROM GRID
ALTERNATIVES AND I AM CALLING
MY ENTHUSIASTIC SUPPORT FOR SB
SIX SEVENTEEN THANKS LEARN NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU WITH A
LINE OF ONE FIFTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE CURRENT
MEMBERS DAN CHAU WITH TOUCH IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANKS DAN
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER.
THANK YOU THAT OF THE LINE OF
ONE SIXTY YEAR LINE IS OPEN.
JERRY MCGUIRE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THAT MURRAY FOR BAD CHECKS
SOLAR IN RANCHO CORDOVA
CALIFORNIA. DISTRIBUTED
GENERATION CONTRACTOR IN
SUPPORT. THANKS SO MUCH I THINK
SAID BRIGITTE THE PHONE CALL
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER.
THANK YOU AND WE HAVE NO MORE
FOR THE SUPPORT IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME BETTER MODERATOR NICE
JOB WE'RE GONNA BE BACK WITH
YOU IN JUST A FEW MOMENTS WERE
NOW GOING TO BE GOING TO THOSE
WITNESSES WHO MAY BE OPPOSED OR
IT WILL CONSIDER YOU IN THE
SQUISHY CATEGORY. WE DO SEE
THAT WE HAVE SOMEONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO BE TO SPEAK AT
POTENTIALLY IN THE SQUISHY
CATEGORY AND THAT'S MISTER
SCOTT WHICH I MISTER WHICH-
HELLO MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS SCOTT WHICH ON BEHALF
OF THE- CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS. THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION OF UTILITY EMPLOYEES.
I JUST KNOW THAT THE
ASSOCIATION ELECTRICAL WORKERS
REPRESENTS ELECTRICAL
INSPECTORS IN. MOST OF THE
LARGE JURISDICTIONS LIKE LOS
ANGELES INTO C. FRANCISCO. WE
HAVE SUSPENDED OUR OPPOSITION
IN SORT OF SUSPENDED ANIMATION
AS WE CONTINUE TO WORK OUT THE
LANGUAGE WITH SENATOR WIENER WE
APPRECIATE HIS EFFORTS AND THE
SPONSORS FILE I JUST LIKE TO
TELL THE COMMITTEE WHAT WE
BELIEVE HAS BEEN AGREED TO AND
WHERE WE BELIEVE THAT LANGUAGE
IS GOING SO THE INSPECTION
PORTIONS OF THE BILL I THINK
WILL BE REMOVED FROM THE BILL.
WE HAVE AGREED TO SUPPORT THE-
THE AUTOMATED PERMITTING
PROCESS FOR. RESIDENCES SINGLE
FAMILY RESIDENCES- WIN A
LICENSE CONTRACTOR HE IS
PULLING THE PERMIT RATHER THAN
JUST AND ITS OWNER. OWNER
BUILDER. AND AS LONG AS THE
SIZE RESTRICTIONS FOR THE PHOTO
WILL TAKE SYSTEM IN THE BATTERY
SYSTEMS ARE THOSE THAT ARE
CURRENTLY ALLOWED IN THE
RESIDENTIAL AND THE FIRE CODE
AND THEN FINALLY. PLUS THE
SPONSORS AND MYSELF HAVE AGREED
THAT WE SHOULD BE CREATING NEW
DEFINITIONS IN THIS IN THIS.
LEGISLATION THAT WE SHOULD USE
EXISTING DEFINITIONS. AND THAT
WOULDN'T THAT INCLUDE THE
DEFINITION OF A PHOTO OF A TAKE
SYSTEM AS IT CURRENTLY READS IN
THE CALIFORNIA. ELECTRICAL CODE
BUT YOU KNOW THE CALIFORNIA
ELECTRICAL CODE IS THE CODE
ADOPTED BY THE BUILDING
STANDARDS COMMISSION WHICH IS
THE OVER TO CODE THE THAT
GOVERNS IN CALIFORNIA SO WE
THINK WE CAN WORK OUT THE
DETAILS OF THIS LANGUAGE BEFORE
THE NEXT COMMITTEE HEARING AND
WITH THAT WE APPRECIATE
EVERYBODY'S EFFORTS THANK THANK
YOU SO MUCH ITS ORIGINAL
SINCERITY MISTER WHICH HAS
BEEN- IN GAUGING ON THIS- IT
CLEVERLY JUST WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO MR WHICH AND ADD TO ALL
THE HARD WORKING MEN WOMEN I.
D. W. OF ALSO. BEEN ENGAGING IS
WELL ALL RIGHT LAYS IN GERMAN
WE'RE GOING TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
BE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OR
POTENTIALLY A SQUISHY CATEGORY
AT THIS TIME IN THE HEARING
ROOM CARRYING SEEN NINE WERE
NOW GOING TO GO CHECK IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WE DON'T HAVE
ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO OUR
PHONE LINES ARE GONNA CHECK IN
WITH BETTER MODERATOR ONE FINAL
TIME FOR THIS AFTERNOON AND SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
SB. SIX SEVENTEEN MADAME
MODERATOR. THANK YOU YOU'RE NOT.
OF SIX SEVENTY. YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO NOW. AND WE
WILL GO TO LIGHT A ONE FIFTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE THIS IS
CHRISTY ABOUT MOM WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS. I JUST WISH
SIMPLY TO SAY THAT WE ARE
OPPOSED TO SB SIX SEVENTEEN BUT
SO APPRECIATE THE WORK. OF THE
CHAIRMAN HAS STAFF IN THE
OFFICER'S OFFICE AND THE-
SPONSORS OF THIS MEASURE AND
HEARING TODAY THE AMENDMENT TO
REMOVE. THE AUTOMATED
INSPECTION SO WE WILL LIKELY
REMEMBER OPPOSITION FROM
DIFFERENT EXPRESS THEIR THANKS
TO ALL. CHRISTY THANK YOU SOME
AS ALWAYS FOR I CHECK IN IN IN
APPRECIATE YOUR ENGAGEMENT AS
WELL ALL RIGHT LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
ONE SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. PARRAMATTA MARGARITA
THAT'S GOOD OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU I'LL COME
FROM A LINE OF THIRTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS
IS LAURA PARAVICINI CALIFORNIA
EDISON WE WILL REVIEW THE
AMENDMENT AND- RECONVENE
CURRENTLY WE HAVE AN OPPOSED.
POSITION BUT- WE WILL CONNECT
WITH THE AUTHOR AFTER REVIEW
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
SHE CON IN TODAY THAT'S GOING
TO OUR NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU
THAT ARE COME FROM LINE ONE
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN MIKE WEIR
BRENDAN IS PRETTY KERN SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING OFFICIALS- WE'VE BEEN
ENGAGED HEAVILY WITH THE AUTHOR
ON THE BILL AND THE SPONSORS ON
THE BILL- BECAME THREE DEMAND
AND STUFF BUT CURRENTLY WE ARE
STUCK. IN OPPOSE WE LOOK
FORWARD TO READING THE
AMENDMENTS AND LOOK FORWARD TO
DISCUSSING THOSE FOR THE FUTURE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR PHONE CALL
TODAY THAT'S GOING TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. THANK YOU COME FROM
MINE OF. ONE SIXTY FOUR. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS WHAT IT IS TO
USE WHAT THE CLIMATE CENTER I'M
ACTUALLY CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
SB SIX ONE SEVEN JUST DIDN'T
GET TO ON THE LINE QUICK ENOUGH
SO CALLING IN SUPPORT ON BEHALF
OF THE CLIMATE CENTER THANK YOU
I THINK YOU WOULD AGREE TO HEAR
VOICE SIR GIVE OUR BEST TO AND
LET'S GO TO THE- NEXT CALLER.
THANK YOU DON'T COME FROM A
LINE OF SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
JUST WANTED TO SAY WE THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR SOME OF THOSE
AMENDMENTS THIS IS ME NOW LEYVA
WITH THE CITY OF THOUSAND OAKS.
WE ARE STILL IN OPPOSITION
PENDING A REVIEW OF THE
AMENDMENT. THANK YOU SO MUCH WE
HAVE A COUPLE MORE FOLKS WERE
ON THE LINE WITH US HERE TODAY
IN OPPOSITION LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER AND THANK YOU FOR
THE PHONE CALL. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT WELL THERE WE
GO. H. WRITTEN UP A BIT THANK
YOU SO MUCH BETTER MODERATE A
REALLY GREAT JOB TO THE-
MODERATOR TODAY WE SO
APPRECIATE ALL YOUR WORK. ALL%
RIGHT. BASINGER WE'RE GONNA
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE TO
BE TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS. OR
MOTION PLEASE CENTER DRAWS OF
APARTMENTS- I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR. FOR WORKING OUT SOME OF
UP THROUGH THESE AMENDMENTS
AND- ASSUMING THAT THE IT GETS
FINALIZED WITH THE ELECTRICAL
WORKERS AND THE FIREFIGHTERS
AND I'M- PREPARED TO SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SOME. SIR
DRAWS ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
COMMENTS CONCERNS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. ALL RIGHT DO WE HAVE
A MOTION A MOTION ON SIX
SEVENTEEN. SO RIVER MOTION BY
CENTER DURAZO. CENTER WINNER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE ARE
QUESTIONABLE THANK YOU SO MUCH
SO WITH THE MOTION MY CENTER
DRAWS ON SIX SEVENTEEN WERE NOT
INJURED OVER TO MISTER NOW
MISTER FOR NOW IS GOING TO BE
READING A FORMAL MOTION AND IT
WILL BE CALLING THE ROLE MR
PRONOUNCE. MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
ENERGY UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATION. SENATOR MCGUIRE
BY WATER SENATOR NIELSEN. DATE
SENATOR DO. HI DRAWS HI
SENATORS BURKE ALL RIGHT
HERTZBERG HI SENATOR WIENER.
WIENER BY BORDER ZERO. ARE THAT
THE FOR YOUR VOTE LAYS DOWN
COMMITTEE WERE CLOSING AND THAT
OUT IN THE BILL IS CLOSE TO IT
SO THEY WERE CLOSE THE ROLE I
SHOULD SAY THANK YOU SO MUCH.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE
WHAT WOULD LIKE ME TO DO IS
WE'RE GONNA TAKE A TWO MINUTE
PAUSE I WANNA SAY THANK YOU TO
SENATOR ALSO IN CENTER WIENER
YOUR VOTE NOT YOUR VOTER AND
EVERYTHING IS ALL GOOD- THANK
YOU SO MUCH. YES YOU DO- IT
CENTER DRAWS ARE. YOU CAN
RESENT THAT- HERE TO. SIX POINT.
I THINK YOU SO MUCH. TO HE IS
TOLD IT HEARING I LOVE IT THANK
YOU SENATOR ALSO IN GIVE US A
JUST ECHO MINUTES GOING TO GET
OUR PAPERWORK IN ORDER AND
WE'RE GOING TO OPEN UP THE ROLE
FOR SENATOR CONCERNING ONE
MOMENT PLEASE.
ALL RIGHT LAYS
IN GERMAN WE'RE GONNA. HAVE THE
VICE CHAIR IN- THE MAJORITY
LEADER ADD ON WE'RE GONNA GO A
LITTLE OUT OF ORDER SO HERE WE
GO EVERYBODY IF YOUR PHONE AT
HOME FOR CERTAIN AT ITEM NUMBER
THREE ITEM NUMBER THREE SB
THREE NINETEEN THE CURRENT VOTE
IS THREE ZERO THREE ZERO. MR
NOW CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL SENATOR NIELSEN HI NIELSEN
SENATOR HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
FIVE FIVE ZERO FIVE ZERO VOTE
LAYS IN GERMAN BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT WE'RE CLOSING THE ROLE
THAT BILL IS OUT WE'RE GOING TO
SAY THANK YOU TO VICE CHAIR
NIELSEN HE IS NOW ON EVERY BILL
THANK YOU SO MUCH RESERVE RIGHT
HERE HAV A WONDERFUL WEEKEND
SIR. OKAY WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE
GOING TOWARD CONSENT CALENDAR
WE HAVE LINE ITEM ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR THAT'S ITEM
NUMBER TWO SB SEVENTY NINE THE
CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR ZERO
CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR ZERO ONE
SB SEVENTY NINE MR CANAL CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS PLEASE.
SENATOR HERTZBERG HI HERTZBERG
AT THE FIVE ZERO VOTE THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT FOR
CLOSING THE ROLE THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR NOW JUMPING BACK TO
ITEM NUMBER ONE THAT'S SB
TWENTY TWO GLAZER CURRENT VOTE
IS FOUR ZERO MR CANAL ABSENT
MEMBERS PLEASE BURGER HERTZBERG
BY. THIRTY FIVE ZERO VOTE THAT
BILL IS OUT WE'RE CLOSING THE
ROLE WE'RE NOW JUMPING AHEAD TO
ITEM NUMBER. FOUR WE'RE GOING
TO ITEM NUMBER FOUR. SB THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT CURRENT IS FOR
ZERO. NOW THE NEW RIVER. THIRTY
SORRY FIVE VOTE THAT BILL IS
THAT WE'RE CLOSE THE ROLE WE'RE
NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER
FIVE SB THREE NINETY FIVE. KERN
VOTE IS THREE ZERO WITH VICE
CHAIR NIELSEN NOT VOTING-
MISTER NOW. THE NEW NIELSEN.
SENATOR HERTZBERG AYE HERTZBERG
BY FOUR ZERO VOTE LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN THAT BILL IS OUT FOR
CLOSING THE ROLE ITEM NUMBER
SIX SB THREE NINETY EIGHT
CURRENT VOTE IS THREE ONE
MISTER GRINNELL. SENATOR
HERTZBERG. SEARCH BURKE ARE FOR
ONE VOTE THAT BILL IS THAT
WE'RE CLOSING THE ROLE ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN SP FOUR TWENTY.
FOUR TWENTY SEVEN KERN VOTE IS
FOUR ZERO MISTER NOW SENATOR
HERTZBERG AYE HERTZBERG BY
THINKING THAT BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT FIVE ZERO THAT DEAL IS
THAT WE'RE CLOSING THE ROLE
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SB FIVE SIXTY
THREE KERN VOTERS FOUR ZERO
MISTER NOW. SENATOR HERTZBERG.
HI HERTZBERG. FIVE ZERO DEAD IS
OUT WORK THE ROLE ITEM NUMBER
NINE IS D. FIVE SB SIX FIFTY
EIGHT ITEM NUMBER NINE SB SIX
FIFTY EIGHT. CURRENT VOTE IS
FOUR ZERO MISTER NOW SENATOR
HERTZBERG SUPERCAR FIVE ZERO
VOTE THAT BILL IS OUT WE'RE
CLOSING THE ROLE ITEM NUMBER
TEN KERN VOTE IS FOR A ZERO. ON
SB SEVEN NINETEEN THE SERRANO
IN ORDER HERTZBERG AYE
HERTZBERG FIVE THEY CAN ACT AS
MISTER MAJORITY LEADERS OUT A
ROLE THAT'S A FIVE ZERO VOTE
THAT DEAL IS THAT WE'RE CLOSE
THE ROLE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN.
CURRENT VOTE IS THREE ZERO ON
SB SEVEN EIGHTY MR CANAL
SENATOR MCGUIRE HI WIRE HI
SENATOR HERTZBERG. CHURCH BURKE
BY. HI ZERO VOTE BILL IS OUT
WE'RE THE ROLE. LAYS IN GERMAN
HAVE TO ITEM THAT WILL BE IN
FRONT OF NEXT WEEK- EXPECT
ABOUT A THREE HOUR. HEARING
POTENTIALLY THREE AND A HALF- I
WILL LET YOU KNOW APRIL TWENTY
SECOND AND MAY FIFTH BRING YOUR
CAMPING GEAR- BECAUSE WE'RE
GONNA BE HERE FOR A WHILE. SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH LAYS IN
GERMAN AT THIS EDITIO OF THE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE. IS NOW ADJOURNED.